[Musique]
la séance est reprise
mes chers collègues la Conférence des
Présidents s'est réunie pour examiner
les conditions
dans lesquels nous allons examiner ça
fait une répétition mais ça montre
l'importance de l'examen de la suite du
projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 après l'engagement de la procédure
de votre unique par le gouvernement en
application de l'article 44 alinéa 3 de
la Constitution
il a été rappelé que les auteurs
d'amendements
tous les amendements conservent la
possibilité de les présenter
par ailleurs les prises de parole sur
article sont possibles dans les
conditions déterminées par la Conférence
des Présidents lors de sa réunion du
mercredi 8 mars dernier
il a été indiqué au président de groupe
les motifs pour lesquels les sous
amendements transmis depuis l'annonce de
l'application de l'article 44 alinéa 3
par le gouvernement ne sont pas
recevables de même les deux notions de
renvoi en commission qui subsistent
tombent
la conférence a évoqué également et
rappel au règlement à l'appréciation
bien sûr du président de séance ils ne
vont pas constituer un détournement de
procédures par ailleurs la conférence je
crois que ça a été partagé à réaffirmer
que notre vivant ensemble c'est
notoriale ne doit pas nous autoriser ni
aux interpellations qui sont je le
rappelle
interdite par notre l'article 36 de
notre règlement comme on l'utilise
beaucoup je voudrais rappeler quelques
principes du vivre ensemble et à nous
filmer les uns les autres à notre insu
je rappelle que voilà je compte sur vous
pour assurer dans le respect des
convictions de chacun jusqu'à la fin de
nos débats la sérénité qui doit être la
marque de notre assemblée voilà les
conclusions mes chers collègues de la
Conférence des Présidents et nous allons
passer à l'examen des amendements quatre
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune le premier amendement
porte le numéro 330 8 et il est présenté
par Madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement vise à rétablir la notion de
pénibilité dans la loi en général et
dans les codes de la sécurité sociale et
du travail en particulier
l'ordonnance du 2017 13 89 du 23
septembre 2011 17 a supprimé le terme
pénibilité du Code de travail le
remplaçant par les mots facteurs de
risque professionnel Suite effectivement
aux réserve émise par les organisations
patronales qui ont voté autour du fait
qu'il faut pas associer travail et
pénibilité Emmanuel Macron lors d'une
concertation citoyenne à l'occasion de
son précédent projet de réforme du
système de retraite avait déclaré qu'il
n'adorait pas le mot pénibilité car ça
donne le sentiment que le travail serait
pénible
ce glissement sémantique
monsieur
le ministre n'est pas neutre
Jean Jaurès disait
quand les hommes ne peuvent changer les
choses
ils changent les mots
quand les hommes ne peuvent changer les
choses il change les mots c'est ce que
vous faites
quand on parle d'usure ce sont les corps
qui s'usent par le travail ce qui
renvoie à une réalité individuelle
constatée a postériori donc curative
alors que quand on parle de pénibilité
ce sont les métiers qui sont pénibles
d'où une présomption d'usure et une
notion préventive
il est d'autant plus urgent que soit
réhabilité cette notion et ne pas
l'escamoter dans le concert d'amatrice
de la protection de la santé de du fait
de la suppression des CHSCT je ne doute
pas que cet amendement aurait pu ouvrir
un débat sincère
et je sais plus quoi
éclair mais par le 49.3 sénatorial
malheureusement vous nous en empêcher
ensuite qui porte le numéro 2971
rectifié monsieur Cardon le présente
il va être suivi de deux amendements
identiques en même temps
étant donné qu'il n'y a plus de vraiment
de débat mais je vais donc présenter cet
amendement donc c'est un point
d'information c'est un amendement visa
réinstaurer la notion de pénibilité dans
la loi sachez qu'en 2017 le gouvernement
a supprimé par ordonnance le compte
personnel de prévention de pénibilité le
C3 P les quatre facteurs de pénibilité
postures pénible manutention manuelle de
charge vibration mécanique agent
chimique dangereux tout ça a été
supprimé la notion de pénibilité au
travail a été supprimée alors comme la
droite est pas très fan des rapports et
des avis alors sachez que fin décembre
2022 un rapport sur la santé au travail
publié par la Cour des comptes exprimée
une vive déception concernant ces
mesures prises par ordonnance ce même
rapport pointe à l'écoute excessif du
patronat qui qui a conduit justement une
dégradation de la gestion de la
pénibilité au travail et donc une
dégradation de la santé des travailleurs
alors monsieur le ministre pour mettre
en oeuvre des politiques de santé de
travail ça lui a implique donc de nommer
les choses oui monsieur le ministre le
travail peut être pénible et il peut
même altérer la santé des travailleurs
il est donc urgent de réhabiliter la
notion de pénibilité dans la loi et donc
malheureusement comme vous ne l'entendez
pas monsieur ministre et puis on est
contraint par le temps
je vous et je sais que vous avez plutôt
de l'humour et un goût profond pour les
mots croisés je vous fais parvenir une
grille de mots croisés pour faire preuve
de pédagogie en espérant en espérant
qu'elle vous fasse réfléchir à défaut et
qu'elle vous fasse tout simplement
revenir et qu'on puisse réintroduire la
mobilité alors si on commence par le le
mot critère supprimé en 2017 par
Emmanuel Macron qui ne sont pas repris
dans votre projet de réforme impopulaire
pénibilité monsieur ministre donc pour
vous occuper pendant les suspensions de
séance je vais vous l'envoyer et puis si
certains collègues parce que
merci l'amendement 3801 monsieur le elec
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
souhaitions par cet amendement remplacer
toutes les occurrences du mot
usure par le mot pénibilité qui nous
paraît plus adéquate pour décrire les
modalités de travail de certaines
activités je ne vais pas reprendre
l'étymologie du mot travail tout le
monde sait ici qu'il vient du latin
tripalium et vous irez vérifier plus
amplement évidemment les racines de ce
monde et cette dénomination mais il y a
une réalité mes chers collègues
historiquement dans la question du
travail car le travail ne génère pas
spontanément la joie et l'allégresse
même lorsque le travail que nous faisons
nous plaît
il est plus fort que l'usure il affecte
le physique et le mental et c'est pour
cela que le terme pénibilité est bien
plus adapté le travail ne peut être
uniquement vu comme une activité
sacro-sainte il est primordial d'en
soulever les conséquences et nous avons
besoin de travailler mais pas au prix de
notre santé c'est pourquoi nous
proposions de remplacer le mot usure par
le mot
pénibilité car la pénibilité appelle une
compensation
l'usure n'appelle pas la compensation
mais le remplacement merci de votre
attention
super nique
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues je vais donc
présenter
l'amendement 4692 qui est à l'initiative
de ma collègue Mélanie Vogel il vise à
spécifier que le fond pour la prévention
de l'usure professionnelle pourra
financer les actions de sensibilisation
et des mesures de prévention de l'usure
professionnelle causées ou renforcée par
le changement climatique le changement
climatique a déjà des impacts sur le
monde du travail impact qui ne cesseront
de de s'aggraver alors que le premier
janvier le Président de la République
est modèle Macron s'est demandé qui
aurait bien pu prévoir la crise
climatique je crois que nous devons
prendre les devants et mettre en place
des mesures de prévention permettant de
lutter contre ces effets sur les
travailleuses et travailleurs alors
qu'il faudrait un profond changement
pour adapter le monde du travail et pour
mieux protéger les salariés
cet amendement vise déjà à ce que le
fond pour la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle en tienne compte en
détail il s'agit précisément de
clarifier que les actions de
sensibilisation et prévention du jour
professionnel qui seront financées par
le fond pour la prévention
professionnelle pourront aussi être
utilisés pour mener des actions de
sensibilisation et prévention sur les
effets d'usure causés ou renforcés par
les effets des changements climatiques
cet amendement nous l'avons compris mais
je le précise n'est plus à proprement
parler tout à fait un amendement
puisqu'il ne pourra pas amender la loi
puisqu'en vertus de l'article 44.3 de la
Constitution et de l'article 42 points
alinéa 9 de notre règlement il ne sera
pas soumis à notre vote unique c'est
donc en quelque sorte pour mémoire que
je voulais présenter afin de préserver
si c'est possible un petit peu de clarté
merci alors la vie sur le rapporteur
de la Commission sur ces quatre avancées
le président la vie a été défavorable de
la part de la Commission à tous ces
amendements la vie du gouvernement mais
ma vie monsieur le Président merci nous
avons ensuite 6 amendements qui vont
faire l'objet d'une discussion commune
nous commençons par l'amendement 425
monsieur benaroche merci monsieur le
président
la question de la santé au travail est
majeur vous le savez la Commission des
accidents du travail et des maladies
professionnelles la catmp et gouvernée
par les termes le financement de cette
broche de la sécurité sociale s'appuie
sur la cotisation des employeurs
uniquement et ce depuis le compromis
social historique et fondateur de la
broche ATMP entre les partenaires
sociaux et l'État
notre amendement prévoit que les
modalités de fonctionnement du fond et
les conditions dans lesquelles il
finance les actions prévues sont
déterminées par les partenaires sociaux
siègea à la seatmp la branche accident
du travail et maladie professionnelle
est en financeuse du fort de prévention
de l'usure professionnelle via une
partie de ses excédents il appartient
aux partenaires sociaux de déterminer
les financements accordés en lien avec
les politiques de prévention primaire de
désinsertion professionnelle et de
maintien en emploi
l'amendement que nous avons déposé sur
ce base sur les travaux de la CFDT vous
savez la CFDT c'est ce syndicat assez
révolutionnaire qu'il a appuyé le
gouvernement dans sa tentative de
réforme de 2019 après il est sûr que
l'idée du gouvernement paritaire du
respect de certaines équilibre dans la
prise de décision n'est pas forcément
dans l'ADN de ce gouvernement et de son
président pourtant c'est bien cette
parité qui est qui est à la tête de la
broche ATMP qui par ailleurs est une
branche excédentaire les partenaires
sociaux sont déjà en lien avec la
Direction des Risques Professionnels
garant de l'équilibre financier de la
broche par les actions menées en matière
de prévention et de réparation il paraît
si logique que ceux qui jusqu'à présent
assurent l'équilibre financier de ces
missions puissent prix prioritairement
proposé le montant de la dotation ce
refus de permettre à continuum dans la
vision et la gestion de ces questions
réponses sans doute à un souci de
pragmatisme toujours avancé par le
gouvernement alors madame
Annick billon
président cet amendement déposé par
Michel Canevet et défendu je vous
remercie il est défendu et nous passons
à l'amendement 26 38
rectifié madame Ferré
le président donc cet amendement porte
sur ou autant déclinaison on va dire
concrètement de la création du fipu le
fond d'investissement de prévention à
l'usure professionnelle qui n'a qui
n'est pas comparable avec le C de P nous
l'avons déjà dit je veux le réaffirmer à
ce moment votre vision monsieur le
ministre avec cette réforme sur la prise
en compte de la pénibilité est éloignée
de la nôtre ce fond créé permet
effectivement de donner quelques moyens
mais totalement insuffisants par rapport
aux conséquences du recul d'âge
notamment pour bon nombre de celles et
ceux qui pourraient bénéficier de cet
accompagnement particulier au titre du
film et insuffisant aussi par rapport au
fait que le gouvernement d'Emmanuel
Macron dès 2017 avait supprimé 4
critères sur 10 critères de pénibilité
qui sont pourtant essentiels et qui sont
le lot commun le lot quotidien pardon de
bon nombre de nos concitoyens alors avec
grandement et bien nous proposons parce
qu'il s'agit là de organiser on va dire
le fonctionnement de ce fond nous
proposons que la Commission est
rappelons que la Commission
ATMP excusez-moi qui gouvernait
paritairement et le financement de la
branche s'appuie sur la cotisation des
employeurs uniquement c'est ce que l'on
a rappelé alors il est important que on
remette et on préserve ce maintien de
paritarisme également dans ce fond donc
l'amendement prévoit de laisser priorer
le clairement à la main de cette
commission
la décision du montant des dotations qui
seraient ainsi fixés tout comme la
détermination du fonctionnement du fond
et les conditions dans lesquelles les
actions prévues pourraient être retenues
je veux dire aussi que cet amendement a
été suggéré nous l'avons promis prévu
nous avons travaillé avec la CFDT parce
que c'est un site que nous avons
souhaité ité organiser notre travail
pour construire et intervenir à bon
escient pour ce projet de loin
3372 madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président alors cet
amendement travaillé avec la
Confédération française démocratique du
travail
prévoit
dans un premier temps de laisser prier
retirement la main à la commission
ATMP pour proposer le montant de la
dotation du futur fonds d'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle
la commission ATP ATMP et gouverné
paritairement faut-il le rappeler le
financement de la branche ATMP s'appuie
sur la cotisation des employeurs
uniquement car et cela est issu du
compromis social historique et fondateur
de 1898 de la branche à TMP entre les
partenaires sociaux et l'État donc il
faut respecter ce qu'on a fait quand
même au XIXe siècle les partenaires
sociaux en lien avec la Direction des
Risques Professionnels sont garants de
l'équilibre financier de la branche par
les actions menées en matière de
prévention et de réparation
c'est grâce à cette gouvernance
paritaire que la branche assure donc ses
missions et aussi son équilibre
financier
par ailleurs
l'amendement prévoit que les modalités
de fonctionnement du fond et les
conditions dans lesquelles ils financent
les actions prévues sont déterminés par
les partenaires sociaux ces gens à la
commission ATMP la branche ATMP est en
financeur du fond de prévention de
l'usure professionnelle via une partie
de ces excédents il appartient
logiquement aux partenaires sociaux de
déterminer les financements accordés en
lien avec les politiques de prévention
primaire de désinsertion professionnelle
et de maintien en emploi
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues alors je
sais pas ce qui est autorisé ou pas par
le 39-3 c'est notorial mais j'ai une
question est-ce que au minimum le
ministre pour répondre je sais que je
n'ai plus le droit ensuite de d'avoir la
parole mais au moins d'avoir la réponse
à la question la première ministre a
annoncé le 10 janvier dernier donc cette
création d'un fonds de prévention
l'usure professionnelle et de l'abonder
à hauteur de 1 milliard d'euros
évidemment
elle est elle a plutôt raison parce que
allongé la durée légale et à 64 ans va
faire que un certain nombre de personnes
vont être encore plus usés par le
travail qu'ils ne le sont aujourd'hui et
donc c'est une mesure en quelque sorte
du gouvernement de justice sociale enfin
de justice sociale à leur sauce donc la
question
qui va le gérer parce que en même temps
dans l'annonce il a été dit que on
renvoyait la balle au patronat qui
devait se mettre d'accord avec les
partenaires sociaux c'est pas exactement
le paritarisme et le compromis social
que vient de dire ma collègue pose donc
nous nous posons un amendement parce que
nous souhaitons que si à ce fond d'usure
il puisse être géré de façon paritaire à
égalité entre le patronat et le syndicat
des salariés première question et
quels sont les critères qui vont être
retenus parce que la question de la
pénibilité n'est pas la question l'usure
vous pouvez avoir un travail très
pénible quelque temps mais pas forcément
vous usez sur le long de votre vie et
puis vous pouvez avoir un travail pas
très pénible au quotidien mais qui vous
usent tout au long de votre vie donc on
voudrait aussi savoir c'est ma deuxième
question quels seront les critères et
comment ils seront pris est-ce que par
décret ou pas on aura compris qu'on
n'aura pas le droit nous en tout cas de
donner
il me reste encore deux secondes je vous
rends la parole monsieur le président
alors madame ponce
merci monsieur le président
alors vraiment dans la continuité de mon
collègue communiste le présent
amendement vise à associer les
partenaires sociaux à la définition des
moyens alloués au fond de prévention de
la pénibilité monsieur leur rapporteur
je vous sais à l'écoute des partenaires
sociaux dont je rappelle qui sont
patronaux certes mais aussi syndicaux
la Commission des accidents du travail
maladie professionnelle est parfaitement
paritaire avec cinq membres présentant
donc les employeurs et cinq membres
représentant les salariés
et bien entendu tout autant de
suppléance 5 suppléances
voilà elle se réunit 10 fois par an
afin de répondre véritablement aux
enjeux au plus proche du terrain les
organisations syndicales et patronales
doivent jouer un rôle primordial dans le
choix des montants alloués assez faux
par ce faux
la Commission des accidents du travail
maladie professionnelle peut alors
rendre un avis au gouvernement chaque
année afin d'informer d'indiquer et
fléchir le montant nécessaire au fond
pour répondre au plus près de la réalité
du travail du travail concret pas du
travail prescrit et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut les organisations syndicales il
s'agit ici donc de réinvestir les corps
intermédiaires un peu malmené par depuis
2017 notamment enfin malmener c'est les
syndicats de salariés non écoutez lors
du quinquennat quinquennat et dont le
président Macron parlait alors d'une
forme de dialogue social nouvelle qu'il
allait amorcer pour ce nouveau mandat
voici une proposition monsieur le
ministre que vous allez soutenir afin de
passer du discours aux actes alors
l'avis de la commission sur ces quatre
amendements
merci monsieur le Président
effectivement nous avons été dans cette
démarche de consultation des partenaires
sociaux qui doivent jouer leur rôle de
même que la Commission ATMP doit choisir
son rôle en ce qui concerne les
orientations également pourquoi pas sur
le fonctionnement mais en ce qui
concerne la gestion en direct du fond
c'est un fond de la CNAM la casse
nationale de l'assurance maladie branche
ATMP qui le gère voyez-vous nous plaçons
la position en position plutôt avancée
les partenaires sociaux anticipant les
décisions qui peuvent éventuellement
être pris c'est là que nous avons
l'objet de sujet de concertation en ce
qui concerne les partenaires sociaux
donc avis défavorable puisque c'est pas
le schéma que vous nous proposez
monsieur le ministre la vie du
gouvernement
il a le même avis que le alors nous
avons 6 amendements qui font l'objet
d'une discussion commune d'abord 425
pardonnez-moi
un amendement excusez-moi
l'amendement de 37 96
autant pour moi avec deux sous
amendements suite merci monsieur le
Président c'est amendement vise à
conditionner le décret concernant le
montant du futur fond d'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle à une concertation
préalable avec les organisations
syndicales représentatives amendement
qui est fort utilement à mes yeux sous
amendé par nos collègues
je crois que le fond en question pose
une première question qui a été
effleurée et que malheureusement
l'utilisation de l'article 44-3 ne va
pas permettre d'approfondir alors
qu'elle est majeure c'est la différence
entre l'usure professionnelle qui est le
propre de salarié qui sont usés par le
travail
qui est très différente à nos yeux de la
pénibilité des métiers qui ce qui est en
quelque sorte intrinsèque un certain
nombre de métiers et qui n'est pas prise
en compte comme nous pensons qu'elle le
devrait et qui va se sans doute se
renforcer du fait de l'allongement à 64
ans de l'âge de la retraite l'autre
sujet à aborder nous semble-t-il sur ce
fond ce sont les montants accordés 200
millions d'euros par an ça n'est pas
tout à fait de nature à engager de
véritables et ambitieuses politiques de
prévention enfin le risque est grand que
se font
aux entreprises et en particulier à leur
direction à décider de ce qu'elle
considère du ressort de la prévention
qui n'est pas forcément ce que les
salariés eux-mêmes jugent utile de
mettre en œuvre voilà pourquoi nous
pensons que les organisations syndicales
représentatives doivent être concertés
je crois que c'est encore plus important
dans le contexte que nous vivons
aujourd'hui où je le rappelle l'Inter
syndicale s'est adressée de manière très
solennelle aux présidents de la
République il n'a toujours pas reçu de
réponse ce qui est très inquiétant dans
le contexte social que nous vivons merci
un sous amendement de Madame ponceron
de nos collègues du groupe communiste
républicains citoyen et écologistes et
le bienvenu
ils vise effectivement je rappelle
l'objet à conditionner le décret
concernant le montant de la dotation de
la branche accident du travail et
maladie professionnelle du régime
général
au futur fonds professionnels de
prévention
à une concertation préalable avec les
organisations syndicales représentatives
nos collègues communistes seront très
certainement d'accord avec notre
sous-amendement
il s'agit de proposer de renforcer cette
amendement en remplaçant cette
concertation par une négociation
il est vrai que le gouvernement
en général
c'est ce que c'est qu'une concertation
mais rarement une négociation
Hubert tout ça professeur émérite de
psychologie sociale explique
l'étymologie du terme concertation
cela nous éclaire sur l'objectif visé
une concertation vient du vieux mot
concert accorde de personnes qui
poursuivent le même but
ce concerter s'entendre pour agir de
concert
ce qui apparaît au cœur de la définition
c'est bien l'action collective en vue
d'un accord d'un but commun
quant à la négociation selon ce même
auteur à la différence de la
concertation le conflit est à la source
de la négociation et le pouvoir des
acteurs fait partie intégrante des
processus en jeu dans les laboration
d'une solution
même s'ils ne sont pas radicalement ah
bon très bien ben écoutez je vais
conclure
je passe le relais
l'amendement 55581
[Musique]
monsieur monsieur Dantec merci monsieur
le Président et donc
Hubert touzar conclut même s'ils ne sont
pas radicalement opposés les objectifs
les intérêts des uns et des autres sont
très différents et ce sont ces
différences qui créent le conflit le
terme concertation je vais essayer de
l'illustrer concrètement il existe ici
deux concerts la majorité sénatoriale le
gouvernement de concerts ont décidé ce
matin qu'il n'y aurait plus
véritablement de débats et là
effectivement c'est la même musique même
si cette musique est difficile à
entendre et ne plaider aux oreilles des
Français qui sont dans la rue la
négociation c'est un très joli mot
négociation camarades la négociation
c'est quand effectivement il y a des
intérêts contraires dans la société et
la négociation elle sert à apaiser la
société une société qui ne règle pas les
conflit mais qui en reste à la
concertation entre ceux qui sont
d'accord et une société qui se fragilise
ce que nous vivons depuis quelques
semaines ce que nous vivons aujourd'hui
au Sénat ce que nous allons vivre dans
les prochains jours c'est la
fragilisation de la société française et
cette fragilisation cette fracturation
dans un monde en plus particulièrement
difficile aujourd'hui faut-il rappeler
que par ailleurs nous avons la guerre en
Europe et que nous sommes en train de
passer énormément de temps de fracturer
sur 0,5 % du PIB je crois monsieur le
ministre qu'il faut que vous nous
expliquiez votre refus de la négociation
votre refus de trouver des compromis
votre refus de respecter les partenaires
sociaux qui t'ont sont un des socles de
la démocratie française et je ne parle
pas du respect du Sénat donc je crois
que ce terme négociation il faut le
remettre au coeur et effectivement il
serait temps que vous entendiez l'appel
des syndicats
alors monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le Président la sémantique
s'est intéressé les actions c'est mieux
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
donnons un avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président la vie est
défavorable simplement un mot pour dire
que tous les décrivés qui nécessitent
une constatation interprofessionnelle
seront précédés d'une concertation
interprofessionnelle et que pour la
différence entre la négociation et la
concertation je maintiens à une lecture
stricte du Code du travail ce qui relève
du L1 du Code du travail fait l'objet
soit d'une constatation soit du
négociation mais je m'appuie
véritablement sur le code du travail
pour déterminer ce qui relève de la
concertation de la négociation
je rappelle les conditions de pas
perturber la clarté de nos débats
au contraire monsieur le Président je
vous remercie de me donner la parole
c'est pour l'éclairer
ce rappel règlement de ce fait donc sur
la base de l'article 46 bis alinéa 1 de
notre règlement qui concerne comme vous
le savez monsieur le Président les
amendements juste une petite réflexion
nous avons recommencé après l'acte
d'autorité sinon d'autoritarisme de
Monsieur le Ministre ce matin avec
l'acceptation de la droite de ce de
cette hémicycle et bien nous avons
entamé un nouveau débat et je vois très
bien que en fait c'est exactement le
débat que vous vouliez un débat
relativement calme dans le fait
ou d'une certaine façon on laisse parler
d'autant plus l'opposition que sa parole
ne sert strictement à rien et c'est
exactement l'illustration de ce que vous
souhaitez vous écoutez patiemment parce
que vous sais que vous savez très bien
que tout ce que nous allons dire ne sert
à rien et tout ça justement ça
s'agissant de la clarté de la sincérité
du débat la question n'est pas
d'utiliser ou pas des procédures de
parlementarisme rationalisé la question
c'est de faire en sorte que pour la
première fois il y a une collusion entre
les arguments qui sont portés par la
Constitution en matière de
parlementarisme rationalisé et ce qui
sont ceux du Règlement du Sénat en
faisant ainsi vous avez fait en sorte
que l'ensemble des procédures se
rassemblent pour nous faire taire et
pour nous empêcher d'avoir du poids et
ici nous ne sommes plus aujourd'hui et
les Français vont le voir dans un
Parlement mais dans un théâtre d'ombre
de votre fête
elle nous passons à l'amendement
qui le défend madame pensé Monge
effectivement ce bel défendre bien que
ce que vient de dire notre collègue est
évident
je vais parler dans le vide et comme de
toute façon il n'y aura pas
d'explication de vote qu'il n'y aura pas
de conflictualité de vote oui de conflit
de qualité vous savez ce qui donne lieu
au négociations justement
bon on se prête à ce jeu de théâtre
d'ombres effectivement que vous nous
avez imposé je le vois pas là le présent
amendement vise à prioriser les actions
en faveur de la prévention primaire et
pourtant vous voyez ce sont des débats
importants des débats auprès qui
importent aux salariés et qui apporte
aux organisations syndicales de salariés
les actions de prévention au travail
souffrent d'une méconnaissance de la
part de nombreuses employeurs c'est un
fait
il en résulte dans certains cas une
défaillance dans l'organisation générale
de la prévention parfois jugée par
certains employeurs optionnels bien que
pourtant ils ont l'obligation de
préserver la santé des travailleurs et
puis ils sont résulte aussi une absence
de mesure particulière adaptées aux
situations vécues par les salariés le
rapport de la Cour des comptes pour
améliorer l'efficacité des politiques
publiques en matière de prévention des
risques professionnels mais en lumière
les défauts de l'action publique dans le
champ de la santé au travail monsieur le
ministre selon ce même rapport les
actions de prévention ne font pas partie
du quotidien de tous les salariés et de
nombreuses entreprises reconnaissent ne
pas se sentir impliqué de plus depuis
2013 la fréquence des accidents du
travail ne diminuent plus et le risque
des maladies
professionnelles restent stables alors
je reprends conclure
le président merci la vie de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur la
commission n'a pas souhaité lister les
actions de prévention parce qu'on
risquerait d'en oublier c'est la raison
pour laquelle je donnerai un avis
défavorable
bien monsieur le ministre
mais ma vie
nous passons à l'amendement 24 27 qui
représente monsieur salmon
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
c'est amendement vise également à
préciser les actions en faveur de la
prévention primaire la santé au travail
est un enjeu majeur avec chaque année
très d'un million d'accidents du travail
comptabilisés dont plusieurs centaines
d'accidents mortels et près de 50000
nouvelles reconnaissances de maladies
professionnelles les actions de
prévention au travail souffrent d'une
méconnaissance de la part de nombreux
employeurs il en résulte dans certains
cas une défaillance dans l'organisation
générale de la prévention parfois jugé
optionnel et l'absence de mesures
particulières adaptée aux situations
vécues par les salariés
le rapport de la Cour des comptes pour
améliorer l'efficacité des politiques
publiques en matière de prévention des
risques professionnels mettent en
lumière les défauts de l'action publique
dans le champ de la santé au travail
selon ce même rapport les actions de
prévention ne font pas partie du
quotidien de tous les salariés et de
nombreuses entreprises reconnaissent ne
pas être impliquées
les progrès observés dans certains
secteurs en particulier le BTP
coexistent avec des dégradations
significatives dans d'autres par exemple
ceux du soin et de l'aide à la personne
du nettoyage et de l'intérim
de plus depuis 2013 la fréquence des
accidents du travail ne diminuent plus
et le risque de maladies
professionnelles reste stable les
données disponibles riches et détaillées
permettent à cet égard d'identifier
clairement où se situe les priorités
d'une politique de prévention en termes
de risques
la question du sens et travail et la
question des conditions de travail sont
essentielles et ont toutes leurs places
dans les présentations sur cette loi je
parle bien de présentation car le 49-3
sénatorial nous prive du débat
rapporteur
oui merci même esprit même résultat donc
défavorable
monsieur le ministre mais ma vie ensuite
un amendement 21 33 qui est présenté au
nom de la commission des affaires
sociales par monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre c'est favorable
alors deux amendements qui
vont faire l'objet d'une discussion
commune parce qu'ils sont identiques un
amendement 31 13 monsieur Assouline le
présente
merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement
vise à ce que en complément du Conseil
national d'orientation des conditions de
travail le Comité national consultatif
des personnes handicapées puissent
également donner un avis sur cette
réforme injuste et injustifiée comme
dans les autres parties de la loi les
personnes en situation de handicap sont
les grandes oubliées et il est
nécessaire que le comité consultatif des
personnes handicapées puissent donner un
avis à faire d'intégrer les
problématiques particulières qu'il les
régissent l'étude d'impact de cette
réforme est restée confidentiel et les
associations alertent fortement sur les
effets imprévus et négatifs de cette loi
sur les personnes en situation de
handicap quand nous savons que le taux
de pauvreté des retraités en situation
de handicap et de 12,7% en 2022 contre 8
pour la moyenne selon l'adresse nous
sommes en droit de nous inquiéter de
l'impact de votre réforme sur
quand nous savons que l'ancienne
témoigne de l'inscription au chômage des
personnes handicapées de 900 jours
compte 695 jours pour la moyenne
nationale nous sommes en droit de nous
inquiéter de l'impact de cette réforme
sur eux vous avez trop peu pris en
compte dans ce texte les personnes en
situation de handicap il est possible de
rectifier il est possible de donner des
signes en votant cet amendement mais
nous ne pourrons pas avoir le débat sur
cette question car vous avez
décidé à votre bloqué qui évitera que
nous puissions échanger plus de façon
plus approfondie sur ces situations
oubliées dans votre loi
madame Cohen présente l'amendement 38 72
oui merci monsieur le Président c'est le
même amendement que celui qui vient
d'être proposé en effet en l'état actuel
de la rédaction de l'article seul le
Conseil d'orientation des conditions de
travail est consulter aujourd'hui
composé de plus de 160 membres le
Conseil national consultatif des
personnes handicapées veuillent à une
meilleure représentation des personnes
dont qui sont en situation de handicap
en son sein et renforcent leur
participation à la co-construction des
politiques publiques le Conseil
accompagne et conseil les pouvoirs
publics dans les laboration la conduite
et l'évaluation des politiques et de
l'action publique et vous le savez il
est la mort de manière indépendante des
avis des contributions d'émotions ce
conseil a été créé par la loi du 30 juin
1975 il est reconnu pour son expertise
son expertise s'appuyait sur ses membres
dans le cas du financement du fond de
l'usure professionnelle qui devrait être
plutôt appelé pénibilité serait donc une
plus-value et permettrait d'éviter
d'éventuelles lacunes certains écueils
dans la façon d'aborder les
problématiques puisque le fond a pour
mission de participer au financement
d'action de sensibilisation et de
prévention d'action de formation
d'action de reconversion et de
prévention de la désinsertion
professionnelle la vie du CNCPH par un
légitime dans ce domaine mais je
resterai du dubitatif sur l'appréciation
vous allez avoir sur notre amendement
continue de tout ce que vous avez
dégainé pour nous empêcher de parler
pour nous empêcher de d'avoir un débat
qui soit un débat contradictoire et
quand on veut effectivement faire
évoluer les choses il faut savoir
entendre cette voix de contradiction qui
permet de construire des choses bien
plus importantes ensemble donc voilà il
y a la danse une super intéressante il
me reste 15 secondes c'est super
intéressant il y a la litanie et c'est
costumes jours tu m'intéressent monsieur
le rapporteur pour ces deux amendements
identiques
oui effectivement merci monsieur le
Président on ne peut pas dire quand même
que c'est un peu charité naturel que les
personnes handicapées ou les personnes
en situation de handicap sont les
grandes oubliées nous avons pris en
compte nous avons travaillé dans ce
domaine là notamment avec des
propositions que comité consultatif nous
ne les avons pas toutes retenu néanmoins
nous avons tenu et c'était l'amendement
de Philip mouiller à inscrire dans la
loi justement l'âge de 55 ans et là je
effectivement de retraite anticipée le
plus le plus long que l'on puisse avoir
puisque sont des personnes en situation
de handicap particulièrement touchées
nous avons veillé également parce que
les propositions qui étaient faites
concernaient pas forcément directement
la loi retraite nous avons veillé à ce
que ceux qui ont une diminution de la
pension
d'invalidité même une suppression
contenue des nouveaux décrets d'ailleurs
qui ont été pris au mois de septembre ne
soit pas pénalisés dans la prise en
compte des trimestres ils seront comptés
nous en avons l'assurance donc vous
voyez que nous n'avons pas oublié ces
personnes quand
concertation je pense qu'il appartiendra
effectivement de prendre les plus longs
les plus larges concertations et celle
du Comité national consultatif sera
évidemment bien sûr tout à fait
indispensable c'est pas forcément
nécessaire de le mettre dans la loi
c'est la raison pour laquelle la vie est
défavorable sur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
avis défavorable pour les mêmes raisons
que c'est l'évoquer par monsieur le
rapporteur et se la renvoie à des
discussions que nous avons eu sur les
amendements précédents concernant les
différents organismes pour formation à
consulter nous avons systématiquement
considéré que de la des consultations
obligatoires il n'était pas utile de
lister tous les organismes pouvant être
utilement consultés
maintenant
à l'amendement
3831 qui le présente
mes chers collègues par cet amendement
nous proposons que les grandes
orientations de ce fond d'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle ah non pardon je me
trompe
je vous prie de m'excuser cet amendement
vise à consulter l'AFPA Centre de
Formation Professionnelle des Adultes
qualifiantes pour sur les orientations
stratégiques du fond de l'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle
initié par le ministre communiste
Ambroise Croizat l'AFPA rassemble
aujourd'hui des représentants de l'état
des régions des employeurs et des
salariés il contribue au sein du service
public de l'emploi à la formation et à
la qualification des personnes les plus
éloignées de l'emploi et à leur
insertion sociale et professionnelle il
contribue aussi à la politique de
certification menée par l'État les
galaxies des femmes et des hommes à la
formation professionnelle et à la
promotion de la mixité des métiers
légales accès aussi sur l'ensemble du
territoire au service public de l'emploi
et de la formation professionnelle
malgré l'ouverture à la concurrence de
ce secteur qui a mis l'AFPA en grande
difficulté avec notamment des
suppressions de sites des suppressions
d'emplois cet organisme va continuer à
assurer la formation de centaines de
milliers de personnes dans des
demandeurs d'emploi principalement sur
des formations qualifiantes son
expertise est reconnue depuis des années
dans ce domaine il nous paraît donc
légitime de sol il nous paraissait
légitime de solliciter son avis sur les
orientations du fonds d'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle
je connais très bien cette organisme de
formation qui fait un travail
remarquable et c'est bien la raison pour
laquelle je regrette d'autant plus que
cette amendement reste l'être morte de
par la procédure qui nous est présente
demain
merci la vie de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur essayez de donner un avis
global sur l'ensemble de ses amendements
nous avons dit que la concertation était
tout à fait utile et qu'il n'était pas
nécessaire de la mettre dans la loi
alors maintenant vous vous citer
amendement par amendement des
des propositions de consultation tout à
fait intéressantes l'AFPA Cap Emploi les
chambres de commerce et d'industrie qui
bien sûr peuvent m'amener une valeur
ajoutée mais mais
les services de renseignement en droit
du travail ou même la caisse d'assurance
vieillesse véhicules voyez-vous vous
avez fait une longue liste de
consultations peut-être pour
la volonté commune d'avancer dans le
débat et pouvoir véritablement aborder
les sujets les plus profonds qui
intéressent les français plutôt qu'une
liste longue de consultation nous
pouvons si vous le souhaitez si vous le
souhaitez vous pouvez en tout cas
n'hésitez pas à retirer ces amendements
en tout cas avis défavorable pour
l'ensemble merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président sans vouloir
être dans avec l'amendement précédent
c'est un avis défavorable pour les mêmes
raisons et cette cette refuse en tout
cas sa vie défavorable au fait de lister
tous les organismes d'ailleurs qui
risqueraient de créer une forme de
compétence incontrio vaut pour tous les
amendements analogues qui vont venir
merci
l'amendement suivant qui décline donc
l'Association nationale pour
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
qui le défend
il est défendu
il est défendu le 3835 qui parle de Cap
emploi chez Julias
non merci monsieur le Président mais
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
j'ai parfaitement entendu votre réponse
monsieur le rapporteur mais je crois que
quand même ça aurait mérité une petite
discussion sur comment on peut organiser
la démocratie sociale il y a beaucoup
d'organismes qui font un travail de
terrain extrêmement important tout à
fait exemplaire et à un moment donné il
faut pouvoir les intégrer par le biais
de la concertation dans l'association à
toute à toutes ces politiques et
notamment la l'amendement que je dépose
c'est pour Cap Emploi Cap Emploi à une
mission extrêmement importante pour les
personnes en situation de handicap il
faut pouvoir les intégrer donc
l'objectif général de nos amendements
c'est comment on peut faire vivre ces
corps intermédiaires et comment on peut
faire vivre la démocratie sociale merci
monsieur le Président il en est pas de
même pour le centre d'animation une
ressource d'information
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président voilà encore
un débat qui serait fort utile à nos
yeux mais que le 44.3 est la brutalité
que de ce qui est infligé aujourd'hui va
nous empêcher de mener on a eu un débat
à l'initiative de notre collègue ça vole
des lits sur l'extrême pénibilité du
travail des égoutiers sur leur taux de
mortalité excessivement élevé et sur les
écarts considérables d'espérance de vie
qu'ils ont avec les autres salariés et à
l'occasion de ce débat qui s'était
engagé et qui malheureusement a été
stoppé le ministre Guérini nous a dit
que parmi les pistes qu'il envisageait
d'explorer il y avait
la piste donc d'une exposition moins
longue de ces égoutiers
à leur condition de travail ce qu'il
traduisait par du temps partiel chacun
imagine ce qui reste de revenu à un
égoutier qui est travail à temps partiel
il nous a aussi dit que la une autre
piste consistait en la réorientation
professionnelle
donc avec des formations qui vont avec
ce qui valide la proposition que nous
voulons faire que les centres
d'animation de ressources d'information
sur la formation soit consultée sur les
orientations stratégiques du fonds
d'investissement dans la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle et permet toi
permettez-moi monsieur le rapporteur qui
avait indiqué que vous pensiez que la
concertation était
utile mais qu'il n'était pas nécessaire
de la mettre dans la loi que ce que nous
vivons précisément actuellement montrent
qu'il faudrait donner des garanties et
donner des garanties de concertation à
l'ensemble des corps intermédiaires et
des organisations syndicales qui
aujourd'hui souffre justement que leur
avis ne soit absolument pas entendu vous
nous avez aussi proposé de retirer ces
amendements dois-je vous rappeler que
vous les avez balayés merci
pour les chambres de commerce et
d'industrie monsieur Bocquet
ministère collègues on ne peut ignorer
dans ce débat la pénibilité du travail
pas plus que le rôle des chambres de
commerce et d'industrie effectivement et
en particulier leur place d'importance
dans la formation via leur gestion des
centres de formation des apprentis vous
le savez nous ne sommes pas favorables à
ces multiplications de petits gages que
vous peignez d'accorder aux Français aux
françaises en échange de la privation de
deux ans de retraite mais votre passage
en force étanche qu'il est ne vous
proposons d'associer les chambres de
commerce et d'industrie aux orientations
stratégiques du fonds d'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure comme vous
dites nous savons que les jeunes voire
très jeunes travailleurs et travailleurs
sont sur représentés en matière
d'accident du travail et le seront
encore plus à l'avenir la loi de Madame
Pénicaud a justement nommé choisir son
avenir professionnel à amoindri la
protection des apprentis en ouvrant la
possibilité d'une extension des horaires
de travail dans les secteurs déjà
extrêmement occidentogène 27% d'entre
elles et eux travaillent dans deux des
cinq domaines les plus exposés aux
produits chimiques le BTP et la
mécanique et travaillent des métaux en
2019 se sont ainsi 10300 1 actions de
travail qui ont été recensés parmi les
apprentis il et elle subit 50% des
accidents de travail des salariés de
moins de 20 ans il est accumule les
difficultés liées à leur âge et à leur
place dans l'entreprise faisant de le
dernier maillon le plus corvéable le
plus sensible ainsi aussi au chantage eu
égard à leur contrat qui peut être rompu
plus facilement et qui engage leurs
études d'après la DARES en 2013 leur
place induit que les activités confiées
aux apprentis comme le nettoyage de zone
en poussières ou de dégraissage de
pièces sont souvent à risque
merci pour les Chambres d'agriculture ce
bagi merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre le fond que vous
souhaitez créer a pour mission de
participer au financement par les
employeurs d'action de sensibilisation
et de prévention d'action de formation
mentionnées à l'article
l6323-6 du code du travail et d'action
de reconversion une prévention de la
désinsertion professionnelle à
destination des salariés
particulièrement exposés au manutention
manuel de charge à des postures pénibles
définies comme position forcée des
articulations et à des vibrations
mécaniques les agriculteurs sont la
troisième profession la plus touchée par
la pénibilité au travail après les
travailleurs et les travailleuses de la
construction et de l'industrie
manufacturière et extractive elle est
ils sont particulièrement imposés
exposées pardon à des contraintes
physiques marquées au quotidien 79%
portent des charges lourdes 76% restent
debout régulièrement toute la journée
76% encore font des mouvements
douloureux et 76% sont à des vibrations
par ailleurs elle travaille dans un
environnement physique particulièrement
agressif 74% sont exposées à des asans à
des agents chimiques dangereux 80% des
fumées et des poussières c'est un métier
difficile mais absolument nécessaire
pour notre quotidien or pour assurer une
utilisation efficace des financements du
fonds d'investissement dans la
prévention de l'usure professionnelle il
est important de s'assurer que les
orientations stratégiques de ce fond
nouvellement créé soit en adéquation
avec les réalités du terrain et les
habitudes de ces travailleuses et
travailleurs de la terre qui exerce leur
métier avec passion certes mais aussi
avec beaucoup de souffrance je vous
remercie merci
les chambres de métiers de l'artisanat
madame
oui nous maintenons
[Musique]
enfin nous rappelons que si ce projet a
le mérite d'investir dans l'anticipation
afin de garantir la santé des actifs
malgré de fortes protections certains
métiers restent malgré tout pénibles
c'est constat appel à la réintroduction
de critères de pénibilité supprimer en
2017 pour rappel l'exposition a des
agents chimiques dangereux la
manutention manuelle de charge les
postures pénibles et les vibrations
mécaniques afin de véritablement
améliorer des conditions de travail des
salariés en prenant en compte et
reconnaissant en conclusion
professionnelle et puisque mon
amendement n'aura pas de suite dans
notre pays je voudrais rappeler parce
que ça me paraît important que c'est pas
moins de 3 millions de salariés qui sont
exposés à un ou plusieurs agents
chimiques cancérigènes près de 11
millions subissent des contraintes
physiques marquées 4 millions de travail
dans un environnement agressif près de 5
millions de rythmes de travail et près
d'un salarié sur 10 travail de nuit
pour les directions départementales de
l'emploi du travail et des solidarités
monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues le gouvernement par la
voie de madame la Première ministre a
donc annoncé un fond d'investissement de
1 milliard comme cela vient d'être
rappelé se font se penchera donc sur
l'usure professionnelle dont souffre de
nombreux métiers du fait des conditions
de travail difficiles si en l'état
actuel du texte les orientations du fond
qui encadrent l'attribution des
ressources du fond sont définies par la
Commission des accidents du travail et
des maladies professionnelles après avis
de la formation compétente du Conseil
d'orientation des conditions de travail
nous pensons effectivement que
l'association des directions
départementales de l'emploi et du
travail et des solennités auraient
renforcé l'efficience des textes
alors disons-le nous avons de
l'excellence et nous aurions tort de
nous en priver merci de votre attention
régionale de l'économie de l'emploi du
travail et des solidarités monsieur gay
merci monsieur le Président comme j'ai
vu qu'il y en avait qui avait la
surcotte d'autres la côte et d'autres
qui avaient un peu de décote je vais
essayer de me tenir dans les uns 58
nous proposons un amendement visant à
instaurer un droit David et direction
régionale des entreprises de la
concurrence de la consommation du
Travail de l'Emploi sur les orientations
décidées dans le cadre du Fonds
professionnels créés par le président
arctique les dreads sont des acteurs
clés de la politique de l'emploi de
l'inspection du travail de l'insertion
sociale et professionnelle à ce titre
elles sont essentielles pour la mise en
place des politiques publiques visant à
protéger les travailleuses et
travailleurs contre les risques
professionnels si notre groupe estime
que le font en question demeure
insuffisamment doté nous ne remettons
pas en cause son objectif de financer
des projets de prévention et de
réduction des risques professionnels il
est cependant primordial d'assurer que
les orientations prises dans ce cadre
soit prise en cohérence avec les besoins
et les réalités territoriales des
travailleurs et travailleuses c'est
pourquoi nous avons besoin d'impliquer
les drets dans les orientations de
stratégique du fonds d'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle nous devons prendre en
compte leur expertise et leur
connaissance approfondi des réalités
territoriales pour garantir l'efficacité
de la politique de prévention de l'usure
professionnelle enfin en impliquant les
drets dans les prises de décision nous
renforçons également la collaboration
entre l'État les assurés sociaux et les
employeurs représentés au sein de la
commission des accidents du travail et
des maladies professionnelles cette
mesure permettra une meilleure
coordination des politiques et une
meilleure prise en compte des besoins
des travailleurs sur le terrain je vous
invite donc à soutenir cet amendement
afin de renforcer l'efficacité et la
pertinence des décisions prises dans le
cadre de ce fond d'investissement 8
minutes 8 secondes
et nous poursuivions par l'établissement
d'insertion pour l'emploi dans l'emploi
merci monsieur le Président en 2017
Emmanuel Macron décidé de supprimer
quatre facteurs de pénibilité sur 10 du
compte professionnel de prévention c'est
de paix
expulsant ainsi des millions de salariés
du dispositif bien qui est nous ayons eu
un manque du rapporteur qui est
réintroduit un critère celui des agences
chimiques aujourd'hui au lieu de
réintrerduire l'ensemble des critères la
présente réforme propose la création
d'un fond d'investissement doté d'un
milliard d'euros sur le quinquennat donc
environ 250 millions d'euros par an
chargé de financer avec les employeurs
des actions de prévention en direction
des salariés exclus du C2P sur le
principe injecté de l'argent pour la
prévention n'est évidemment pas une
mauvaise chose mais ici encore nous
retrouvons une certaine habilité du
gouvernement qui nous l'avons déjà
expérimenté avec la politique du chèque
nous propose d'injecter de l'argent pour
répondre à des problèmes structurels si
vous n'envisagez pas en faveur d'une
amélioration globale des conditions de
travail il est impossible d'éviter
l'usure liée au travail et les
contraintes extrêmes alors comment
demander aux Français de sacrifier leur
vie au travail ce d'autant plus que les
enquêtes sur les conditions de travail
montrent que certaines caractéristiques
du travail connu pour être
particulièrement pénalisante pour les
travailleurs vieillissants et sources
d'usure professionnelle continue leur
progression en France nous pensons
notamment travail de nuit ou aux
horaires décalés aux exigences physiques
au travail sous forte contrainte de
temps et au changement fréquents dans le
travail de fait par nous demandons à ce
que les orientations stratégiques du
fonds d'investissement dans la
prévention de l'usure professionnelle
soit définie avec le concours de
l'établissement pour l'insertion dans
l'emploi
c'est un souvenir pour moi
merci monsieur le Président je pensais
que vous allez annoncer comme vous le
faisiez à l'instant les maisons de
l'emploi qui que nous considérons
nécessaires effectivement d'associer
aussi à la consultation sur les
orientations stratégiques du fonds de
prévention de l'usure professionnelle
Maison de l'emploi dont la lettre de
mission est précisément de développer
une stratégie en matière d'emploi de
participer à prévenir les mutations
économiques et les accompagner
d'encourager l'emploi local et à relever
les obstacles à l'accès à l'emploi pour
ce faire elles sont le point de
rencontre des collectivités de l'état de
Pôle emploi et de tous les acteurs
locaux de la politique de l'emploi et de
la formation professionnelle y compris
les partenaires sociaux répartis sur
l'ensemble du territoire national le
rapport de la mission d'information
sénatoriale qui leur a été consacrée en
2018 on en comptait 116 à l'époque et
elle bénéficie comme le disait le
rapport d'une visibilité d'une
reconnaissance forte dont l'expertise
est continue de part et d'autre
d'ailleurs l'Association des maires de
France auditionnée dans le cadre de
cette mission d'information sénatoriale
notez je cite souple et pragmatique ces
maisons sont devenues des plateformes de
proximité complémentaire à Pôle emploi
et sont particulièrement impliqués
auprès des élus des collectivités des
services de l'État malheureusement cette
réforme qui si elle est adoptée va jeter
des milliers de travailleurs dans le
labyrinthe administratif se doit à
minima de garantir accès et
compréhension des nouveaux dispositifs
et de leur fonctionnement tant auprès
des entreprises que des salariés s'étend
cela que nous pensons que les maisons de
l'emploi peuvent être aux côtés du
Conseil d'orientation des conditions de
travail un acteur clé pour que les
orientations du fond soient les mieux
calibrées par rapport aux besoins je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues c'est
en effet un amendement d'appel sur
l'émission locale pour l'insertion
professionnelle et sociale des jeunes et
je me permets ici de présenter mon
activité de conseiller départemental de
Bagneux je connais parfaitement ce le
travail que font ces missions locales et
notamment dans le cadre de la prévention
des problèmes liés à la santé au travail
je pense qu'il faut trouver une solution
alors peut-être que celle là est pas la
bonne les monsieurmises il faut trouver
une solution pour leur redonner des
moyens et surtout de l'importance dans
le travail qui font pour sensibiliser
les jeunes à tous les les risques qui
sont liés pour leur santé dans le
domaine du travail merci monsieur le
président
Pôle emploi
monsieur Baki
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre fait assez incroyable de ce
projet de réforme il introduit un fond
pour lutter contre un phénomène qu'il va
lui-même provoquer et aggravé ce fond
c'est celui qui financera des actions de
prévention de l'usure professionnelle si
votre projet de réforme réussit son
passage en force c'est tout de même
assez cynique reconnaissez-le vous
rajoutez au minimum deux ans aux
professions aux travailleuses et aux
travailleurs qui se cassent le dos au
quotidien où il cumulent trouble
musculo-squelettique geste répétitif et
posture statique le cocktail passait un
certain âge peut infliger au corps des
dégâts irréversibles qui sont le
résultat d'année passée au travail
parfois des décennies mais pas de
panique le gouvernement a prévu la
solution 1 milliard d'euros il faudra
faire deux ans de plus dans ces mêmes
conditions ça fera mal au dos au genou
aux cervicales au doigt aux mains mais
il y aura un fonds de prévention de
l'usure qu'elle soulagement il faut être
sérieux un instant vous pourrez mettre
les milliards que vous voudrez dans un
fond le problème
c'est qu'il y a dans les corps et dans
les esprits qui n'en peuvent plus qui ne
pourront pas supporter deux ans de plus
et vous le verrez très rapidement cela
étant dit le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste ne
fera jamais obstate à des actions de
prévention je souligne simplement ici
une certaine incohérence chercher à
prévenir des effets que l'on a créé
soi-même ce n'est probablement pas le
moyen le plus efficace de répondre à un
problème nous vous demandons toutefois
l'association aussi de Pôle emploi à la
définition des orientations stratégiques
de ce fond je vous remercie merci le
service de renseignement droit du
travail c'est évoqué le président notre
amendement visa approfondir les missions
du faux d'investissement dans la
prévention de l'usure professionnelle
que vous souhaitez créer en associant
notamment le service de renseignement en
droit du travail ce sera un premier gage
de prise en compte du droit du travail
pour éviter que ce fond ne soit dévoyé
pour finalement devenir une forme de
gadget de plus qui remplirait vos
campagnes de communication
les services de renseignement ont droit
du travail sont joignables autant par
les salariés que par les employeurs et
ils font preuve d'une neutralité propre
à tous les services publics leur mission
peut aussi être d'assurer le respect de
la protection des salariés en les
informant des droits en matière de
protection justement pour éviter ou du
moins pour limiter l'usure
professionnelle comme on l'appelle
désormais en ce qui concerne ce fond en
investissement dans la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle comment
pourra-t-il être pertinent s'il ne se
préoccupe pas de l'existant et de la vie
de celle et de ceux qui côtoient au
quotidien la réalité des salariés et des
employeurs
France compétences
donc je suis le ministre mes chers
collègues l'article 9 prétend améliorer
la prise en compte et la prévention donc
de l'usure professionnelle et des
accidents de travail or rappelons que
l'on ne peut qu'être inquiet de la façon
dont l'exécutif envisage la pénibilité
au travail le président Emmanuel Macron
s'est permis en 2017 et en 2019
d'expliquer qu'il n'aimait pas le mot
pénibilité car je cite ça donne le
sentiment que le travail serait pénible
bienvenue dans le monde réel où il
existe des dizaines de métiers pénibles
nous en avons parlé tout à l'heure et
usant et des millions de salariés qui
sont ainsi exposés à une usure physique
précoce du fait de leur travail il est
ainsi concernant que malgré l'échec du
camp de professionnel de prévention
issus en 2017 du rabotage du compte
pénibilité vous ne vouliez toujours pas
réintégrer les quatre facteurs de risque
que vous avez supprimés l'article nous
examinons affirme l'importance de la
cartographie des métiers pénibles dans
la définition des orientations
stratégiques du fond de prévention de
l'usure professionnelle que vous voulez
créer le gouvernement préconise pour
cela la consultation du Conseil national
d'orientation des conditions de travail
cependant cette organisme n'est pas
impartial car directement présidé par le
ministre du Travail et il en dépend
financièrement la consultation d'un
organisme plus indépendant de l'exécutif
nous paraît donc nécessaire on a vu par
exemple que dans le débat qui nous
occupe le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites avait permis de relativiser
les affirmations excessives du
gouvernement or l'action publique a
besoin de donner objectif pour prendre
des décisions politiques efficaces
France compétences serait donc utile
dans ce processus c'est un établissement
public administratif doté d'une
personnalité morale et de l'autonomie
financière dans la gouvernance et
quadripartite avec l'État les régions
les partenaires sociaux et les
personnalités qualifiées nous
considérons que la participation de
France compétences pour l'élaboration de
cette cartographie et des orientations
stratégies du fond permettrait une
meilleure prise en compte des
difficultés au travail et l'attribution
d'un budget réellement la hauteur des
besoins de prévention
l'inédit que
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
associés l'unique aux orientations
stratégiques du fonds d'investissement
ça devrait aller de soi en effet
l'unique est un acteur clé de la
protection sociale en France elle
possède une expertise et une
connaissance approfondie des
problématiques liées à l'emploi et puis
cette consultation permettrait d'avoir
une vision plus globale des enjeux liés
à la prévention et à la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle et d'assurer que
s'assurer que les financements sont bien
garantis
et puis et puis ludique
l'un de ses rôles essentiel c'est quand
même d'accélérer le retour à l'emploi
des salariés donc il serait à nos yeux
normals que l'individique puisse se
prononcer telle est le sens de
l'objectif visé par cette proposition
d'amendement merci de votre attention le
Conseil national des politiques de lutte
contre la pauvreté
il est défendu
et le Haut Conseil de la famille de
l'enfance et de l'âge madame Cohen
[Musique]
je le redis devant vous monsieur le
Président j'aurais vraiment souhaité que
le ministre quand il a fait il a dégainé
le 44 3
avec donc le vote unique et le choix de
70 amendements il est fait en votre
présence
voilà je vous le dis et vous savez que
nous avons des opinions divergentes et
des analyses divergentes mais le moindre
des choses c'est le respect du Parlement
et de l'institution et je le dis pas y
compris au nom de Monsieur du stop mais
aussi à son collègue qui est très
silencieux qui s'occupe des relations
avec le Parlement qui vient de temps en
temps s'asseoir et qui est d'un mutisme
remarquable cela étant dit j'en viens à
l'amendement avant de me faire gronder
cet amendement prévoit la consultation
du conseil national de politique de
lutte contre les pauvreté l'exclusion
sur les orientations stratégiques du
fonds d'investissement dans la
prévention de l'usure professionnelle
dans un délai de six mois suivant la
promulgation de cette loi ce conseil
national de la lutte contre les pauvreté
exclusion sociale et de fait charger
d'assister le gouvernement
par ses avis sur toutes les questions de
portée générale qui concernent la lutte
contre la pauvreté question qui nous
préoccupe quand même et de l'exclusion
sociale par des études et la formulation
des propositions donc son approche et
son expertise y compris qui est souvent
reconnu par les assemblées
parlementaires mais aussi par les
collectivités territoriales et j'irai
même dire par aussi la puissance
d'analyse qu'on des personnes morales
qui sont des personnes morales de droit
public ou de droit privé je pense qu'on
ne peut pas se priver cette expertise
voilà donc je demande évidemment que cet
amendement comme tous les autres
amendements soient pas balayés par un
avis défavorable tout azimut voiture
balai et rentrer chez vous d'accord
allez
merci
le Défenseur des droits
merci monsieur le Président non c'est
juste pour bien comprendre parce que là
on est pas en discussion commune
monsieur le Président il me semble pas
nous avons eu la vie de la tout à
l'heure mais poursuivez
je savais que
attendez c'est moi c'est moi si si
non non
c'est sur les missions du Défenseur des
droits donc c'est moi face aux
difficultés que par rencontre un usager
avec une administration ou un service
public le Défenseur des droits et les
personnes à mieux comprendre leurs
droits et les oreillons dans leur
démarche en ce sens compte tenu de la
complexité des dispositifs et des règles
de droits le Défenseur des droits est en
mesure de veiller à ce que rien
n'empêche les usagers de bénéficier
pleinement de leurs droits encore plus
dans le cadre de ce fonds
d'investissement dans la prévention et
l'usure professionnelle qui pour le
moment pose plus de questions qu'il
n'apporte de réponse concrètes ou
salarié face à la pénibilité de leur
travail sur quelle à l'année analyse
repose la création de ce fond et surtout
son abonnement d'un montant de 1
milliard d'euros sur cinq ans quel
objectif concret se donnera ce fond
d'investissement
s'agit-il d'une extension du Front
national de prévention de la Caisse des
dépôts ou d'un fond
ces questions sont pour l'instant au
suspens la prévention l'usure
professionnelle figure déjà au coeur de
l'axe stratégique 2 du plan santé au
travail adopté pour la période 2021 2025
si certains progrès techniques
permettent effectivement d'améliorer les
conditions de travail il reste loin de
résoudre le problème je vous remercie
la Caisse nationale d'assurance
vieillesse des travailleurs salariés
même Cohen
toute façon vous inquiétez pas monsieur
le Président on va faire un duo ça va
très bien se passer donc
mon collègue Fabien gay vient de
défendre le 38 74 je défends le 38 69 et
tout va bien donc par cet amendement
nous visons à ce que le Haut Conseil de
la famille de l'enfance et de l'âge
soient consultés sur les orientations
stratégiques du fond d'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle dans un délai de six
mois suivant la promulgation de la
présente loi en effet nous savons que
cette loi aura un impact social massif
pour les travailleurs et les
travailleuses de notre pays des ouvriers
des ouvrières seront impactés dans leur
vie professionnelle par l'usure
quotidienne de leur corps cela faisant
suite à des travaux pénibles et
répétitifs il convient donc chers
collègues de pouvoir mesurer d'ici 6
mois l'impact terrible pour des millions
de nos concitoyennes et concitoyens de
ces décisions prises parfois dans des
salons dorés de la République loin du
quotidien de ces mêmes millions de
Françaises et de français qui seront eux
victimes de cette loi dans leur
quotidien il est impératif monsieur le
ministre de pouvoir mesurer l'impact de
faire travailler deux années de plus
l'ensemble des travailleurs et des
travailleurs c'est ce que nous proposons
avec cet amendement car de nombreuses
études l'ont démontré l'usure des corps
au travail est déjà forte à 62 ans et le
sera encore plus à 64 ans les
conséquences seront nombreuses parmi
lesquelles pour certaines et certains
une incapacité totale de travail ce qui
augmentera les besoins financiers de la
sécurité sociale un nouvel exemple
monsieur le ministre et mes chers
collègues de droites puisque vos projets
sont identiques qui démontent combien
cette réforme est
inutile et particulièrement dangereuse
je vous remercie
38 77 puisque
que vous regardiez en même temps que moi
38 77 Monsieur laelec Merci monsieur le
Président agricole très bien merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
qu'il me soit permis tout d'abord de
saluer ici
l'engagement exemplaire et particulier
qui est celui
des mutualités sociales agricoles tant
en matière de diagnostic
d'accompagnement des mutualistes et ici
devant notre Haute Assemblée peut-être
avons-nous une raison supplémentaire de
souligner encore plus le rôle de cette
MSA
il est bon également de rappeler que
dans le monde agricole la notion de
pénibilité du travail
est plus prégnante et plus spécifiques
encore que dans bien d'autres
professions qu'on soit éleveur c'est
réalisé viticulteurs arboriculteurs et
donc parfois aussi exposé à l'usage de
pesticides le métier d'agriculteur est
un métier exposé à une forme
particulière de pénibilité et il est
donc légitime et bien que les situations
spécifiques qui en découlent puissent
complètement apprécié
alors la MRC intervient en outre pour la
santé et la sécurité au travail des
exploitants salariés employeur et chef
d'entreprises agricoles et l'agit pour
améliorer les conditions de travail et
prévenir les risques en agriculture et
de ce fait de mieux placer la MSA dans
le rôle de concertation et d'association
à la décision ne serait que légitime
merci monsieur le Président
l'Association générale des institutions
bretonnes des cadres
monsieur gay alors c'est Monsieur
Président c'est moi qui me suis trompé
donc je m'en excuse auprès de ma
collègue tout à l'heure donc celui-là il
est défendu voilà très bien
le Conseil d'orientation des retraites
on en a beaucoup parlé du corps
monsieur Bocquet oui merci monsieur le
Président la rédaction actuelle de
l'article 9 évoque la possibilité pour
les branches professionnelles d'établir
des listes de métiers ou d'activités
particulièrement exposées à la
pénibilité et aux risques professionnels
l'attention est certes loi mais sans
caractère obligatoire et sans agenda
nous craignons que cette bonne volonté
ne reste un peu pieux c'est le sens de
cet amendement donné six mois aux
branches professionnelles pour établir
ses listes la seule possibilité offerte
n'a aucune valeur contraignante depuis
la loi el khomri les branches
professionnelles ont acquis une place
prépondérante dans l'organisation du
travail et du droit des travailleurs il
est donc selon nous légitime qu'elle se
saisisse de façon paritaire de cette
problématique les branches
professionnelles négocient les
conventions collectives et les accords
collectifs qui sont applicables salariés
qu'elles regroupe c'est donc selon nous
l'échelons essentiel pour promouvoir
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
le comité de suivi des retraites
monsieur Julias
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je suis le président j'ai un
petit regret c'est dommage qu'on veut de
plus parce que la gauche et largement
majoritaire là on aurait pu faire passer
des amendements c'est dommage oui donc
bien évidemment le comité de suivi des
retraites il est fondamental dans
dans le dispositif actuel donc c'est
pour ça que nous nous demandons qu'il
soit consulté de façon institutionnelle
structurelle parce qu'il est au coeur de
la présente-toi je remercie monsieur le
Président
1897 le fond de solidarité vieille
merci
monsieur le Président
200 millions d'euros donc par année
alors que 97% des 25 millions de
travailleurs sont exposés à plusieurs
risques au 31 décembre 2019 le secteur
des transports et de l'entreposage
employés un million 426000 salariés hors
intérim dans ce secteur 94% 95% des
maladies professionnelles sont des TMS
plus de 860 000 jours d'arrêt de travail
des salariés seront déposés par des
travailleurs exposés chaque année ce
sont donc
147 euros par travailleur promis aux
entreprises si chaque année l'ensemble
du fond allait intégralement et ce
secteur qui ne représente que 12% de
l'emploi tertiaire marchand nous voulons
bien que vous payez avec des mots à des
fautes payer des solutions aux
travailleurs qui ont dos cassé mais ne
nous demandez pas de venir se font j'en
reviens très spécifiquement à l'objet de
cet amendement qui propose que le fond
de solidarité vieillesse souhaite
associé aux orientations du fond d'usure
professionnelle c'est assez simple parce
que 61% des salariés qui sont au minimum
vieillesse la SPA ou l'ASV sont partis
pour inaptitude ou invalidité ils sont
donc trois fois plus que ceux qui ont
des pensions de droit commun c'est
travailleurs sont pleinement concernés
même sur représentés face au risque de
pénibilité et d'usure professionnelle
pour rappel l'usure professionnelle est
un processus d'altération de la santé du
fait de l'exposition à des contraintes
de travail physique
cognitives durant le parcours
professionnel dès lors que le fond de
solidarité vieillesse dispose d'une
connaissance fine de ces pensionnés et
donc de ces travailleuses et
travailleurs en fait carrière notamment
qui se rapproche de ses services il
apparaît nécessaire de l'associer aux
orientations stratégiques du fond
d'usure mais pour réserve des retraites
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre bon
il y a un truc qu'on sait tous c'est
qu'on va augmenter le temps de travail
hebdomadaire
on va augmenter le temps de travail
nécessaire pour obtenir le droit au
chômage et on va et on va allonger
seulement deux ans allez hop le droit à
la retraite bon en gros allez pour
parler simple offensif travailler plus
pour produire plus et surtout qu'on
s'aimait plus en dehors évidemment d'un
productivisme dépassé rien de salut
alors aujourd'hui je nous pensons que
nous la réforme est à rebours les
employeurs vont exiger une disponibilité
permanente on va avoir un élargissement
des amplitudes horaires étendues un
travail de nuit les week-ends
professionnel tout en baissant la
cotisation des employeurs alors il a ils
ont été totalement absents nos débats
alors là les employeurs pour leur
demander de faire un effort absent
depuis jeudi dernier mais bon allez
comment on va alimenter la branche
accident travail et maladie
professionnelle de la sécurité sociale
quand on regarde les chiffres vous nous
dites un milliard d'euros attendez pas
pour l'année 2023 un milliard d'euros
d'ici 2027 ça veut dire 250 millions par
an c'est largement inférieur à ce que va
coûter le relèvement de l'âge légal de
départ la retraite de 62 à 64 ans en
rente d'invilliers on rentre
d'invalidité et là c'est pas le groupe
communiste qui dit ça mes chers
collègues et ça ça mérite débat j'ai les
chiffres c'est l'adresse il va y avoir
250 millions on nous dit un milliard et
l'adresse nous dit à minima 1,8
milliards de dépenses supplémentaires
voilà ce qui va se passer réellement on
va laisser combien de jeunes combien de
gens sur la touche combien de gens
écartés donc les dépenses de prévention
vont être inférieures à la réparation
pénibilité et je vous le dis mes chers
collègues vous l'avez voté mais le CDI
va accélérer cette difficulté
la caisse de prévisions c'est de
retraite de la SNCF monsieur Laennec
il est défendu
il est défendu la caisse de retraite du
personnel de la région autonome des
transports parisiens un brûlant merci
monsieur le Président c'est amendement
vise à prévoir la consultation
obligatoire de la caisse de retraite du
personnel de la RATP concernant les
orientations stratégiques du fonds
d'investissement dans la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle vous connaissez
les critiques que nous perd que nous
portons depuis quelques instants
maintenant à l'insuffisance de ce fond
sur le financement et les montants qui
lui seront affectés comme sur la
démarche vous savez aussi que nous
reconsidérons qu'en repoussant l'âge
légal à 64 ans le gouvernement génère
infiniment plus d'usure professionnelle
nous nous appelons ça et nous
continuerons d'appeler ça la pénibilité
pour les raisons que là aussi nous avons
évoqué qu'il ne pourra en compenser à
posteriorer avec ce dispositif Pascal ça
vole des vies vient de le montrer
efficacement
outre notre désaccord de principe nous
considérons essentiels que ce fond soit
géré démocratiquement en associant
l'ensemble des acteurs concernés la
caisse de retraite du personnel de la
RATP qui gère aujourd'hui et qui
continuera à gérer demain les carrières
les départs en retraite et les pensions
de dizaines de milliers de travailleurs
du secteur des transports étant ce sens
incontournable c'est pourquoi nous
présentons cet amendement
l'établissement national des invalides
de la marine
très grand département côtier
plage
La Courneuve plage on vous invitera cet
été avec la présidente assassin à venir
découvrir
nos plages
cet amendement de repli vise à prévoir
la consultation de l'établissement
national des Invalides la marine sur les
orientations stratégiques du fond
d'investissement dans la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle dans un délai de
six mois suivant la promulgation de la
loi pourquoi on demande ça un des
métiers les plus accidentogènes c'est
celui de marin est-ce que vous savez sur
les à peu près 38 900 marins c'est 42
accidents sur 1000 marins donc il y a
une vraie question autour de ce métier
et tant d'autres que nous venons de dire
mais nous pensons qu'au minimum seront
ces questions là sur les marins ils
doivent être associés sur cette question
de prévention des risques des usures et
je vous repose la question monsieur le
ministre il va falloir un minimum un
moment donné je ne sais pas quand on
viendra le temps de la réponse de la
Commission du rapporteur et de vous-même
mais nous répondre sur les critères
parce que je vous le redis la pénibilité
n'est pas l'usure
la pénibilité n'est pas l'usure mais
c'est un métier extrêmement pénible
marin et qui use très rapidement puisque
là vous savez que aussi l'espérance de
vie en bonne santé et moindre pour un
marin que pour un ouvrier ou un salarié
en moyenne je vous remercie monsieur le
Président la Caisse nationale des
industries électriques et gazières
il est défendu
il est défendu non il faut suivre
moi je suis
madame Cohen
excusez excusez-moi monsieur le
Président nous l'avons dit les critères
de pénibilité et vous voyez moi c'est
des critères pour descendre là des
IEG est plus importantes que celle du
régime général en ce sens la suppression
des régimes spéciaux va à rebours
complet de la reconnaissance de la
pénibilité dans ce secteur et remet en
cause l'attractivité des métiers
pourtant aujourd'hui en manque chronique
de personnel ce que vous remettez en
cause avec la fin des régimes spéciaux
votés à l'article 1 c'est bien la
pénibilité de certains postes on a parlé
le problème des astreintes travail de
nuit charge lourdes environnement de
travail bruyant risque de contracter des
maladies professionnelles nous vous
parlons d'efforts physiques importants
de postures non naturelle et pénible
comme par exemple l'ascension de support
sans nacelle le port et ou la
manipulation de charge lourdes le tirage
de câbles
et tout ça se fait dans un espace clos à
des températures souvent extrêmes un
travail donc difficile manuel et
contraint exposé aussi aux intempéries
et voici quelques-uns des exemples et
j'aurais pu continuer ma liste n'est pas
exhaustive bref ce que vous détruisez
c'est bien la juste contribution sociale
du aux agents qui assure le service
public de l'énergie
365 jours par an 24 heures sur 24 par
tous les temps pour la nation et les
usagers c'est pourquoi nous souhaitons
que la consultation de la Caisse
nationale des industries électriques et
gazières sur les orientations
stratégiques du fonds d'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle que les syndicalistes
préfèrent appeler pénibilité dans un
délai de six mois suivant la
promulgation de la présente loi donc se
fasse tel est l'objet de notre
amendement je vous remercie merci la
caisse d'assurance vieillesse et
maladies des cultes
monsieur zoulias
merci monsieur le Président c'est à moi
de le faire
donc il s'agit de mes chers collègues il
s'agit de la quasimak donc la caisse
d'assurance vieillesse et maladie des
cultes c'est une c'est une caisse très
intéressante je pense qu'il faut que
vous soyez attentif parce que les
pensions gérées par cette deste par
cette caisse sont les plus basses de
France entre 387 euros et 697 euros ce
sont les pensions les plus basses de
France par ailleurs la quasimak c'est
100 millions de déficits tous les ans
pourquoi parce qu'il y a 38 000
bénéficiaires et aujourd'hui 19000
cotisants il y a deux bénéficiaires pour
un seul cotisant aujourd'hui elle est
largement déficitaire et pourquoi elle
subsiste encore parce que la solidarité
nationale s'exerce à son profit et que
l'équilibre financier de la quasimaque
et assuré par une compensation générale
ce qui ne pose aucun problème et bien au
contraire je trouve que c'est tout à
fait naturel mais Mac montre bien que là
le problème structurel du déficit de ces
caisses ne sera pas réglé par cette
réforme il y a un déficit structurel et
malheureusement les ministres du culte
il s'arrêtent pas 62 ans ils vont
largement au-delà à 70 voire beaucoup
plus donc le problème structurel de
financement de cette caisse va subsister
après votre effort je pense que c'est
vraiment un exemple intéressant sur
lequel il faudra revenir quand notre
hémicycle sera un peu plus intéressé par
la question merci monsieur le Président
et la Caisse des dépôts est consignation
la meilleure santé que les cultes là on
y va
si monsieur le Président
cet article 9 créé un fond spécifique
pour l'usure professionnelle nous
déposons cet amendement pour comprendre
l'articulation finalement du fond
d'usure avec le compte personnel gérer
lui-même par la Caisse des Dépôts ce
fond d'usure servirait par exemple à
financer France compétences au titre des
financements de projets de reconversion
professionnelle
c'est incompréhensible d'ajouter des
nouveaux fonds à France compétences qui
de toute évidence ne fonctionne pas je
cite le titre des échos du 7 novembre
2022 qui disait que France compétences
le très coûteux en même temps du
gouvernement et pour cause entre 2020 et
2022 inclus France compétences aura
cumulé 11,2 milliards d'euros de déficit
monsieur le ministre pourquoi invoquer
une nouvelle recette en trompe l'oeil
pour France compétences quel est
l'article entre le CPF et les crédits du
d'usure à France compétences au titre de
la reconversion tout cela ne nous paraît
pour l'heure pas vraiment très clair
plus largement nous nous demandons de là
de ces prérogatifs comment va
fonctionner le fond pour le moment le
fonctionnement du fond les conditions de
sa participation financière et ses
modalités de gestion et d'affectation de
ces ressources sont renvoyées à un
décret en Conseil d'État nous demandons
des précisions car nous pensons que ce
fond est une diversion pour éviter que
le débat sur le retrait des quatre
critères de pénibilité décidé sous le
précédent quand quinquennat soit
réouvert je vous remercie le conseiller
économique social et environnemental
Président le ministre mes chers
collègues avec le cesé nous avons une
instance unique en son genre de par sa
pluralité d'acteurs qui la composent et
de par la qualité de ses travaux cette
instance nous le savons à l'avantage de
ne pas être aux ordres de l'exécutif
le cesé et après l'Assemblée nationale
et le Sénat de la troisième assemblée
cité dans la Constitution il assure le
lien entre les pouvoirs publics et nous
les citoyens sa mission est de
conseiller le gouvernement et le
Parlement dans les laboration des lois
et des politiques publiques plus
récemment c'est aussi devenu la chambre
de la participation citoyenne il est le
trait d'union entre les pouvoirs publics
et la société ce sont des femmes et des
hommes de terrain qui travaillent dans
des entreprises des syndicats des
organisations patronales aussi des
associations des ONG
et ils sont ce conseil il accueille 175
conseillères et conseillers je pense
qu'il est très utile pour le
gouvernement d'écouter ses avis et je me
permettrai de dire d'ailleurs que vous
allez être contraint de recevoir leur
avis puisque la pétition contre votre
réforme des retraites un thème plus d'un
million de signataires quand il en faut
seulement 150 000 pour saisir le sais
merci et vous conseille à l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes
oui merci monsieur le Président la
consultation du Haut Conseil et
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
sur les orientations stratégiques du
fond en investissement dans la
prévention de l'usure professionnelle et
un élément crucial pour garantir
l'égalité entre les sexes dans le
domaine de la santé au travail en effet
il est incontestable que les femmes sont
souvent plus exposées que les hommes au
risque professionnels liés d'une part à
la précarité de l'emploi elle a
discrimination sexiste et au violence
sexuelles et sexistes y compris c'est
pourquoi il est selon nous plus que
nécessaire que le Haut Conseil à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
soient consultés pour assurer que les
orientations stratégiques du fond en
investissement dans la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle prenne en compte
les besoins spécifiques des femmes en
matière de santé et de sécurité au
travail
j'avais compris monsieur le rapporteur
que vous aviez donné un avis général sur
l'ensemble de ces amendements nous nous
confirmer il est défavorable et vous en
avez donné les motifs le gouvernement de
confirme bien nous passons ensuite un
amendement à l'article 9 qui porte le
numéro 2134 il est présenté par Monsieur
Savary au nom de la commission des
affaires sociales monsieur le président
excusez-moi coordination
coordination c'est un amendement de
coordination
ensuite un amendement 429 monsieur
benaroche le présente
nous l'avons dit depuis tout à l'heure
la pénibilité au travail aurait dû être
le sujet central ou un sujet central de
ce projet de loi gouvernement a décidé
de Nicot sacré que seul l'article est
encore largement insuffisant et alors je
sur le foil largement édulcoré en
utilisant le terme d'usure
professionnelle avec toutes les
différences d'acceptation qu'à expliquer
tout à l'heure ma collègue vraiment de
passer pourtant
la question de la taxe sanitaire
négative du travail aurait dû être pris
en compte vous ne souhaitez peut-être
pas l'entendre venir de nous vous
n'acceptez pas vraisemblablement de
l'entendre tout simplement venant des
syndicats de travailleurs alors je vous
dis monsieur le ministre soyez attentifs
au moins au collectif des responsables
de la société française de santé au
travail et du Collège des Enseignants
hospitaliers et universitaires de
médecine du travail les médecins du
travail qui sont en première ligne pour
savoir exactement quels sont les effets
du travail sur la santé au travail ils
ont récemment publié une tribune dans Le
Monde soulignant à quel point la réforme
des retraites prend trop peu en côte les
risques professionnels je cite elle
poursuit ainsi le mouvement initial 2017
lorsque quatre critères de billibilité
sur 10 avaient été supprimés les
inégalités sociales de mortalité
d'espérance de vie sans incapacité
d'état de santé entre cadré et ouvriers
persistent indépendamment des modes de
vie des milieux de vie et
d'environnement et du recours aux soins
la pénibilité de certains métiers posent
de travail cumulés au fil de la carrière
professionnelle contribue à ces
différences pour ces professionnels de
la santé au travail je cite de nouveau
l'approche proposée dans la loi retraite
est à la fois restrictive et non
conforme aux principes généraux de
prévention des risques professionnels
restrictives car plusieurs facteurs de
pénibilité avérés sont absents non
conforme car contraire au principe
fondamental de la prévention des risques
qui enjoint de supprimer ou de réduire
les risques plutôt que de côté les
victimes à posteriori
la vie de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
ce Président nous pensions que
l'intention de l'élysateur sera
respectée donc avis défavorable par
rapport à cette proposition
monsieur 427
bien sûr je vais le présenter monsieur
le Président mais j'en profite suite au
repas que je viens d'avoir sur quand ça
va être là pour qu'elle je ne peux pas
répondre puisque les formes de de
processus que vous avez adopté
gouvernement majorité ensemble nous
empêche en fait à la fois d'avoir un
débat sur nos propositions je vous le
fais remarquer sur amis de droite qui
absorbe absolument pas de l'obstruction
au débat mais qui sont enrichissement de
ce qu'on aurait dû être l'autre débat et
en plus de toute façon on pourra pas les
voter puisque vous avez décidé quand
votre épave donc 10 débat ni votre nous
sommes dans un effet de leur nous sommes
dans un effet de trompe l'oeil comme on
le dit c'est à dire on nous présente un
magnifique gâteau mais en fait derrière
il s'agit peut-être de d'une soupe à la
grimace donc en ce qui concerne
l'explication de votre sur enfin
l'explication de votre la défense de cet
amendement 427 je dirais simplement que
l'efforts qui sont prévus ne financeront
des actions de prévention à destination
des salariés exposés à moins seulement
de trois critères de pénibilité
uniquement cela manutention manuelle de
charge
vibration mécanique et donc les 10
facteurs existants par ailleurs
l'exposition des agences civiques
dangereux le travail en équipe
successives alternante l'exposition au
bruit les températures extrêmes ou
d'autres d'ailleurs comme la pénibilité
psychique qui a été demandé par la
CFE-CGC ne sont pas pris au code là
encore aussi le gouvernement aurait pu
réintégrer les quatre critères de
pénibilité supprimés en 2017 par les
ordonnances médicaux
mais il est clair que d'un point de vue
général ce gouvernement pense toujours
faire mieux que les autres pourtant
l'écoute et le dialogue avec les
institutions devraient rester des
passages obligés pour arriver à des
dispositifs équilibrés juste et
acceptable le président semble avoir dit
en disant que en fait il recevraient pas
les syndicats tant que la période
parlementaire serait pas terminé en fait
la période par le volontaire elle est
terminée chers amis donc je pense que le
président va décider de recevoir les
syndicats puisqu'elle est terminée ça
aura au moins servi à ça peut-être les
décisions vous avez prises à faire que
le président reçoivent les syndicats
plus rapidement merci l'abonnement 427
monsieur président Gontard
merci 4680
oui
il y a la vie de la Commission et il
serait défavorable notamment parce que
nous pensions qu'il va y avoir une
négociation nationale
interprofessionnelle donc c'est pas
nécessaire que cette négociation soit
réunie pour les décrets nous pensons
qu'elle a un rôle beaucoup plus utile
que ça à ce moment là je voudrais vous
faire une précision que les choses
soient claires revenant aux agents
chimiques nous les avons pas rajouter
dans le C2P nous les avons
ouvert à la prévention par le biais du
fipu et notamment pour prendre en compte
ceux qui sont exposés à la fois des
troubles ergonomiques et à des
expositions agents chimiques c'est la
cohérence qui nous a conduit à cette
proposition mais il faut bien dissocier
cela donc avis défavorable monsieur le
ministre mais ma vie que la Commission
alors nous passons maintenant à
l'avendement
4680 monsieur le Président guitare
merci monsieur le Président donc comme
je le disais cette amendement du groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoire a
été travaillé par ma collègue Mélanie
Fogel vise à assurer une perspective
jeanrée délice de métiers ou d'activités
exposés à des facteurs de risque
professionnels dressés par les branches
Emmanuel Macron déclaré qu'il n'aimait
pas le terme de pénibilité du travail
parce que ça donnait le sentiment que le
travail serait pénible minimiser la
pénibilité du travail et dangereux car
cela induit aussi de minimiser les
risques auxquels les travailleuses et
les travailleurs sont exposés au lieu de
rendre le travail plus dangereux il faut
qu'on protège davantage les
travailleuses et les travailleurs cette
protection passe aussi par une prise en
compte du fait que les risques sont
genrés c'est précisément l'objectif de
cet amendement qui vise à assurer que
les listes de métiers ou d'activités
exposés à des facteurs de risque
professionnel dressés par les branches
prennent en compte ces risques
différenciés par le genre
la nécessité de cette prise en compte
découle en première ligne de la
ségrégation jeanrée persistante des
professions les femmes exercent souvent
des professions intermédiaires sont
davantage au contact du public par
exemple dans les soins médicaux et
paramédicaux ou la prise en charge des
enfants des aides à domicile et des
assistantes et assistants maternelles
les aides-soignantes et aide-soignants
des infirmières et infirmiers et des
enseignantes et enseignants dans ce cas
s’inscrivent des constats préoccupants
de risques professionnels pour les
femmes les femmes sont surexposées aux
troubles muscaux squelettiques car parmi
les cas reconnus cumulant un certain
nombre de facteurs de risque de TMS dans
leur travail se trouvent 58% des femmes
de plus les femmes sont plus fréquemment
exposées à certains facteurs de risque
psychosociaux elles sont plus nombreuses
à subir de pression et à devoir se
dépêcher elle manque d'autonomie et de
marge de manœuvre enfin 33% des flammes
déclarent de voir cacher leur émotion ou
faire semblant d'être de bonne humeur
contre 22% des hommes pour ces raisons
il convient d'intégrer une perspective
genrée de la pénibilité point de départ
pour assurer une meilleure prise en
compte des métiers souvent exercé par
des femmes un amendement important qui
est là ce ne pourra pas être ni discuté
ni voter
avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur parce que nous pensons qu'il
faut prendre l'exposition aux risques
qu'elle a traitée de façon identique ce
soit des hommes ou des femmes en tout
cas merci d'avoir exposé la pénibilité
particulière pour les femmes nous y
avons également réfléchi sur le ministre
Nassim c'est le président c'était
favorable pour une raison un peu
différente de celle évoquer par Monsieur
rapporteur nous considérons qu'il n'y a
pas lieu de l'inscrire dans la loi dès
lors que les critères de mesure la
pénibilité et la déclinaison au-delà de
ce qui est déjà inscrit sur les quelques
items des indicateurs de pénibilité
relève du dialogue social et des
branches les branches sont cette
habitude vont beaucoup de branche de
gens
nous allons examiner
un amendement et trois sous amendements
qui vont faire l'objet d'une discussion
commune d'abord un amendement présenté
au nom de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur
prévoit que les carsats interviendront
en identifiant les entreprises
auxquelles pourront être allouées les
ressources de ce fond d'investissement
de plus il élargit le champ des
destinataires des ressources du fond aux
institutions concombres à l'organisation
de la prévention afin de pouvoir y
inclure des acteurs tels que la nacte ou
le réseau des Arabes
la vie du gouvernement
alors je vais d'abord voir les sous
amendements pardonnez-moi non non
celui du gouvernement merci monsieur le
Président c'est un amendement de
précision rédactionnel le gouvernement
considère que la clarification du champ
apporté par la commission est utile et
pourquoi simplement cette précision de
texte
et sous abonnement que présente monsieur
Fernique et merci monsieur le Président
je suis particulièrement heureux de
présenter ce sous amendement puisque
dans cette morne phase de de vacuité
parlementaire engendré par le 49.3 de la
Constitution et le 49 de notre règlement
et bien c'est un moment précieux puisque
ce sous amendement et oui figure dans la
fameuse lipste des amendements et sous
amendements acceptés par le gouvernement
et donc je suis ravi de vous le
présenter il propose que les fonds
d'investissement dans la prévention
levure professionnelle puisse bénéficier
à d'autres entreprises que celles
identifiées par les carsats donc
l'amendement vise à agrandir le
périmètre des entreprises pouvant
bénéficier des financements du fond et
en permettant ainsi de laisser les
partenaires sociaux aux partenaires
sociaux la liberté de fixer les
orientations du fond par ailleurs cette
amendement propose que le fond puisse
également financer les organismes de
prévention de branche qui ont
conventionné avec des organismes
nationaux de prévention en effet les
organismes de prévention par branche
sont spécialisées dans leur domaine
d'activité ce qui leur permet de fournir
des conseils et des formations adaptées
aux risques et aux enjeux spécifiques à
chaque profession voilà je crois vous
avoir expliqué ce qu'il fallait savoir
pour que vous puissiez voter en
connaissance de cause si vous le
souhaitez sur ce sous-amendement qui
figure dans la liste
relevant du vote unique
et l'amendement 5741 monsieur ficher
oui merci monsieur le Président donc
voilà sous amendement qui aurait pu
assez rapidement obtenir un vote
consensuel mais voilà votre refus du
débat nous prive d'un vote important en
effet ce sous amendement cet amendement
propose que les fonds d'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle puisse bénéficier à
d'autres entreprises que c'est
identifiées par les carsattes
l'amendement visa agrandir le périmètre
des entreprises pouvant bénéficier de
financement du fond en permettant ainsi
de laisser les partenaires sociaux la
liberté de fixer les orientations du
fond par ailleurs cet amendement propose
que le fond puisse également financer
les organismes de prévention de branches
qui ont conventionné avec des organismes
nationaux de prévention en effet les
organismes de prévention par branche
sont spécialisées dans leur domaine
d'activité ce qui leur permet de fournir
des conseils et des formations adaptées
aux risques et aux enjeux spécifiques à
chaque profession les organismes de
prévention par branche ont également une
meilleure compréhension des pratiques et
des évolutions de chaque secteur ainsi
que des contraintes auxquelles ils sont
confrontés ils peuvent donc proposer des
solutions pratiques et adaptées aux
réalités de chaque branche ce qui peut
améliorer leur acceptabilité et leur
efficacité
permettre de les financer directement
permet d'agir au plus près du terrain je
vous remercie merci alors l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
commençons par le sous amendement du
Gouvernement avis favorable au
sous-emmenons du gouvernement voilà donc
favorable aux autres pour les autres
sous amendements
il me paraissent identique mais la
Commission n'a pas eu le temps des
examiner parce qu'ils étaient très loin
je vais un dérive sont
identiques
la ville du gouvernement
par contre la Commission a suivi les
propositions de du gouvernement
merci Michel président sur les sous
amendements dans la mesure où
dans la mesure où le 5496 de 57 41 sont
identiques à l'amendement du
Gouvernement par construction bien
évidemment la vie est favorable ainsi
que sur le 21 36 de monsieur le
rapporteur merci
sont identiques les autres
ensuite un amendement de Monsieur Savary
au nom de la commission des affaires
sociales
le numéro 2135 monsieur le président
la vie du gouvernement
merci un amendement 21 37
le gouvernement favorable ensuite à
l'amendement 2104 rectifiés le président
requier le présente oui merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues c'était l'avant de la
Guillotin qui vise à intégrer les
travailleurs indépendants dans les
dispositifs de prévention et de
réparation de l'usure professionnelle
elle parle notamment aux professionnels
de santé libéraux qui connaissent aussi
leurs yeux en professionnel et appelle
tous leurs vœux des mécanismes de
compensation plusieurs études font état
de niveau de pénibilité physique et
psychologique importante liée notamment
aux impératifs du mode libéral et de la
participation au service de santé
publique qui sont plus nombreux que la
moyenne nationale à mettre en avant la
pénibilité physique de leur métier
jusqu'à 70% des infirmiers et 52% des
kinés ils révèle aussi un taux
importants d'hyperfraisses de Berlin
notamment ses infirmiers il y a une
charge mentale importante le manque de
temps et la difficulté à conseiller vie
personnelle et vie professionnelle aussi
les proposer ici de permettre aux
travailleurs nos salariés de financer
leur affiliation en service de
prévention et de santé au travail grâce
au fond d'investissement prévu à
l'article 9 1 sur salle bon pour le
alors l'avis de la commission d'abord
merci monsieur le Président pour
l'instant le fipu effectivement n'est
pas ouvert au profession indépendantes
puisqu'ils ne cotise pas à la branche
ATMP donc avis défavorable et on verra
ensuite l'avenir sur le ministre mais ma
vie monsieur salon
merci merci monsieur le Président le
présente amendement seulement présenté
mais non voté à cause du 49-3 sénatorial
vise à mettre en place des modalités de
contrôle de l'utilisation de ce fonds de
prévention de la pénibilité à ce sujet
la Cour des comptes appelait dans son
rapport sur les politiques publiques de
prévention en santé au travail dans les
entreprises que les enveloppes
budgétaires consacrées aux différents
programmes et consommer très tôt dans
l'année au fil de la demande de facto un
budget constant cela ne permet pas
d'assurer que ce sont des entreprises
qui en ont le plus besoin qui en
bénéficient à la différence d'un appel à
projet
la cour incite par ailleurs à mettre en
oeuvre sans tarder un programme de
contrôle du respect par les employeurs
de leurs obligations relatives en
matière de prévention de la pénibilité
ces modalités sont définies par le
décret en Conseil d'État aussi il est
important que l'utilisation par les
entreprises des moyens alloués dans le
cadre de ce fond face l'objet d'un
contrôle afin de s'assurer qu'ils ont
bien été utilisés conformément à leur
objet initial
vous le savez chers collègues la Cour
des comptes multiplie les études et les
alertes sur de nombreux pans des
politiques publiques de ce gouvernement
mais ici comme ailleurs et je pense aux
questions de rénovation thermique nous
constatons des fins de non-recevoir on
pourrait parler de politique de
l'autruche mais je voudrais profiter de
cet instant pour réhabiliter réhabiliter
ce brave animal qui contrairement à ce
gouvernement ne s'enfouit pas la tête
dans le sable
si la vie de la Commission
tant qu'il est effectivement important
de définir des modalités de
d'utilisation des ressources de FIP
humain et il en existe déjà c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons pensé
que cette précision n'était pas utile à
être inscrit directement dans la loi
donc avis défavorable
mais ma vie
un amendement qui porte ensuite
le numéro
3525 qui le présente Madame pour ces
Monges ou monsieur benaroche
madame ponce
oui mais merci monsieur le Président le
président amendement vise à mettre en
place des modalités de supervision de
l'utilisation du fond de prévention de
la pénibilité dont on discutons à
l'instant ces modalités sont définies
par décret en Conseil d'État il est
important que l'utilisation par les
entreprises des moyens alloués dans le
cadre de ce fond fasse l'objet d'une
supervision avant de s'assurer qu'ils
ont été bien été utilisés conformément à
leur objet initial
d'autant que nous avons voté avec
enthousiasme hier que les risques
chimiques faisaient partie avec les
trois risques
ergonomiques des risques pouvant donner
lieu
pouvant mobiliser le fond et donner lieu
donc à des actions de prévention
ce risque vous les l'aviez exclus ce
risque chimique des agents chimiques
vous l'aviez exclu du C2P sous des
prétextes de la difficulté à aller
suivre à les évaluer nous pensons que
c'est possible nous et qu'il convient
donc de superviser
l'utilisation de ce fond de prévention
de la pénibilité notamment
concernant ces risques chimiques si peu
considérer
j'en profite pour rappeler que les
Françaises ne doivent rien comprendre à
ce qui est au facteur de pénibilité qui
sont qui sont dans le C2P à ceux qui
peuvent mobiliser les actions de
prévention du fond du fonds de
prévention de la pénibilité donc
effectivement il y en a un qui a
désormais quatre facteurs mais ces
quatre facteurs sont pas dans le C2P et
le CDP en ont 6 mais le CDP n'est pas
éligible au fond donc je renouvelle que
il faut clarifier tout ça il faut un peu
de transparence et mettre les 10 dans
les deux dans le C2P et dans le fond
merci
l'amendement la vie de la commission
avis défavorable parce que nous pensons
que les modalités de superficie sont
déjà bien définies
le gouvernement mais ma vie que la
Commission l'amendement 432 rectifiés
monsieur benaroche
le président monsieur le ministre
d'après les données de la DARES alors la
DARES c'est la direction de l'animation
de la recherche des études et des
statistiques au sein du ministère du
Travail
13,5 millions de personnes en France
métropolitaine ce qui correspond à 61%
des salariés étaient exposés à un ou
plusieurs facteurs considérés de
pénibilité sur leur lieu de travail en
10,7% parmi ces 13,5 était concernés par
des contraintes physiques marquées
4,1 million par un environnement
agressif et 4,8 millions par des rythmes
de travail atypiques il y en a de plus
en plus il existe des emplois et des
profils de salariés qui ont tendance en
plus à cumuler ces différents facteurs
de pénibilité le problème monsieur le
ministre et que d'après la Farès la
surexposition facteur de pénibilité
s'ajoutent à d'autres risques majeurs
pour la santé par exemple ce sont les
catégories socio-professionnelles les
plus exposées aux risques professionnels
à savoir les ouvriers qualifiés et non
qualifiés qui sont aussi celles les plus
exposées à d'autres facteurs de risques
tels que la consommation de tabac
d'alcool ou une mauvaise alimentation
les disparités d'exposition aux facteurs
de pénibilité en milieu professionnel et
inégalités et les inégalités sociales de
santé s'engrodent il est donc essentiel
que les représentants des travailleurs
puissent être consultés sur les méthodes
d'investigation les modalités de gestion
des fonds mais surtout sur les modalités
d'identification des métiers des
activités exposant à des contraintes
physiques marqués alors si la
concertation avec les syndicats
patronaux comme salariés n'a pas nourri
le développement de cette réforme c'est
un euphémisme leur vision leur retour
d'expérience sont précieux dans la
réflexion sur la pénibilité ou sur les
facteurs d'usure si la novlogue est de
rigueur écoutant-les et écoutez-les
monsieur le ministre
avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur merci
si vous êtes Président je répondrai pour
cette amendement et le suivant
effectivement dans les échelons de
négociations il y a une certaine
gradation nous pensons que c'est au
niveau des accords de branches que
doivent être négocier notamment et
établir la liste des métiers et
activités sensibles et qu'au contraire
les les partenaires au niveau national
ou
ou interprofessionnel pardon sont
[Musique]
consulter au niveau et font partie de la
commission ATMP de la CNAM donc à chaque
niveau correspond une responsabilité
donc des favorable par rapport au schéma
que vous proposez pour les deux monsieur
le ministre
merci monsieur le Président le
gouvernement à la même remarque qu'il a
même position que sur la porteur sous
les deux amendements avec la même
répartition des rôles
un amendement 3803 qui le présente
Madame A poursuppoli
attention
merci monsieur le Président la création
du fonds d'investissement pour la
prévention de l'usure professionnelle
prévue dans cet article 9 et une des
très bonnes et très rare nouvelle de ce
projet raison de plus pour s'assurer
qu'il pourra bien remplir avec
efficacité ces missions le texte précise
que les modalités de gestion et
d'affectation sont précisées par décret
en Conseil d'État nous proposons que la
vie des organisations syndicales
représentatives soit aussi sollicitée en
amont de ce décret il existe une autre
bonne nouvelle liée à ce projet que vous
n'aviez pas prévu monsieur le ministre
les syndicats dans leur diversité
retrouvent une grande légitimité auprès
des salariés les uns comme les autres se
félicitent du nombre croissant de
nouveaux adhérents c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour notre démocratie c'est
peut-être la seule conséquence de votre
projet de réforme que l'on pourra sans
doute qualifier de gauche monsieur le
ministre grâce à vous les syndicats de
salariés vont se vont ressortir
renforcer merci pour eux nous vous
proposons ici de reconnaître leurs
fonctions je sais que votre volonté de
passer par-dessus les corps
intermédiaires est une marque de
fabrique de la démarche du président de
la République mais nous croyons de notre
côté que leur rôle est plus que jamais
incontournable le risque est que ce fond
d'investissement finissent par financer
des opérations cosmétiques comme des
campagnes d'affichage dans les
entreprises ou la mise en place de
dispositifs de sécurité inapplicable en
pratique par les travailleurs bref ne le
laissons pas aux éminents membres du
Conseil d'État fixé seul les modalités
d'application d'un fonds pour lequel les
syndicats nous semblent être les
meilleurs garants de son efficience
merci la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
défavorable monsieur président parce que
ces deux agences enfin en tout cas
l'Apec et la nacre ne sont pas des
instances consultatives
le même avis du gouvernement
un abonnement 3904 rectifiés madame
Cohen oui merci monsieur le Président
nous sommes favorables à l'objectif
affiché d'abonder un fond pour la
prévention mais il ne faut pas que cela
soit un alibi ce serait dommageable de
consacrer un milliard d'euros ou pour
être plus précis 250 millions d'euros
par an et que cette somme ne soit pas
utilisée avec pertinence quand on parle
d'usure au travail on pense souvent aux
salariés exposés aux intempéries à des
produits dangereux des travailleurs et
des travailleurs qui doivent assumer des
charges lourdes nous en avons beaucoup
parlé ici au niveau du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste mais il
existe aussi d'autres catégories qui
sont impactées auxquels on ne pense pas
obligatoirement de la même façon je veux
parler des cadres eux aussi avec les
nouvelles méthodes de management
connaissent l'usure au travail eux aussi
et elles aussi d'ailleurs sont
confrontées à l'absence de perspective
ou de reconnaissance professionnelle au
manque d'autonomie il et elles sont
souvent les premiers les premières à
être exposés au facteurs de risque
psychosociaux la moitié des cadres
affirme avoir fait un burn out dans leur
vie voilà pourquoi nous demandons par
cet amendement que l'association pour
l'emploi des cadres puis cette consulté
avant qu'un décret ne précise le
fonctionnement de ce fonds
d'investissement cela nous semble être
la moindre des choses que les
représentants des principaux intéressés
soient sollicités pour nous c'est un
gage de réussite pour ce fond mais je
dis bien pour nous puisque on voit bien
que ici la représentation parlementaire
quand elle est dans l'opposition et bien
maltraitée qu'on n'a pas envie non plus
de nous solliciter
merci la vie de la commission sur le
rapporteur
3904 monsieur le rapporteur
sur l'avis de l'association pour
l'emploi des cadres
oui 3904
sur le rapporteur
c'est la même oui bon
nous pensions que ce ne sont pas des
instances consultatives l'Apec ni la
nature
avis du gouvernement
identique
ensuite je vais passer à l'examen d'un
amendement et de deux sous amendements
qui vont faire l'objet d'une discussion
commune un amendement pour que chacun
repère bien qui porte le numéro
3907 et Madame varias le présente
je souhaite rappeler en préambule que
l'employeur en ce qui concerne la santé
la sécurité au travail à une obligation
de résultats nous avons parfois pris
l'habitude de parler de prévention comme
d'un synonyme de de bonnes postures de
dispositifs situés à la marche du
travail de petits ajustements or le
concept de prévention désigne
précisément la prévention primaire qui
vise à supprimer et j'insiste supprimé
la source du risque voir la réduire la
prévention secondaire qui vise à réduire
les atteintes aux individus exposés
enfin la prévention tertiaire curative
qui vise à réduire l'impact de
consécutif à une exposition
c'est pour ça que c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous parlons bien ici de
révolutionner l'ensemble de notre
appareil productif nous parlons de
révolution organisation orgas
organisationnel autant que matériel la
réforme des retraites de 2010 a
inévitablement conduit à des dépenses en
hausse de l'ordre de 1,8 milliards
d'après la direction de la recherche des
études de l'évaluation et des
statistiques 1,2 milliards pour les
pensions d'invalidité 600 millions pour
la vie du Haut Conseil des finances
publiques du 18 janvier 2023 qui
soutient que votre réforme n'entraînera
qu'un coup caché si l'on peut dire de
400 millions d'euros nous jugeons cette
réforme d'une violence inouïe elle le
sera d'autant plus que les dispositifs
que vous proposez comme des garde-fous
ou des solutions à même d'apporter des
de régler des problèmes dont vous êtes
responsables apparaissent doté de
moyenne dérisoires pour ces raisons nous
demandons l'avis de l'Association
nationale pour l'amélioration des
conditions de travail avant la rédaction
du décret qui fixe les conditions de
financement du fonds d'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle
alors
sous amendement numéro
5494 madame quand c'est mon
merci monsieur le Président alors c'est
amendement de notre de nos collègues du
groupe communiste République citoyen et
écologiques et bienvenue et accueillir
avec satisfaction par le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoire qui
si vous nous le permettez puisque c'est
un peu un dialogue entre nous seulement
va être sous-amendée
donc il s'agit vous l'avez dit
mes collègues de prévoir la consultation
de l'Association nationale pour
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
avant qu'un décret ne précise le
fonctionnement du fonds d'investissement
dans la prévision de l'usure
professionnelle c'est bien mais nous
soutenons suite à Orions également nous
les écologistes que les négociations
avec les partenaires sociaux
participent à l'édiction du
fonctionnement du fond
et des modalités aussi d'identification
des métiers et activités exposants au
facteurs pénibles
si le Gouvernement entend faire de la
concertation pour l'instant on n'a pas
bien vu mais si il entend toujours faire
de la concertation le grand principe qui
devra guider la construction de ces
politiques publiques
le droit du travail ne peut entrer dans
cette philosophie
qui déséquilibre le dialogue social
aussi les partenaires sociaux ne sont
pas des instances à seulement consulter
nous l'avons dit précédemment ce sont
les interlocuteurs privilégiés de la
négociation collective
garante du paritarisme et d'une
connexion réelle avec les personnes
concernées et la protection des droits
des travailleurs et travailleuses
je vous remercie de votre écoute
attentive
alors sous abonnement 54 94 je me suis
fait
immerci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le mini chers collègues donc c'est à
l'initiative de ma collègue Mélanie
Vogel avec un certain nombre de membres
de notre groupe que nous proposons ce
sous amendement donc qui sous-amand de
l'amendement de nos collègues du groupe
communiste
amendement nous saluons à défaut de
pouvoir le voter tout à l'heure c'est
amendement vise après avoir la
consultation de l'Association nationale
pour l'amélioration des conditions de
travail avant qu'un décret ne précise le
fonctionnement du fond d'investissement
dans la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle nous souhaiterions
également que les négociations avec les
partenaires sociaux participent à
l'édiction du fonctionnement du fond et
des modalités d'identification des
métiers et activités exposant aux
facteurs pénibles je crois que en
s'autorisant à définir par décret sans
réel négociation avec les partenaires
sociaux les modalités de fonctionnement
du fond le gouvernement peut facilement
outrepasser les position à sa lettre de
cadrage ou à son support de concertation
et imposer une réforme qui ne respecte
pas les principes du débat démocratique
et du dialogue social donc la prise en
compte de la voie des travailleurs et
des travailleurs et pourtant primordial
pour garantir qu'une mesure soit enfin
avec le terrain et protectrice il est
donc pertinent de compléter l'alinéa3 de
l'amendement 3907 par la phrase suivante
et après négociation avec les
organisations syndicales et les
organisations patronales je vous
remercie de votre attention
le 4681
peut-être les avis de la commission
avant de passer sur les sous amendements
toujours le même principe en ce qui
concerne les traits donc nous pensons
que c'est bien avant les décrits qu'il
faut associer les partenaires sociaux et
en conséquence à vie défavorable sur les
deux sous amendements identiques et sur
l'amendement
huit du gouvernement c'est exactement le
même raisonnement que les amendements
précédents donc la vie est défavorable
sur l'amendement est sous un moment
merci monsieur le Président je voulais
faire un rapide rappel au Règlement sur
leur type 44 bis juste pour la bonne
organisation de nos travaux et nous
permettre de suivre aussi au rythme de
présentation des amendements le déroulé
papier qui nous a été donné et indiqué à
13h30 n'est pas le même que celui qui
figure sur l'écran et je dois vous
avouer nous sommes quelque peu perturbés
dans la présentation et l'organisation
la distribution de nos amendements
c'était juste ce que je voulais dire et
je pense que il serait bon soit on fait
une petite pause soit on réajuste les
éléments
je préciserai mais ce qui est indiqué
sur le tableau fait suite à certains
abonnements qui ont été retirés donc les
sous amendements tombent donc vous avez
bien ici et nous allons passer
immédiatement à l'amendement
4681 oui monsieur le Président c'est
indiqué voilà Monsieur verdict oui merci
monsieur le Président donc l'amendement
4680 à l'initiative de ma collègue
Mélanie Vogel
alors qu'un projet de loi de finance
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale et
généralement par nature de nature
financière la Linéa 18 vise à garantir
qu'au moment du constat d'une invalidité
les victimes soient informées des
bénéfices en matière de retraite
auxquelles elles auront désormais droit
notamment l'abaissement de l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite alors qu'on ne
peut que saluer cette disposition en soi
le projet de loi reste malheureusement
vague car il prévoit deux décrets il
laisse ainsi deux questions importantes
à la discrétion du gouvernement or les
deux questions sont quand même
essentielles la première de ces
questions elle concerne les modalités de
cette information le projet de loi de
l'indique pas enfin le projet de loi ne
spécifie pas l'âge avant lequel la
victime doit être informée de ses
bénéfices or cette question n'est pas
négligeable parce que si l'information
se fait trop tard la victime ne pourra
pas adapter son parcours afin de pouvoir
bénéficier pleinement de ces éventuels
bénéfices en vue de cet enjeu nous
demandons à ce que ces deux décrets
soient pris en Conseil d'État
la vie de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
il y a pas du tout dans l'exposé des
motifs de rapport avec cet amendement
puisque nous sommes à l'article 9 nous
sommes plus à l'article 8 en conséquence
il s'agit là de d'un décret en Conseil
d'État pour lequel vous demandez une
négociation préalable c'est la vie donc
défavorable puisque ce même veine même
peine
monsieur le ministre mais ma vie
un amendement 21 39 monsieur le
rapporteur
amendement rédactionnel donc
voilà un moment il est gouvernement il
est favorable
alors chers collègues pour répondre pour
répondre tout à l'heure la question qui
a été posée
et le faire dans l'ordre
il y avait un amendement 2140
qui venait de la commission des affaires
sociales
cet amendement a été retiré
et il est sous amendements tombent en
conséquence voilà pour
expliciter
cette évolution
ensuite
nous avons un amendement qui porte le
numéro 2141
il a été retiré
elle est sous amendement tombe en
conséquence
vous devez donc repartir
sur l'alliance orange
se donne le temps d'une petite
respiration
alors
examiner le 286
madame meunier
merci monsieur le Président l'amendement
2876 on est d'accord par cet amendement
nous souhaitons favoriser l'effectivité
à court terme de la mesure visant à
réintroduire les critères de pénibilité
telles qu'ils sont définis à l'origine
dans le conte personnel de pénibilité je
ne reviens pas sur la description on en
a beaucoup parlé nous estimons que les
branches professionnelles doivent
établir des listes de métiers et
d'activités particulièrement exposée au
risque professionnel et nous ne
souhaitons pas simplement en laisser la
faculté à un horizon un défini mais bien
inscrire ces listes établies dans les
six mois suivant la promulgation de la
loi permettez-moi monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre un aparté parce
qu'en l'état actuel de nos débats ou de
ce qu'il en reste choisissant de la
promulgation de cette loi nous la
souhaitons pas ou à ce moment là nous la
souhaitons repousser synédié comme l'a
fait Jacques Chirac en 2006 concernant
le Contrat Première Embauche il vous
reviendra monsieur le ministre dans les
prochains jours de trouver une porte de
sortie à ce conflit social massif que la
France insiste en ce moment pour revenir
à l'effectivité de cette de ces critères
de pénibilité par les biais de
convention il nous semblait déterminant
d'appuyer le dialogue social en le
rendant obligatoire et sans délai de
prescription
j'ai un amendement qui est identique
présenté par le groupe communiste un
mariage
le président
objectifs calendaire aux branches
professionnelles pour établir les listes
de métiers d'activités exposés aux
facteurs de risque professionnels la
santé la sécurité des travailleurs
doivent être des préoccupations majeures
bien sûr pour toute société les facteurs
de risque professionnels tels que
l'exposition produit chimiques le bruit
les vibrations les postures
contraignantes ou encore le travail en
hauteur peuvent avoir des conséquences
graves sur la santé et la qualité de vie
des travailleurs il est donc crucial que
nous travaillons tous ensemble pour
identifier ces facteurs de risque
professionnels et mettre en place des
mesures préventives efficaces dans ce
contexte les branches professionnelles
bien évidemment un rôle clé à jouer
elles connaissent mieux que quiconque
les risques spécifiques aux différents
métiers et activités de leur secteur
elles sont donc les mieux placés pour
établir des listes de métiers et
d'activités exposées aux facteurs de
risque professionnels et pour proposer
des mesures préventives adaptées
cependant bien évidemment il est
important que je travaille soit fait de
manière proactive et transparente c'est
pourquoi nous proposons de donner un
objectif calendaire aux branches
professionnelles pour établir ses listes
et pour les rendre publics cela
permettra aux travailleurs aux
employeurs et aux autorités compétentes
de mieux comprendre les risques liés aux
différents métiers et activités et de
travailler ensemble pour mettre en place
des mesures de prévention efficaces je
vous invite cette amendement
viennent donc contribuer à améliorer la
santé la sécurité des travailleurs en
favorisant une meilleure identification
et une meilleure prévention des facteurs
des risques
la vie de la Commission sur ces deux
amendements identiques
président effectivement
la liste des métiers et des activités
exposés étaient établies par les
branches professionnelles et on ne peut
on peut contraindre effectivement les
partenaires sociaux et négocier mais on
peut pas les contraindre à conclure
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous ne
souhaitons pas fixer un délai comme ça
contraint de 6 mois donc la vie
défavorable pour ces deux amendements
bien un amendement vous vouliez faire un
rappel au règlement
merci monsieur le Président titre de
l'article 44 bis en fait je souhaitais
comprendre vous venez d'annoncer la
suppression d'un amendement qui n'avait
pas été annoncé et qui faisait tomber
une trentaine bon je vois bien qu'on est
en train d'accélérer les débats
peut-être pour permettre nous permettre
demain de manifester mais je voulais
savoir s'il était possible dès lors que
ça n'est pas annoncé par les porteurs de
l'amendement d'avoir la liste des
amendements qui vont être supprimés dans
la suite de la discussion ce qui nous
permettrait de savoir lesquels devront
être défendues et lesquels n'auront pas
à être défendus d'autant plus ces
amendements d'un temps pas soumis au
vote pour la plupart d'entre eux ce
serait bien qu'on sache qu'on puisse
anticiper tout le monde gagnerait du
temps oui
pour la clarté de nos débats
d'amendement peut être retiré à tout
moment
alors nous passons
l'amendement et 5 sous amendements
donc j'ai un amendement 2142 qui est
retiré
et donc les sous amendements de fait
puis nous passons un amendement 2143 il
est présenté par monsieur le rapporteur
au nom de la commission des affaires
sociales c'est également un amendement
rédactionnel monsieur le président
trois amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune
le 3815 monsieur Julias merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mais
mes chers collègues sauf mieux informés
il nous semble que les années à 32 et 33
sont déjà satisfaits par l'article du
Code du travail est le
4163-7 je vous en donne une lecture très
rapide le titulaire du compte
professionnel de prévention peut décider
d'affecter en toute ou partie les points
inscrits sur son compte à une ou
plusieurs des trois utilisations
suivantes etc il me semble que la mesure
que vous proposez monsieur le ministre
et soir redonnant de soi superfétatoire
merci monsieur le Président merci le
sous-abondement qui le présente 5300
93 il est Madame Libin
il n'est pas soutenu
l'amendement 2145 est retiré
et les sous amendements qui vont avec le
Son aussi
un amendement
qui porte le numéro 3912
et il est présenté par Monsieur gay
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en effet
nous proposons par cet amendement
d'inscrire dans le texte dans le texte
pardonnez-moi que les conditions de
départ pour carrière longue et les
conditions des parents anticipées en
retraite sur l'objet d'une négociation
préalable avec les organisations
syndicales et patronales et
permettez-moi de citer
la loi de modernisation du dialogue
social dites-lois du président de
Larcher je me permets d'en citer trois
lignes
oui bah oui quand même
[Musique]
attendez je viens de perdre la ligne
vous voulez que je vous les souffle
vous auriez pu tout projet de réforme
envisagée par le gouvernement qui porte
sur les relations individuelles et
collectives de travail l'emploi et la
formation professionnelle et qui relève
du champ de la négociation nationale et
interprofessionnelle fait l'objet d'une
concertation préalable avec les
organisations syndicales de salariés et
d'employeurs représentatives je dis ça
pourquoi
Monsieur le Ministre parce que vous
savez qui est un débat sur les
négociations qui ont
conduit à ce projet loi et les deux
principaux secrétaires généraux de la
CFDT puis de la CGT on dit que le
dialogue social avait été quasiment
inexistant et que seulement il y a
quelques semaines ils avaient eu la
première ministre 5 minutes au téléphone
et nous nous pensons pas sur ces bancs
que c'est un dialogue social
satisfaisant et je vous refais une
demande
l'Inter syndical a demandé à être reçu
par le Président de la République le
président de la République a répondu
c'est le temps du débat parlementaire
bon depuis que vous avez activé le 49-3
je pense qu'on ne peut plus dire que
nous sommes dans le temps du débat
parlementaire donc si vous plaît seul
ministre refaite passer le message à
l'Élysée et recevez l'intersyndicale je
vous remercie
sous amendement
5486 madame poncemonge
merci monsieur le président
alors il s'agit de après les mots et les
assurés d'ajouter les mots notamment à
l'attente de leur 5ème anniversaire
excusez moi je vais très vite parce que
je vais rapidement parce que la vitesse
ou la majorité y compris leur rapporteur
retire leurs amendements j'avais peur
d'être interrompu avant la fin de mes
deux minutes et vous savez l'intérêt que
j'ai à vous parler donc au moins là
c'est bon je peux aller jusqu'à deux
minutes c'est bien je m'aperçois
d'ailleurs que le rapporteur ou la
majorité retire leurs amendements ils
croient pas tellement effectivement aux
améliorations qui prétendent apporter à
ce texte effectivement la seule chose
qu'ils intéresse c'est de voter au plus
vite ce texte nous sommes ici dans un
simulacre de débat et je m'en excuse moi
pour le Sénat au nom du Sénat auprès des
organisations syndicales et des salariés
parce que ici nous parlons de la
pénibilité nous parlons des conséquences
les plus graves de l'article 7 que vous
avez voté et effectivement vous disiez à
l'article 7 nous on discutera au 8 c'est
ça qui nous intéresse ça vous intéresse
tellement que vous retirez vos
amendements voilà alors bon maintenant
pour les deux minutes qui me restent je
vous l'ai dit sur cet amendement je sais
pas ce qui me seconde que de nombreuses
sources selon démontré le nombre de
ruptures de contrastes à 59 et 60 ans et
très important l'inédit que observé dans
sa dernière étude ça c'est important
effectivement c'est plus important que
de retirer les amendements à 59 ans
l'étude démontre l'existence d'une nette
hausse des ruptures conventionnelles à
59 ans au total 17% des ouvertures de
droits de chômage à 56 ans le son à la
suite d'une rupture et ce chiffre grimpe
à 25% à 59 ans et c'est Seigneur bien
plus souvent au chômage de longue durée
vont pâtir de votre réforme
et après avoir bâti je le rappelle de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage qui
ramène leur durée à 27 mois au lieu de
36 ah ben c'est désolé merci de vous
avez l'amendement 5487 monsieur ferrique
oui merci monsieur le Président je vois
que nous avons eu raison entre Mélanie
Vogel et Madame pansemont de déposer par
inadvertance peut-être le même sous
amendement comme ça je pourrais prendre
la suite de ces explications qui étaient
incomplètes donc selon la Dares 68% des
seniors durablement exposés un facteur
de pénibilité sont en emploi contre
75%. 75% pour ceux qui n'ont pas été
exposés un facteur de exposé en plus la
pénibilité augmente et plus la
pénibilité pardon augmente et plus le
taux d'emploi décroît 66% des seniors
qui ont deux facteurs de pénibilité sont
en emploi et 62% s'ils ont trois
facteurs ceci s'explique très simplement
c'est que dès qu'un métier est pénible
dès que le corps est usé dès que la
vulnérabilité de ce senior est consumé
l'entreprise sépare de lui au lieu de
faire ce qui est écrit et dit dans la
loi c'est-à-dire proposer une
requalification offrir un poste moins
pénible offrir des droits à la formation
selon la Dares l'accès à la formation
décroît avec l'âge à caractéristique
d'emploi identique les plus de 50 ans se
forment moins que leur cadet leur taux
d'accès fléchissant nettement après 55
ans 62% des salariés de moins de 50 ans
ont accès à une formation et à peine 40
% pour les plus de 55 ans cela montre
bien qu'il se passe quelque chose à 55
ans cela montre bien que l'information
est importante qu'elle devrait même être
obligatoire et que c'est cette
information qui pourra peut-être
permettre de maintenir les seniors en
emploi notamment les plus précaires les
ouvriers et les employés dont on connaît
le très faible taux d'emploi à
l'approche de la soixantaine notre
amendement est donc un amendement qui
renforce celui de notre collègue et va
dans le sens d'un renforcement du bon
usage du C2P
pour ces Monges 5588
merci Monsieur le
président mais il me semble que c'est le
même là vous avez le même que celui que
j'ai défendu rapidement dans un premier
temps et très lentement après c'est le
même donc il y a je vais demander l'avis
de la commission sur l'amendement 3815
puis l'amendement 3812 elle est sous
amendements qu'il accompagne
donc nous commençons pour avoir votre
avis sur le 3815 + 3912 elle est sous
amendements allez-y
activement je commencerai par la
susamment déposé de façon identique par
inadvertance c'est vrai ça peut arriver
une fois mais voilà
et quand un amendement qui concerne
l'information des assurés sur le compte
professionnel de prévention je vais vous
rendre heureux
pour une fois
il est satisfait et vous il est
satisfait parce que la Commission aussi
avait le même souci d'information de nos
concitoyens et après il y a
effectivement des
âges spécifiques où il faut faire une
meilleure information voilà ça c'est
pour l'information mais je partage vos
propos en ce qui concerne les pics les
pics où on voit bien que il y a des pics
de chômage qui correspondent justement à
deux à trois ans avant le départ en
retraite il risque d'être décalé c'est
pour ça qu'on vous a proposé toute une
stratégie autour notamment on essaye de
l'emploi seniors ou d'autres dispositifs
qui doivent permettre justement de
prendre l'employé militaire des seniors
un peu plus importante donc compte tenu
du fait qu'il est satisfait je vous
demanderai plutôt de le retirer sinon je
serais vraiment désolé de vous donner un
avis encore une fois défavorable
alors
la vie du gouvernement
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
avis défavorable mais pour la même
raison je confirme ce que dit monsieur
le rapporteur l'amendement est satisfait
merci nous allons maintenant examiner
un amendement avec deux sous amendement
dans le cas du discussion commune
l'amendement 21-44 monsieur le
rapporteur au nom de la commission des
affaires sociales c'est amendement
nous le présentez le 21 44
6 que j'ai là 44
21 44 non excusez-moi
simplement
simplement très rapidement le C2P
pourrait être mobilisé à tout moment de
la carrière des salariés
pour un projet de reconversion
professionnelle et la prise en charge
dans ce cadre de formation sera ouverte
également au demeures aux demandeurs
d'emploi et nous voulons garantir les
droits du salaire et en congé de
reconversion c'est pour ça que nous
avons préféré encadrer spécifiquement la
loi à travers cette amendement merci
ensuite il y a deux sous amendements
5491 madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président et merci
monsieur le rapporteur de ne pas avoir
retiré cet amendement qui me permet de
présenter mon sous amende
ce sous amendement renforce
effectivement les dispositions établies
par le rapporteur concernant le C2P le
C2P est un dispositif extrêmement
important permettant aux employés de
faire valoir un départ en retraite
anticipée un passage en temps partiel où
la validation d'une formation
à ce propos je veux dire que vous voyez
qu'il y a trois modalités pour faire
valoir les points qu'on a accumulé soit
un départ en retraite anticipée soit un
passage en temps partiel ou la
validation d'une formation dans les
faits dans les faits les gens sont
tellement usés qui ne demandent pas du
tout la formation si tu demandes encore
presque pas Epsilon un passage à temps
partiel à 80%, il demande un départ
anticipé et ce simple choix devrait
quand même nous éclairer sur la qualité
des conditions de travail en France qui
font que voilà il préfère ça et
puisqu'on parle du CDP je voudrais dire
aussi
que le C2P est essentiellement
utiliser par les hommes 4/5 des
bénéficiaires sont des hommes et cela
revient à ce qui était dit avec
l'amendement de notre collègue Mélanie
Vogel sur le fait que les critères de
pénibilité qui donne droit à des points
dans le C2P sont des critères de
l'industrie de l'industrie
manufacturière où les hommes sont sur
représentés par contre aucune étude
aucun travail n'est fait sur les
facteurs de pénibilité des services et
comme par hasard enfin comme par hasard
les services c'est là où les femmes sont
sur représentées et vous avez des pays
au Québec ailleurs qui ont regardé les
les facteurs de pénibilité et qui ont
mis en regard des métiers de femmes à ba
mince alors
enfin donc voilà c'est pour que
l'employeur ne pose se poser à la
demande je dirais la Suisse
monsieur ferrique le présente
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
les écarts entre les travailleurs entre
les travailleurs effectivement déclarés
par les employeurs et les travailleurs
soumis à des facteurs de pénibilité
laisse la Cour des comptes il faut le
dire dubitatif sur l'usage qui est faite
du dispositif par certains employeurs
selon la Cour je cite son rapport
l'ampleur des écarts au moins en ce qui
concerne certains critères montrent une
appropriation très en deçà des objectifs
du dispositif par les employeurs
concernés malgré l'absence de coûts pour
ces derniers rendant nécessaire la mise
en oeuvre d'actions de sensibilisation
et de contrôle la couragoute je cite
toujours le dispositif n'a plus aucune
vertu de prévention il n'est pas à la
hauteur des objectifs qui lui étaient
assignés dans un contexte où l'âge de
départ en retraite recule par ailleurs
fermer les guillemets selon les chiffres
de l'assurance vieillesse seul 3300
personnes ont ainsi pu partir plus tôt
grâce aux comptes professionnels de
prévention c'est de paix incapacité
permanente en 2021 soit 0,5 % des
départs quand par ailleurs plus de
100000 nouveaux retraités continuent
chaque année de liquider leur retraite
au titre de l'invalidité et de
l'inaptitude ce faible taux de départ
est potentiellement imputable en partie
à l'augmentation en parallèle des
ruptures de contrat à l'approche de la
soixantaine laissant ainsi à penser que
certains employeurs préfèrent se séparer
de leurs salariés plutôt que de leur
permettre d'activer leur C2P il est
important de lutter contre ce phénomène
et c'est précisément ce que tente de
faire l'amendement du rapporteur que
nous saluons que nous sous-amendons mais
il semble important d'ajouter une
protection supplémentaire au
bénéficiaire en empêchant les employeurs
de refuser ou de contourner l'activation
du C2P d'où le rajout de cette phrase
l'employeur ne peut s'opposer à cette
demande cet amendement tente de proposer
une solution en actant que l'employeur
ne peut opposer un refus alors l'avis de
la commission monsieur le rapporteur sur
ces deux favorables parce qu'il ne me
semble pas utile d'ajouter cette
précision à mon amendement
sur le deuxième donc de doublement
défavorable monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le Président de la vie du
Gouvernement est favorable sur
l'amendement de monsieur le rapporteur
et défavorable sur les deux sous
amendements pour les raisons qu'il a
évoqué merci
monsieur Savary un amendement qui porte
le numéro
2146 un monde coordination au sein du
Code du travail monsieur le président
favorable un amendement 21 47 monsieur
le rapporteur
un amendement
4685 qui le présente monsieur benaroche
je me suis fait
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
mini chers collègues ce projet de loi
vise donc à mettre en place un fond pour
faciliter la reconversion
professionnelle des travailleuses et
travailleurs qui sont particulièrement
exposés au risque d'usure
professionnelle je me permets de résumer
les deux critiques les plus importantes
de mon groupe à l'encontre de ce
dispositif premièrement ce dispositif
est largement insuffisant pour répondre
au problème de l'usure professionnelle
qui se trouverait encore aggraver si
l'âge des légal de départ était reporté
comme le prévoit la réforme ceci dit il
conviendra rappeler que la procédure
prévue et plus que floue le projet de
loi prévoit que les conditions de sa
mise en œuvre seront définies par décret
serait donc à la discrétion du
gouvernement c'est pourquoi nous avons
déposé des amendements pour concrétiser
la procédure et pour nous assurer
qu'elle soit au plus près des réalités
du terrain dans l'unique objectif de
garantir l'accès des personnes victimes
de l'usure professionnelle à ce
dispositif de reconversion par exemple
nous avions déposé un amendement pour
permettre aux syndicats et aux
organisations patronales de négocier les
conditions de la procédure d'instruction
et de prise en charge administrative et
financière en complément le présent
amendement vise à ce que les conditions
ne soient pas définies par décret
ensuite mais par des crayons conseils
d'État alors l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur sur l'amendement
c'est toujours le même type d'amendement
donc défavorable
un amendement
4683 monsieur benaroche merci monsieur
le président
ce projet de loi vise à mettre en place
un fond d'investissement dans la
prévention de l'usure professionnelle de
doté d'un milliard d'euros sur sur 4 ans
tandis que ce fort comprendrait
plusieurs volets un de ses volets
permettrait le co-financement des
projets de reconversion professionnelle
d'une part cette mesure n'est qu'une
goutte d'eau dans l'océan puisqu'il
faudrait faire beaucoup plus pour
réellement tenir code de la pénibilité
du travail on l'a démontré tout à
l'heure il faudrait par exemple remettre
les quatre critères de pénibilité au
travail supprimé en 2019 sous la pulsion
d'Emmanuel Macron cette réforme
d'ailleurs aurait pu être l'occasion de
les réintroduire mais on les cherche en
vain dans le projet de loi monsieur le
ministre
d'autre part ce gouvernement semble
avoir oublié l'existence des syndicats
qu'en est-il des manifestations
qu'en est-il de la rencontre avec
Emmanuel Macron mais au lieu de remettre
en cause cette réforme le gouvernement
semble au mieux vouloir minimiser leur
ampleur et au pire vouloir contester le
bienfait durant des syndicats le projet
de réforme est maintenu comme si de rien
n'était comme s'il n'y avait personne
qui s'y opposé ni même d'ailleurs les
parlementaires de gauche ici présents
pire le rôle central des syndicats est
oublié tout au long du texte le
dispositif visé par cet amendement est
un des exemples de cet oubli la réforme
confie en effet à des commissions
paritaires et terre professionnelles
l'instruction à la prise en charge
administrative et financière des projets
de reconversion professionnelle mais
prévoit que le déroulé précis de cette
procédure destruction et de prise en
charge soit définie par décret or
si l'on veut réellement mettre en place
une procédure adaptée aux réalités de
terrain si l'on veut vraiment faciliter
les reconversions professionnelles on ne
peut pas planifier une telle procédure
sans une quelconque consultation du mode
du travail c'est pourquoi cet amendement
de mode à ce que les syndicats les
organisations pas trop dans le
représentatives puissent négocier cette
procédure ce sont eux qui connaissent au
mieux les réalités du terrain non
monsieur le rapporteur quelle est la vie
de la Commission
identique alors maintenant monsieur le
rapporteur vous allez nous présenter
l'amendement qui porte le numéro
2148 au nom de la Commission
merci c'est un amendement qui amène
quand même un dispositif nouveau et dans
la transition entre la vie active et la
vie et sédentaire qui peut se faire en
diminuant progressivement son temps de
travail c'est pour ça que nous proposons
de plafonner en ce qui concerne les
points à qui dans le C2P pour l'activité
partielle rémunira à temps complet de
façon à ce que les salariés puissent en
garder des points pour arriver en fin de
carrière et justement utiliser ce cette
particularité d'avoir une activité
partielle rémunira est en complet plutôt
en fin de carrière avant de la l'âge de
liquidation de la retraite ça peut être
une avancée dans le cas de la prise en
compte de la transition en ce qui
concerne l'emploi des seniors
le gouvernement il est favorable
et nous allons maintenant examiner 12
amendements qui vont faire l'objet d'une
discussion commune d'abord un amendement
de la commission monsieur le rapporteur
de 1149
écoutez 2149
porté sur la suppression du suivi
médical spécifique des salariés exposés
aux risques
ergonomiques n'ont pas que nous voulions
pas qu'il soit pris en charge bien sûr
par la médecine du travail mais
simplement nous pensons que à force
mettre des bornes on arrive plus à voir
et des dates prévisibles d'examens on
arrive à pu laisser il me semble-t-il
une organisation suffisante en ce qui
concerne la prise en compte dans le
cadre de la santé au travail mais cet
amendement n'a pas été retenu me
semble-t-il dans les
les par les amendements donc c'est tout
en contrepartie je donnerai un avis
négatif sur l'ensemble des amendements
qui suivront parce que il garde
effectivement il parle de médecine du
santé au travail alors que nous nous
proposons la suppression à travers cette
amendement
alors
l'amendement
3270 qui le présente Madame ponce
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
rapporteur vous avez raison il faut
supprimer la médecine du travail parce
que c'est la médecine du travail qui
fait le lien entre le travail et la
santé vous voyez ça un médecin
généraliste il peut pas il faut ce lien
est au cœur de la médecine du travail et
effectivement souvent vous demandez que
ça parte à d'autres instances au médecin
conseil au médecin traitant etc si on
pouvait délier les atteintes à la santé
de la pénibilité du travail là c'est
c'est je pense que c'est votre grand
rêve alors effectivement nous ne
présentons amendement a pour but de
restaurer la visite médicale obligatoire
à l'embauche et périodique pour
l'ensemble des salariés dont ce
particulièrement exposé au facteurs
mentionnés au premier alinéa du 1 de
l'article
l4161-1
la loi dite el khomri a rendu
particulièrement inéfective la mission
de prévention assurée par la médecine du
travail parce que je rappelle que quand
un travailleur a des problèmes avant de
le mettre en inaptitude la médecine du
travail Demande à l'employeur d'adapter
le poste car c'est la médecine du
travail c'est ça elle va demander à
l'employeur d'adapter le poste et elle
va pas chercher que comme vous que le
salarié s'adapte aux mais au poste qui
n'est pas modifié c'est et ça c'est sûr
seule la médecine du travail peut le
faire les médecins traitant ne peuvent
pas le faire les médecins conseils de la
sécurité ne peuvent pas le faire donc je
comprends cette atteinte que vous menez
depuis des décennies contre la médecine
du travail
et ses motivations profondes donc la loi
donc je le disais el khomri a rendu
particulièrement inéfectible la mission
de prévention assurée par la médecine du
travail et qui est c'est très bien j'ai
fait trop de digressions je vous
remercie monsieur le président
merci merci monsieur le Président
plusieurs d'entre nous ici se
souviennent encore des débats lors de
l'examen de la loi el khomri parmi les
dispositions qui ont pour nous au niveau
du groupe communiste était synonyme de
recul des droits des salariés on peut
citer la fin de la visite médicale
obligatoire à l'embauche remplacé par
une visite d'information et de
prévention largement insuffisante cette
substitution a été faite sous prétexte
de simplification mais la vérité c'est
que notre pays manquait déjà en 2016
lors de l'examen de cette loi de
médecins du travail et que le déclin se
poursuit nous avions rappelé à l'époque
que se déclin cette pénurie était
organisée on ne facilitant pas par
exemple la formation de cette spécialité
la protection des salariés est pourtant
une question de santé publique comme la
collègue l'a dit et assouplir le rythme
des visites médicales est une aberration
limiter les visites d'embauche au
postulant un poste à risque ne suffit
pas tous les salariés peuvent être
concernés par des difficultés ne pas
concevoir les choses ainsi les réalités
sociales et médicales des millions de
salariés sont confrontés à des risques
médicaux et psychosociaux que seule la
compétence médicale est à même de
prévenir nous proposons donc de
remplacer les alinéas 40 à 43 pour
établir l'obligation de visite médicale
d'embauche et périodique tel que établi
par les dispositions législatives en
vigueur avant le 1er janvier 2017
c'est-à-dire pour l'ensemble des
salariés si l'on suit votre logique de
pousser les salariés à travailler plus
longtemps vous avez tout intérêt à ce
qu'il soit en bonne santé tout au long
de leur carrière si j'ai un peu de
cynisme notre amendement y contribue et
cela est d'autant plus simple que pour
vous d'émettre un avis favorable que
vous n'étiez pas à l'oeuvre de cette
réforme de la médecine du travail je
vous remercie
sous amendement
4954 madame Poumirol merci monsieur le
Président je voudrais d'abord dire à
monsieur le rapporteur combien j'ai
trouvé étonnant de sa part
qu'elle puisse demander une suppression
d'une consultation médicale ça me paraît
aberrant dans la mesure et en plus il
dit que la médecine du travail
fonctionne bien et vous le savez on en a
discuté lors de la loi santé et sécurité
au travail comme il y a la médecine du
travail est en difficulté et combien il
nous manque et de médecins du travail et
comme il nous manque d'infirmiers
spécialistes de la santé au travail donc
l'amendement de nos collègues
communistes et écologistes qui veulent
remettre en piste la nécessité d'une
visite médicale nous paraît très
justifiée le risque de maladies
professionnelles n'a pas diminué bien au
contraire et nous pouvons nous ne
pouvons nous satisfaire de cet état de
fait nous vous devons tout faire pour
limiter les conséquences de ces facteurs
de pénibilité que vous avez en 2017
supprimer je n'y reviens pas de façon
plus générale je dis la prévention et la
grande oubliée de nos politiques
publiques
il nous faut changer de paradigme non
plus être dans le soin le curatif en
permanence mais dans la santé c'est à
dire réunir toutes les conditions pour
vivre en bonne santé aujourd'hui le
budget de la Sécurité sociale c'est 97%
du soin et à peine 3% pour la prévention
et je dirais même si on parle de père
prévention primaire celle qui la plus
importante c'est à dire c'est elle qui
favorise le sport la diététique la
qualité de l'air la qualité de l'eau etc
tous ces facteurs exogènes qui sont en
facteur en fait responsable de 90% des
maladies chroniques ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui l'exposome tous ces facteurs
là ne sont pas pris en compte dans le
business de sécurité sociale donc nous
demandons effectivement que la visite
soit régulièrement organisée et nous
nous demandons à ce qu'elle soit portée
à tous les 18 mois
merci monsieur le Président de je trouve
qu'il est dommage que fonction de
l'article 44 3 de a constitution et le
règlement intérieur en sont l'article 46
bis sont on ne puisse pas débattre de
cette question dans dans l'hémicycle
parce que vraiment sur la question de la
médecine du travail c'est quelque chose
qui est extrêmement important et
contrairement à ce que viennent nous
dire le rapporteur qui lui préconise
plutôt la disparition de la médecine et
bien vous pourrez nous l'expliquer après
oui voilà et bien moi je dis simplement
que c'est un élément essentiel du monde
du travail et c'est également un élément
essentiel dans le cas de la santé
publique la médecine du travail on le
sait elle est gérée par des
organisations paritaires de type
associatif et peut-être que c'est ça qui
zen c'est parce que là on y retrouve
bien entendu les représentants des
salariés les syndicats qui qui aussi
participent à cette gestion la médecine
du travail est souvent le seul lieu que
consulte les salariés et très souvent ni
détecte des maladies qui sont éliées à
l'exercice de la profession mais aussi
des maladies
graves cachées voire sournoise et que ça
participe à la détection effectivement
il a la prévention malheureusement
également les employeurs souvent ne
respectent pas les périodicités des
visites médicales qui sont pourtant
obligatoires et par rapport à cela et
bien aujourd'hui la périodicité est à 24
mois moi j'irai beaucoup plus loin que
ce qui a été proposé précédemment je
propose que nous ayons une péri odicité
à 12 mois parce qu'effectivement c'est
important merci beaucoup le moment 4956
monsieur monsieur le Président
l'amendement du CRCE vise à rétablir une
visite médicale obligatoire dans les
deux mois suivant l'embauche il nous
semble préférable de prévoir la première
visite dès le premier mois suivant
l'embauche afin de s'assurer que le
nouvel embauché peut assumer les tâches
qui lui sont confiées en toute sécurité
et sans exposer sa santé ou risquer un
accident
il s'agit d'amendement concernant au
premier chef la santé des salariés et je
déplore comme mon collègue l'annonce
tout à l'heure de notre rapporteur qui
veut supprimer purement et simplement la
médecine du travail
mes chers collègues nous sommes en train
de présenter des amendements qui ne
seront ni discutés ni voté c'est bien
dommage concernant la santé de nos
concitoyens et des travailleurs
chacun comprendra ici le caractère
inédit de la situation mais c'est ainsi
nous représentation nationale somme
bridée et contraint à l'expression
minimum et à ne pas pouvoir faire notre
travail de parlementaire et ce de votre
faute monsieur le ministre Mesdames et
Messieurs les collègues de la droite
sénatoriale cependant quand bien même
vous nous empêchez de débattre avec ce
49-3 sénatoriales que vous avez dégainé
comme une dernière arme contre nous les
français ont compris que nous nous
opposons absolument au projet de réforme
que leur prépare le gouvernement avec
l'intime complicité de la droite
sénatoriale
un amendement 5719 madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président alors je
veux dire que notre sous amendement
je considère notre sous amendement comme
un amendement de repli du groupe
communiste et aussi du groupe socialiste
je veux dire aucun de nos trois groupes
n'est mieux 10 ans sur cette question
simplement il y a un effet cliquet si
vous voulez moi j'ai connu la médecine
du travail avec une visite annuelle elle
est passée à tous les deux ans elle est
passée à tous les 5 ans je vois que tous
les 10 ans il irait bien sur ses bancs
et donc effectivement quand on demande
de revenir à la visite annuelle c'est
difficile c'est l'effet cliquet quoi on
a l'impression de demander des choses
extraordinaires alors qu'elles ont
existé moi je l'ai connu vous voyez donc
il y a pas je suis pas très jeune mais
je n'ai pas 100 ans non plus donc voilà
ce que je voudrais dire c'est
tous les tous les ans tous les deux ans
vous voyez actuellement c'est tous les 5
ans maintenant et tous les deux ans il
faut avoir une surveillance médicale
particulière
c'est noté renforcer une surdisance
médicale renforcée alors dans la branche
de l'aide et du soin à domicile ça fait
que les soignants les aides-soignantes
comme elles sont confrontées à des
produits biologiques c'est tous les deux
hommes parce qu'elles ont un risque
biologique et les aides à domicile c'est
tous les 5 ans mais excusez-moi au
niveau de assumant des métiers à la
pénibilité avérée je peux vous dire que
les deux métiers ont exactement la même
pénibilité donc il y en a un qui parce
que en plus il est du milieu social et
l'autre du milieu médico-social et
médico-social c'est un peu mieux c'est
plus proche du médecin plus proche du
sanitaire il y en a un qui passe tous
les deux ans quand même à la médecine du
travail et l'autre tous les 5 ans donc
il est temps de ne pas se ne pas se
soumettre à l'effet cliquet et de
redemander ce qu'on a connu il n'y a pas
si longtemps la visite annuelle tous les
ans
un sous-amendement 5720 monsieur Ferny
le Président chers collègues monsieur le
ministre je rebondis sur ce que disait
le sur observation tout à l'heure de
notre collègue Lucien sanzone je crois
qu'il y a effectivement un débat
nécessaire qui pourra pas véritablement
se déployer dans cette mort ne phase
parlementaire sans échange
et sans vote parce que le raisonnement
au terme duquel seule une liste
limitative d'emplois spécifiques exposer
un risque particulier justifierait le
maintien d'un examen obligatoire
d'aptitude ce raisonnement il tient
aucun compte des réalités sociales et
médicales il y a des millions d'employés
qui se trouvent ainsi livrés à des
risques médicaux et psychosociaux que
seuls la compétence médicale est à même
de prévenir ces dispositions donc
menaces la santé des travailleuses et
travailleurs de ce pays en même temps
qu'elles exposent
inutilement les employeurs à méconnaître
les risques encourus par leurs employés
je rappelle j'en parlais tout à l'heure
le rapport de la Cour des comptes sur
les politiques de prévention santé au
travail dans les entreprises publiées en
décembre 2022 et qui critique le manque
d'ambition de la politique publique en
matière de santé au travail et de
prévention des risques professionnels et
l'absence de contraintes qui pèsent sur
les entreprises hors période covid les
accidents du travail se maintiennent
ainsi à un niveau très élevé ne pas
mettre en oeuvre tous les moyens
disponibles pour enrayer ce phénomène
massif et à notre avis simplement
inacceptable donc l'amendement des du
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste visa remettre en vigueur une
visite médicale imposée à l'embauche et
ensuite à une période d'icité de deux
ans cette périodicité nous paraît trop
importante particulièrement pour les
salariés assumant des métiers à la
pénibilité incontestable ou exposée à
des tâches mauvaises pour leur santé
mais la niveau gel avec la signataires
de son amendement propose que ça soit
une visite médicale tous les ans c'est à
dire tous les 12 mois
merci l'amendement
3910 madame va rien
le président le dispositif du suivi
individuel spécifique créé à l'article
40 et défini aux alinéas 41 et 43 n'est
qu'une main consolation pour les
salariés exclus des nouveaux critères du
camp de pénibilité mais plus encore dans
sa rédaction actuelle la linea 40 ne se
réfère qu'aux petits un du Grand tain de
l'article
l4161 en faisant le choix de cette
restriction le dispositif de suivi
individualisé spécifique qui n'est déjà
pas la panacée se limite au facteurs de
pénibilité suivant la manutention
manuelle de charge les postures pénibles
définies comme position forcée des
articulations vibrations mécanique par
notre amendement qui vise à simplifier
le texte finalement tous les cas de
pénibilité si tu es au grand thym
seraient couvert c'est-à-dire
l'exposition aux agents chimiques
dangereux y compris les poussières et
les fumées des activités exercées en
milieu hyperbère celle exercée à des
températures extrêmes dans le bruit de
nuit en travail posté et les tâches
mécaniques répétitives nous demandons
donc nous proposions cet amendement pour
que tous les travailleurs soumis à la
pénibilité disposent d'un suivi lors
d'une rencontre d'ailleurs avec les
syndicalistes de mon territoire conduite
il y a seulement quelques semaines je
puis vous assurer que la pénibilité ne
se limite pas de se limite pas aux
risques ergonomiques il est donc
indispensable d'élargir cette prise en
charge
alors un abonnement qui porte du numéro
2000 sans trois rectifier monsieur
fialer
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre moi je me réjouis de pouvoir
m'exprimer et de profiter un peu de
cette liberté qu'on a quand même de
d'enrichir un débat contrairement à ce
que je peux entendre sur certains côtés
donc dans l'esprit de l'amendement de
notre collègue Véronique Guillotin qui a
été présenté par notre président
Jean-Claude Roquier un peu plus tôt il
est proposé de faire bénéficier les
travailleurs non salariés du suivi
individuel de prévention de l'usure
professionnelle on sait que les
soignants sont souvent les plus mal
soignés et pourtant leurs conditions de
travail qui se dégradent d'année en
année nécessite qu'on s'intéresse aussi
à leur santé compte tenu du niveau de
pénibilité des missions des
professionnels de santé libéraux il est
indispensable de mieux les intégrer aux
différents dispositifs de prévention de
l'article 9
nous devons aussi penser à
l'attractivité de ces métiers qui
s'ouvre d'une désaffection en témoigne
des fortes difficultés de recrutement
donc en regain d'intérêt pour leur santé
physique et mentale pourraient permettre
d'améliorer les conditions de travail et
donc de retrouver de l'attractivité
alors il est possible qu'il puisse
participer justement à ces à cette
prévention simplement les tâches
administratives et qu'ils connaissent
pas forcément
ne favorise pas cette existence
mais merci d'amendement
37,99 qui le présente monsieur volley
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues pour
vous dire vraiment notre contribution
constructive au débat puisque là on
faisait un amendement de repli
c'est vrai que ça fait un peu bizarre de
faire un amendement de repli à un moment
où on a un vote unique et éclat
discussion est bloquée mais on y va
quand même voyez ça c'est notre esprit
républicain les communistes si ça peut
aussi aider le président de la
République à recevoir les organisations
syndicales qui se lâchent puisque notre
groupe propose d'associer les
organisations syndicales et patronales
vous avez bien entendu syndical et
patronal à la définition d'une durée de
travail minimal ouvrant droit un suivi
individuel spécifique en matière de
santé au travail
je vois que vous avez compris tout à
fait la pertinence et le bien fondé de
l'amendement merci
alors un abonnement 3137
49 pardonnez-moi
merci monsieur le Président donc notre
groupe c'est la diversité et je ne
trouve donc aucun intérêt à des feindre
un amendement dans le sort et je vais
vous faire gagner du temps je le retire
alors pardonnez-moi le 3137
madame poncemonge merci monsieur le
Président alors l'article 9 demande que
les branches professionnelles engage des
négociations permettant un recensement
des métiers les plus exposés au facteurs
de risque retenus par le Code du travail
depuis les modifications 2017
et que c'est négociations servent de
base ont renforcement de la visite
médicale de mi carrière
cet engagement des négociations nous on
le demandera au plus vite je crois que
c'est un autre amendement ou du moins
lui donner un temps un temps contraint
ces dispositions sont en effet bienvenue
compte tenues de l'intensification très
importante du travail depuis plus de 30
ans on l'a souvent dit mais il faut le
répéter selon la Dares l'exposition à au
moins trois contraintes physiques
concernent 34% des salariés contre 12%
en 1984 et pendant retenir qu'une parmi
toutes ces contraintes parce que là ce
sont des nombres des chiffres on les dit
mais derrière il y a des hommes et des
hommes cassés et des femmes en 2019
71,5 presque 72% des salariés de tous
les secteurs étaient soumis à des
contraintes posturales posturales et
articulaire se maintenir dans l'emploi
en fin de carrière se prépare en amont
c'est pourquoi l'objet de cet amendement
est de systématiser le rendez-vous
professionnel des 45 ans prévu par le
présent projet de loi en créant un
entretien professionnel renforcé devant
avoir lieu entre le 45e et le 47e
anniversaire du salarié mais ce que nous
demandons c'est que la réalisation d'un
bilan de compétences soit de droit
c'est une demande d'ailleurs des
organisations syndicales je sais plus
laquelle du moins d'une des cinq
organisations 6 organisations syndicale
que nous avons rencontré
il faut conclure bientôt monsieur j'ai
dit principal monsieur le Président un
bilan de compétence de droit
alors
ne quittez pas pour le moment 3368
alors alors alors alors alors alors
alors alors alors
primé l'expression visite médicale et la
remplacer par le terme visite
d'inaptitude la visite médicale
organisée entre le 60e et le 61e
anniversaire du salarié dans le cadre du
contrôle médical dit renforcer n'en est
en réalité pas une il s'agit d'un
aiguillage qui permet d'identifier si
les travailleurs et travailleuses ne
sont plus aptes à travailler le cas
échéant cela permettrait le 3 d'une
pension pour inaptitude
selon la Dares à 61 ans aux portes aux
portes de la retraite
seulement 42,3% des seniors sont en
emploi à temps plein un petit dixième
aussi à temps partiel moins d'un sur
deux quand même les proportions
diffèrent selon les catégories
socioprofessionnelles mais pour les
ouvriers c'est 28% en emploi à 61 ans
alors c'est 28% en emploi qui auront la
visite la fameuse visite entre 60 et 61e
anniversaire je pense que il serait
mieux on ferait mieux de la renommée une
visite d'inaptitude
l'adresse ce chiffre 1,4 millions le
nombre d'individus âgé de 53 69 ans qui
ne sont ni en emploi ni en retraite dont
dont une majorité de femmes plus de 60%
sont des anciens ouvriers et employés
60% dans cette catégorie
socio-professionnelle et un tiers est en
situation désormais de pauvreté
âgé de 58 ans au moyenne 29% déclare un
mauvais ou très mauvais état de santé
contre 11% de cette tranche d'âge 29%
contre 11% dans ces catégories
socio-professionnelles si les personnes
se retrouvent dans cette situation c'est
que le travail et les conditions de
travail ne cessent de s'intensifier et
qui sont la cause principale de cette
sur-représentation des catégories
socioprofessionnelles que j'ai évoqué
voilà donc merci Monsieur le président
alors un amendement 3918
nous nous pensons que cet amendement
parce qu'il crée pas une dépense
supplémentaires il aurait pu être retenu
dans le vote bloqué retenu avait les 70
autres amendements pourquoi parce qu'on
parle de la question la médecine du
travail et vraiment c'est un sujet
extrêmement sérieux je pense que tout le
monde y attentif surtout les bancs qui
dit médecine du travail dit que c'est
pas du curatif on est bien d'accord
c'est du préventif donc si on le fait à
partir de 61 ans sérieusement je vois
pas beaucoup sur le préventif qu'on va
pouvoir agir pourquoi parce que c'est
les ceux qui ont des carrières pénibles
usant
qui ont les métiers avec
les heures de nuit les carrières
arrachées enfin bref c'est bien avant 61
ans qu'il faut prévenir on peut se
mettre au moins d'accord sur ça donc on
s'était dit que à partir de mi parcours
il faut le décider ensemble 40 45 ans on
propose qu'il y ait une visite tous les
deux ans parce que là on peut en faire
de la prévention et là la médecine du
travail peut agir voilà donc c'est je le
dis alors on n'aura pas le temps d'avoir
le débat comme on le souhaitait peu
importe mais je voudrais vraiment au
minimum monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le ministre nous disent au moins sur
cette question là on pourrait se mettre
d'accord parce que c'est pas une dépense
supplémentaire ça demande peut-être de
renforcer les moyens pour la médecine du
travail je pense bien évidemment
monsieur le rapporteur et il faut et
donc nous sommes d'accord et
bon bah essayons de trouver un compromis
au moins sur cette question là je vous
remercie merci sous amendement
4957 madame meunier
oui merci monsieur le Président si vous
acceptez je peux vous présenter le 49 57
et le 49 58 dans la foulée puisque il y
a une simplement une contrainte
voilà donc les auteurs de cet amendement
donc vient de que vient présenter Fabien
guet très bien nous le soutenons et donc
c'est amendement transforme la visite
médicale des 60 et un an en visite
périodique organisée donc tous les deux
ans et que à mi carrière pour les
salariés concernés par des contraintes
physiques marquées
c'est très important la médecine
préventive d'ailleurs nous avons un
médecin un médecin oui aussi mais un
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
et
ce serait bien de mettre du contenu
aussi dans ces appellations et c'est
attributions pour en revenir à
l'amendement il est effectivement
irresponsable que des salariés exposés
soient à la pénibilité de la tâche soit
au stress créé par des objectifs à
atteindre impossible soit par des
responsabilités lourdes ne puisse pas
bénéficier d'une visite médicale pour
vérifier leur aptitude à assumer leurs
fonctions avant l'âge de 61 ans avec mes
collègues du groupe socialiste nous
partageons cette vision préventive et
nous souhaitons d'ailleurs
rapproché puisque nous proposons que ces
lieux tous les 18 mois ou même tous les
ans vous voyez monsieur le ministre nous
aurions aimé
discuter débattre de ces mesures mais
vous en laissez pas le choix l'occasion
puisque vous avez décidé et nous le
regrettons ce vote bloqué pour n'engager
qu'un seul vote qu'une seule ligne sur
celle du gouvernement avec la pluie de
la majorité sénatoriale et nous le
merci un amendement 434
rectifiés
qui le présente monsieur benaroche
oui oui c'est moi monsieur le président
bon ça fait des années que la prévention
à l'éducation à la santé ça les angles
morts de la politique sanitaire depuis
de notre pays ça fait aussi des années
d'ailleurs que que la médecine du
travail est le parent pauvre et encore
c'est un euphémisme notre système de
santé
pourtant au-delà de donner les moyens à
une réelle politique de prévention et de
suivi pour la santé des travailleurs on
pourrait considérer que les dernières
années de travail donc du coup
quand on sera plus vieux et qu'on
continuera à travailler elle devrait
être particulièrement surveillée c'était
d'ailleurs l'objet de cet amendement que
nous aurions aimé discuté et voter si
les dispositions prises par le
gouvernement et la droite du Sénat ne
nous avait pas empêché en 2019
39% des travailleurs avaient une visite
avec un médecin du travail ou un
infirmier au cours des 12 derniers mois
quelques années avant 2005 ils étaient
70%. c'est à dire plus de la moitié en
plus en tout cas ça a diminué depuis de
la moitié
le recensement qui a été effectué par le
Conseil National de l'Or des médecins
mais en lumière une baisse du nombre de
médecin du travail on est passé de 4908
en 2015 à 4650 en 2020 c'est à dire une
baisse sur 5 ans qui est de près de 10%.
donc et qui continue d'ailleurs et ça
s'arrangera pas pourquoi ça s'arrangera
pas parce que en plus une idée une idée
une inadéquation entre les postes
ouverts à l'internat
pour cette spécialité et les postes
pourvu ce décalage encore monté de 20%
récemment et pourtant dans certaines
professions l'intérim par exemple le
risque d'accident du travail avait
arrêté
et deux fois plus élevé que la moyenne
on en est à 39,3 accidents de travail
par milliardaire salariale ce qui est
énorme
d'où souhaiterions donc non pas la
disparition de cette activité mais plus
de contrôle et plus de visite médicale
si vous voulez poursuivre
le dernier amendement
426 monsieur benaroche
la médecine du travail donc pourquoi
continuer sur ce thème qui est concerné
par ces articles et si peu dotés donc
que les visites se forment de plus en
plus rares
dans ce contexte que j'ai expliqué de
diminutions du nombre de médecins du
travail les visites de suivi des
salariés du privé par les services de
santé au travail sans de moins en moins
fréquentes
comment accepter cela cette chute
vertigineuse du suivi occasion qui qui
naugure rien de beau pour l'avenir
particulièrement si l'on demande donc
aux gens d'attendre plus longtemps la
retraite l'évolution de l'espérance de
vie en votre santé stagne déjà on est
sur une stagnation après plusieurs
années
d'amélioration et si aucune mesure
sérieuse de suivi ou de prévention n'est
prise ça ne fera que ce dégrader nous
nous l'avons déjà dit nous regrettons le
choix de ce projet de loi de finance
rectificative de la sécurité sociale
pour cette réforme des retraites mais ne
pas voir dans ce véhicule législatif des
mesures sur une meilleure prise en
charge de la santé des travailleurs afin
de garantir le moindre impact de ce
reculage de la retraite sur leur
capacité à cesser leur activité à
profiter de la vie dans les meilleures
conditions nous paraît être un acte
manqué
particulièrement cynique les règles
d'amendement ne nous permettaient pas
déjà de proposer plus de suivi ou de
proposer plus des certains groupes de
choses qui auraient eu un impact
financier aujourd'hui c'est pire que ça
puisque vous allez vous dire la balle
est dans votre corps monsieur le
rapporteur et Messieurs les madame les
sénatrice mais en fait même pas la balle
est dans le code plus personne elle est
juste dans le cas d'un accord qui sera
passé entre le gouvernement et le
Parlement par l'intermédiaire d'une CMP
qui est déjà accomplie Davos et donc en
fait toutes les possibilités que nous
aurions eu ensemble
n'existe plus
alors monsieur le rapporteur
vous avez déjà
quelques précisions quand même puisque
certains m'ont prêté l'intention de
vouloir faire aimer supprimer les
services de santé au travail que les
choses soient claires c'est une mauvaise
il y a Monsieur J'ai mal entendu j'ai
cru comprendre peu importe je reprends
les propos de Monsieur benaroche parce
que je les partage
il dit qu'il y a de moins en moins de
moyens à la santé au travail on met de
plus en plus de visites obligatoires
alors à chaque loi on rajoute une visite
une visite de mes carrières vous voyez
hop problème réglé il y a plus de
problème mon ami dans la visite noire là
on remet une visite à 60 ans non je
pense que on découpe pas on ne découpe
pas les gens en tranches on les prend
dans l'ensemble et on va pas faire une
visite spécifique là 59 entre 59 60 pour
les troubles ergonomiques non la
personne elle a peut-être des troubles
ergonomiques mais elle est peut-être
exposée à des agents chimiques et
peut-être qu'elle a travaillé continue
également et puis là on prend pas en
compte de façon identique la pénibilité
parce qu'on est ça va bien je pense
qu'il faut une vraie réflexion sur la
santé au travail et vous n'avez tous dit
il faut des moyens supplémentaires c'est
pour ça que c'est pas chaque loi qu'il
faut rajouter ça sûrement pas dans un
PLFSS mais plutôt dans une loi travail
monsieur le ministre et nous attendons
des dispositions effectivement dans la
loi travail c'est pour ça que la
Commission on en a discuté chers
confrères c'est pour ça que la
Commission à la commission nous avons
choisi de dire ça va bien faut une
réflexion on entend la loi travail la
consultation des partenaires sociaux
à la fois les salariaux et patronaux
pour définir une meilleure politique de
médecine de santé au travail voilà que
les choses soient claires entre nous
merci donc je confirme la vie des
favorable en attendant une discussion
plus riche lors d'une loi travail lui
les risques
merci monsieur le Président peut-être un
mot puisque c'est un point de c'est un
point de désaccord que nous avons avec
monsieur le rapporteur
nous considérons qu'il est utile de
préciser
du président qu'il est considérons
pardon qu'il est utile de préciser un
certain nombre de sujets sur la santé au
travail dans ce texte et nous
considérons que les dispositions qui
sont proposées ont un impact sur les
comptes sociaux notamment par l'accès
d'un certain nombre de salariés ainsi
suivi à des départs anticipés mais aussi
par la prise en charge d'un certain
nombre de ses visites du travail qui ont
nécessairement pris en charge qui est
nécessairement un impact
quel est le sens de ce que nous faisons
d'abord la loi telle qu'elle est
proposée là ne règle pas tout et nous
avons des briques pardon sur lesquels
nous pouvons nous appuyer vous avez en
2021 à l'été 2021 adopter une loi santé
au travail à la suite d'un accord
national interprofessionnel cette loi
santé au travail prévoit une visite
médicale de mi-carrière entre 43 et 45
ans je dis 43 à 45 ans parce que là
j'exacte est renvoyé un dialogue de
branche ce que nous prévoyons avec cette
loi c'est que les médecins du travail
puissent déterminer le rythme de suivi
des salariés exposés au métier eux-mêmes
exposés exerçant les métiers pardon
exposés aux trois critères ergonomiques
et que les médecins du travail puissent
déterminer le la régularité du suivi
entre cette première visite de mi
carrière qui commencera entre 43 et 45
ans et une nouvelle visite de fin de fin
de carrière que nous créons par le texte
à 61 ans pourquoi 61 ans
parce que à 61 ans si un salarié
malheureusement
usé par l'activité qu'il a exercé et que
cette usure l'autorise si je puis dire à
bénéficier d'un départ anticipés il est
encore temps d'une certaine manière de
bénéficier de des parents anticipés
alors qu'une retraite une visite pardon
spontanée à 63 ans 63 ans et demi si
c'est pour qu'il s'entende de dire vous
auriez pu partir 2 ans avant c'est trop
tard et donc la loi santé au travail de
2021 à acté cette première visite entre
43 et 45 ans en fonction de dialogue
social nous voulons acter une visite à
61 ans et permettre à la médecine du
travail au médecin du travail de décider
de la régularité des visites entre les
deux est-ce que ça signifie que lorsque
je dis ça tout est réglé pour la
médecine du travail non bien évidemment
non il y a un gros travail un gros
chantier à ouvrir pour revaloriser ce
métier là il y a un second chantier qui
est ouvert et qui s'est déjà traduit par
un certain nombre de décret
d'application c'est la mise en oeuvre de
la loi santé au travail de 2021 qui
elle-même s'appuie sur un accord
national interprofessionnel et parmi les
décrets que nous préparons sur lesquels
nos qui se travaille en lien avec le
ministère de la santé il y a par exemple
la possibilité de mettre en oeuvre des
et de de nous appuyer pardon sur des
infirmiers des infirmières en pratique
avancées comme ça se fait dans d'autres
secteurs médicaux de même qu'il y a
possibilité en appui à la médecine du
travail d'avoir recours à d'autres
secteurs médicaux comme la médecine de
ville pour un certain nombre de visites
et donc nous pouvons avancer cette
manière là c'est la raison pour laquelle
le gouvernement est très attaché à ce
dispositif de suivi médical pour les
salariés qui exercent un des métiers
défini par la branche ATMP comme étant
exposé aux trois critères ergonomiques
je termine pour donner la vie vous avez
compris monsieur le Président que la vie
du Gouvernement est défavorable sinon
nous l'aurions signalé lorsque j'ai
évoqué l'article 44 alinéa 3 la vie du
gouvernement sur les autres amendements
ou sous amendements est aussi
défavorable pour une raison qui est plus
une raison de méthode qu'une raison de
fond pour certains d'entre eux nous
avons une opposition de fond pour
d'autres le gouvernement aurait pu les
soutenir mais à mesure où le fait de ne
pas donner d'avis favorable à
l'amendement de monsieur le rapporteur
fait que nous en restons au texte du
Gouvernement il n'y a pas lieu à mes
yeux de donner un avis favorable sur des
amendements qui ont beaucoup été
présentés comme des amendes replis par
rapport à celui de Monsieur le
rapporteur et donc nous proposerons nous
proposons une proposerons que le Sénat
se prononce sur les dispositions telles
que prévu dans le projet initial sur ce
sujet là merci alors l'amendement 21 51
de monsieur le rapporteur a été retiré
c'est donc tomber les sous abondements
mais nous avons un amendement
21,50 monsieur le rapporteur merci c'est
un moment rédactionnel monsieur le
président
identiques de 24 25
qui le présente monsieur salmon
merci monsieur le Président nous voyons
tout à coup que un désaccord l'un des
premiers entre la droite sénatorial et
le gouvernement et bien ça aurait été
l'occasion d'avoir un vrai débat au sein
de tous les mystiques bien dommage sur
ce projet gouvernement il a refusé
d'écouter les organisations syndicales
le gouvernement a décidé d'utiliser la
procédure d'examen contraint dans le
temps qu'implique l'article 47 1 de la
Constitution le Gouvernement a à de
multiples reprises recours à des décrets
tout cela pour masquer toutes les
incohérences de cette de cette loi ce
projet de loi en raison de l'importance
du décrémentionné ici et des difficultés
de prise en compte des points de vue des
acteurs concernés il nous semble
indispensable que le Conseil d'État soit
associé à l'écriture de ce de ces
décrets ainsi par cet amendement le
Conseil d'État serait amené à préparer
avec le gouvernement un avis qui devrait
être recueilli après une consultation
des organismes dont la vie est souhaitée
enfin je dis sera car lorsque j'avais
écrit la défense de cet amendement je
pensais qu'il serait débattu et soumis à
vote donc je disais sera avec confiance
en quelque sorte mais bon revenons
quelques instants sur cette séquence en
ce moment vous nous avez accusé de faire
de l'obstruction mais vous vous faites
de la déconstruction il faut le
reconnaître vous avez une belle
stratégie mais elle est bien peu
démocratique vous avez positionné dès
lors avec des amendements du rapporteur
qui sont parsemés ici et là dans le
texte les uns pour être déplacés les
autres pour être supprimés
retirez on voilà que vous avez une belle
anticipation vous nous parlez
d'obstruction mais tout était préparé il
y a du métier ça c'est indéniable
mais au bout qui est gagnant
vous peut-être avec cette stratégie
cette stratégie mais le perdant au bout
du compte c'est le débat démocratique et
ici c'est
terminé on a pensé
merci monsieur le Président alors cet
amendement visait à s'assurer que
l'intention du législateur serait
respectée car sur ce projet après avoir
refusé non pas d'écouter mais d'entendre
et de tenir compte des avis des
organisations syndicales après avoir
décidé d'utiliser la procédure d'examen
contraint dans le temps qui implique
l'article 47 1 de la Constitution après
l'usage 44.3 de la Constitution et le 42
l'usage du 42 9 de notre règlement
du Sénat bref dans ce contexte il
libéral je le répète le gouvernement a
il fait encore de multiples recours à
des décrets en raison notamment de
l'importance du décret mentionné ici et
des difficultés de prise en compte des
points de vue des acteurs concernés il
semble indispensable aux yeux du groupe
écologiste que cet amendement que le
Conseil d'État soit associé à l'écriture
de ce décret vous me répondrez très
certainement monsieur le ministre ou
monsieur le rapporteur mais pourquoi
nous répondre puisque nous n'avons pas
le droit après de reprendre la parole
sur vos réponses ça si c'est une
légalité si c'est vous avez le droit
c'est légal c'est mais en attendant sur
le plan intellectuel quand même
quelle malhonnêteté intellectuelle alors
la vie de la Commission sur ces deux
amendements
identiques oui effectivement là aussi
c'est par rapport au décret
avoir la vie du Conseil d'État nous a
paru forcément nécessaire c'est toujours
le même type d'amendement donc vous êtes
n'est pas je donne un avis défavorable
bien entendu
la vie du gouvernement
défavorable
nous allons examiner un amendement qui
porte le numéro
4687 monsieur Ferdy que présente
si monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues l'instance ce
gouvernementale France compétence créée
en 2019 permet d'ores et déjà de
financer la formation professionnelle et
l'apprentissage ce projet de loi prévoit
d'élargir les possibilités de dotation
versées par France compétences afin que
celle-ci puisse également financer des
projets de transition professionnelle
des salariés exposés à certains risques
aux professionnels qui pourraient alors
se reconvertir pour accéder à un emploi
non exposé aux facteur d'usure
professionnelle alors que l'idée pour
être bonne la mise en oeuvre par contre
risque de s'annoncer compliqué et risque
de ne pas répondre aux besoins des
travailleuses et travailleurs qui sont
exposés tous les jours à des risques
professionnels en cause là encore le
manque de considération du rôle central
des syndicats dans le monde du travail
en effet le projet de loi prévoit que le
financement peut que le financement
pardon peut uniquement être accordé par
France compétences si certaines
conditions sont remplies des conditions
qui seront définies
ultérieurement par décret sans
consultation quelconque des syndicats
donc dans de telles conditions le risque
est grand que les conditions soient trop
restrictives et que les travailleuses et
travailleurs exposés à l'usure
professionnelle ne puisse pas bénéficier
de tels financement par France
compétences par conséquent le risque est
grand qui ne pourront pas bénéficier
d'une transition professionnelle tout
court à défaut de financement approprié
c'est la raison pour laquelle cet
amendement vise à ce que le décret soit
uniquement pris après des négociations
avec les organisations syndicales et
patronales représentatives au niveau
national et interprofessionnel c'est
pourquoi il se propose de compléter
l'alinéa 53 par les mots qui permettront
d'assurer ces négociations
alors l'avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur effectivement cet
amendement souligne la participation du
FIP au projet de transition
professionnelle mais nous ne pensons pas
que la négociation doit être faite avec
les négociations avec les organisations
syndicales doit être faite au niveau des
décrets je vous le rappelle nous pensons
que c'est négociations doivent venir par
anticipation c'est trop tard au niveau
des décrets parce que c'est fort
important obtenu de ces nouvelles
circonstances qu'elle soit associées
mais vraiment au départ donc avis bien
sûr défavorable du gouvernement
mais ma vie un amendement 21 52 de
monsieur le rapporteur j'ai compris
qu'il était rédactionnel le gouvernement
il est favorum
et un amendement
3523 madame poncer mon
bon merci monsieur le Président donc le
projet de transition professionnelle est
un outil précieux pour les salariés
souhaitant se reconvertir
professionnellement ou acquérir de
nouvelles compétences nous avions
souhaité un rapport bien sûr déclaré et
recevable qui allait dans ce sens un
rapport sur la possibilité pour les
assurés de jouir d'un droit anticipé à
un congé sabbatique financé par ses
droits à la retraite d'une durée maximum
d'un an et à usage unique ainsi ce droit
à un année sabbatique permettrait une
nouvelle conceptualisation heureuse du
droit au temps libéré de la
subordination nombre de travaux nombre
d'activités plutôt ne sont pas
marchandes mais elles sont porteuses de
sens elles sont dévalorisées dans cette
marchandisation du monde et devrait être
permis par ce droit anticiper à la
retraite pourtant car beaucoup hésitent
à se lancer dans ce projet de peur des
conséquences professionnelles que cela
pourrait engendrer de plus un congé
sabbatique
permettant de mettre son contrat de
travail en suspens allant de six mois à
11 mois est possible mais la
rémunération est aussi suspendue aussi
l'employeur par ailleurs est en droit de
différer le départ voire de le refuser
autant de fois que nécessaire donc le
nouveau droit anticipé que nous
proposons ne proposons absolu ne serait
être contrainte car fonder sur le
salaire socialisé cotisé par l'actif
pris sur ses droits à la retraite et
l'actorait les droits à la retraite
comme un horizon heureux de temps libéré
et d'activité pour soi pour ses proches
la société une possibilité tout au long
de la vie plutôt que l'achèvement du
vide travail et d'usure dans un sens
dans un travail de plus en plus en crise
de sens la bataille pour du temps
libérée de la contrainte de la
subordination et bien celle du progrès
social c'est une nécessité écologique je
vous remercie merci David la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
ça m'étonne de Madame pansement j'ai mes
impressions qu'elle s'est trompé
d'amendement puisque il concerne
celui-là un avis du Conseil d'État sur
le décret fiction la durée minimale
d'activité pour bénéficier d'un projet
de transition professionnelle dans le
cadre du fipu donc c'est toujours la
même intention du législateur nous
pensons qu'elle sera respectée donc avis
défavorable
alors la vie du gouvernement défavorable
ensuite je voulais vous signaler que
l'amendement 21 53
de monsieur le rapporteur de la
commission a été retiré avec lui les
quatre sous amendements
merci monsieur le Président mon rappeur
règlement est fondé sur l'article 4 de
la Constitution il se trouve que on
vient de me signaler de l'extérieur du
Sénat d'ailleurs un tweet reprenant les
propos de notre collègue lévrier qui à
mon sens pose quelques problèmes
je vous le lis mais attendez avant qu'on
le qualifie laissez-moi le temps de le
lire la volonté même de ne pas vouloir
faire un bon tir le texte c'est daigner
le rôle du Parlement jusque là on peut
discuter ces gens là j'imagine que vous
parlez de nous quand vous dites ces gens
là ne veulent pas du Parlement ils y
sont entrés pour le détruire alors
Monsieur lévrier je crois que vos propos
méritent quand même quelques rappels
historiques ou alors que visiblement
votre parole vous a totalement échappé
peut-être auriez-vous voulu dire que
nous étions là pour détruire le
parlementarisme déjà c'était un débat
nous aurions trouvé que c'était faux
mais ce n'était pas la même chose
détruire le Parlement alors dans
l'histoire du XXe siècle il y a quelques
précéd
l'incendie du Reichstag c'est la
destruction du Parlement dans l'histoire
récente du XXIe siècle il y a d'autres
références le Capitole là effectivement
la question était de détruire le
Parlement mais vous pensez sérieusement
chers collègues que nous avons été nous
sommes entrés au Parlement pour le
détruire nous sommes entre Parlement
pour représenter et défendre nos
électeurs pour représenter et défendre
l'intérêt national et la France et la
France c'est son parlement je vous
invite vraiment monsieur dévrier à nous
faire part de vos regrettes ou ses
propos et à nous dire que vous n'avez
pas maîtriser votre parole
[Applaudissements]
je renverrai à mes observations
conférences des présidents
l'amendement
4691 monsieur ferrique
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
miniche chers collègues donc je vais
essayer d'être constructif pour
contribuer à construire le débat
parlementaire il faut tenir compte de
l'impact de plus en plus dévastateur des
changements climatiques sur le monde du
travail en effet les conséquences des
changements climatiques sur les
travailleuses et travailleurs
particulièrement pour certains métiers
professions sont irréfutables et vont
malheureusement encore gagner en ampleur
dans le futur dans un rapport
exhaustif de 2018 l'Alsace l'Agence
nationale de la sécurité sociale a
identifier trois principaux facteurs
augmentant les risques professionnels
premier facteur assez évident les
températures qui vont augmenter
aggravant les risques d'hyperthermie
deuxième facteur l'évolution de
l'environnement biologique et chimique
avec des risques plus fréquents et plus
graves et troisième facteur l'intensité
de certains aléas climatiques parmi ces
aléas climatiques figurent notamment les
canicules phénomènes observés avec une
fréquence et une intensité croissante en
France alors que la Confédération
européenne des syndicats rappelle que la
température optimale au travail se situe
entre 16 et 24 degrés en fonction des
activités les phénomènes de température
extrêmes renforcent la pénibilité du
travail et contribue à l'usure
professionnelle de plus les conséquences
du changement climatique ne sont pas
seulement dangereuses pour les
travailleuses et travailleurs mais
entraînent également des conséquences
néfastes pour l'ensemble de l'activité
économique une étude publiée dans le
journal scientifique zoland 7 a démontré
qu'à l'échec global
153 milliards d'heures de travail ont
été perdus en 2017 année avec un été
particulièrement chaud cette perte était
de 60% au-dessus du niveau de 2000 la
productivité au travail souffre des
impacts des changements climatiques
au-delà des listes de métiers activités
exposés à des facteurs de risque
professionnels prévus dans le projet de
loi cette amendement vise donc à mettre
en place des listes de métiers ou d'ACT
aux conséquences des changements
climatiques j'ai fini alors l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
écoutez nous pensons qu'indirectement
mais même directement l'amendement est
satisfait je pense que on a été très
vigilant à faire en sorte que la liste
des métiers qui sont définis par les
branches soit évolutives ça veut bien
dire qu'il faut tenir compte des
facteurs sociaux d'environnement dans le
travail et pourquoi pas des facteurs
climatiques qui fera que on établira une
liste différente donc je pense que c'est
satisfait dans la réflexion et
l'élaboration de ce type de liste donc
avis défavorable
bien un amendement
B12 sous amendements nous avons eu je
crois les deux avis
alors 4682 monsieur Ferney il tourne
toujours un amendement à l'initiative de
ma collègue Mélanie Vogel dont je suis
signataire donc revenons sur justement
cette liste des professions et métiers
particulièrement exposés à certains
risques professionnels le gouvernement
se vendent que ce projet de loi
améliorerait la protection des risques
professionnels or si on regarde de près
force et de constater que la mise en
oeuvre de cette mesure n'est pas tout à
fait assurée en effet le projet de loi
prévoit que des branches
professionnelles négocient des listes de
métiers ou d'activité particulièrement
exposées à certains risques
professionnels cependant il y a là une
faille le projet de loi spécifique que
c'est négociations des branches
professionnelles doivent être engagés
dans un délai de deux mois à compter de
la promulgation même si cette
contestation devrait être incertaine au
vu de la mobilisation synthétique
syndicale la faille consiste dans le
fait que le projet de loi ne précise pas
de Diem de date limite pardon pour
l'aboutissement de ces négociations s'il
traîne les travailleuses et travailleurs
devraient attendre ces listes avant
d'éviter une telle situation nous
proposons par le biais de cet amendement
d'ajouter que ces listes devraient être
établies au plus tard un an après le
début des négociations ce délai nous
semble le juste équilibre car cette
année laisserait suffisamment de temps
pour un examen détaillé de la situation
sans retarder trop la mise en place de
ces listes enfin force est de constater
qui ne s'agit que de certains risques
spécifiques il y a des risques qui ne
sont pas pris en compte et les tendances
inquiétantes qui ne sont pas prises en
compte quick par exemple de
l'augmentation des risques en
conséquence des changements climatiques
il y a des métiers qui sont exposés
encore davantage à des risques je le
disais par exemple le risque de
déshydratation ou de l'hyperthermie ne
faudrait-il pas faire des prévisions sur
les futurs impacts
alors David la commission écoutez c'est
même dispositif qui a déjà été envisagé
on ne peut pas on peut contraindre des
partenaires sociaux à négocier mais pas
forcément à conclure un accord donc
c'est pas la peine de fixer un déni tout
semble-t-il donc avis défavorable
à vue du gouvernement
alors un amendement qui est douce nous
avons donc ils vont faire l'objet d'une
discussion commune d'abord un amendement
3314 madame pour ces Mons je le présente
merci monsieur le président
la souffrance au travail est un problème
dont on entend de plus en plus parler y
compris la Confédération européenne des
syndicats l'a pris à bras le corps dont
l'important c'est de plus en plus
reconnu l'épuisement professionnel
communément appelé burn out mais
il faut dire l'épuisement professionnel
parce que justement le lien avec
l'activité professionnelle et dans le
terme et non brûler on se demande de
brûler par quoi non l'épuisement
professionnel peut concourir à de
véritables souffrances psychosociales
allant de la dépression au suicide les
chiffres de cette épidémie silencieuse
sont alarmants l'Institut de Weiss
sanitaire évaluait en 2015 après de 500
000 le nombre de salariés en souffrance
psychosociale psychologique liée au
travail dans 7% environ déjà en
épuisement professionnel
les troupes psychologiques et
d'épuisement professionnel sont à
l'origine de 20% des arrêts aujourd'hui
ils étaient de 11% en 2016 il y a une
véritable
explosion de ces troubles-là et de ses
risques là il dépasse désormais les
troubles musculo-squelettiques on
pensait pas qu'un jour il puisse être
dépasser parce qu'ils sont déjà très
hauts qui représentent 16% des arrêts en
ce sont environ 3,2 millions d'actifs
soient près de 12% de la population
active qui risque qu'un épuisement
professionnel au travail les cas
d'épuisement professionnel touchent les
salariés dans toutes sortes d'activités
qui soient employées qui soient ouvriers
qui soient cadres artisan ou
agriculteurs ce sont 16% des salariés
qui sont confrontés à de fortes
exigences émotionnelles liées au contact
avec le public par exemple on a dit tout
à l'heure
il faut conclure mince voilà et bien
voilà alors un sous amendement à 1400 13
madame Poumirol
oui merci monsieur le Président ce sous
amendement demande que les affections
provoquées par les radiations
ionisantes soit inclus dans le FU sujet
intéressant comme tout ce que nous avons
vu depuis le début de l'après-midi quand
on sait d'ailleurs les lourdes de
pathologies qui sont consécutives assez
radiations mais monsieur le ministre
vous avez refusé le débat vous avez
utilisé le 44 3 il nous existe donc
depuis cet après-midi à une mascarade
nous parlons vous n'écoutez pas encore à
l'instant vous l'entendez encore bien
moins bien sûr c'est un déni de rôle du
Parlement et votre seul but et d'arriver
au vote final le plus rapidement
possible et pouvoir ensuite appliquer ce
recul de 62 à 64 ans de l'âge légal qui
refusait par la très grande majorité des
Français dans ce texte injuste et brutal
vous aviez prévu quelques concessions
sur la pénibilité ou la santé au travail
et bien même pas pas de débat
l'image que nous donnons cet après-midi
et lamentable nous défendons aux
amendements sans qu'il y ait le moindre
échange vous donnez l'arme à ceux qui
sont qui pensent que le Parlement ne
sert à rien attention aux conséquences
que cela pourrait avoir
422 qui le présente je chanterelle
merci monsieur le Président je vais
défendre ce sous amendement afin de
bonifier l'excellent amendement de notre
collègue
raymond-ponce mais monsieur le Président
je tenais à préciser que nous défendons
des amendements qui ne feront l'objet ni
de discussion ni de vote nous défendons
ses amendements qu'à contrairement au
gouvernement et à la majorité de droite
sénatoriales nous sommes attachés la
démocratie parlementaire et surtout à
travers ses amendements nous faisons
l'illustration que depuis le début nous
défendons des propositions concrètes et
alternatives à cette réforme injuste
c'est pourquoi nous proposons ce sous
amendement afin d'ajouter les maladies
chroniques respiratoires comme la
brocopnopathie chronique obstructive
nous avons demandé 5423
madame le héros
merci monsieur le Président donc moi je
voulais également rajouter parmi les
pathologies et les affections psychiques
les cancers de la prostate provoqués par
les pesticides les pathologies affectant
la santé au travail sont nombreuses et
il est dommage qu'en vertu des
procédures et de l'article 44-3 que vous
avez que monsieur le ministre a demandé
à ce qu'il soit appliqué donc à nos
débats depuis la fin de la matinée alors
que la discussion avait débuté dans de
très bonnes conditions monsieur le
ministre vous avez tué dans l'oeuf ce
débat important que nous aurions
souhaité tenir sereinement sur la santé
au travail et une médecine au travail
digne de ce nom comme vous l'avez dit
monsieur le rapporteur vous êtes avec
nous très frustré de cette situation
alors j'en reviens aux pathologies
affectant
les notre santé notamment ceux provoqués
par
notre collègue Nicole Bonnefoy a fait un
excellent rapport sur les dangers de ces
substances pour la santé et
l'environnement la mission a limité son
champ d'investigation à l'impact des
pesticides sur la santé de leur
fabricant et de leurs utilisateurs
agriculteurs et panda professionnels et
pour leur professionnelle pardon
personnel des sites de stockage
paysagiste collectivités territoriales
particuliers leur famille la famille de
ces personnes mais aussi les riverains
de ces activités vous voyez nombreuses
sont les personnes affectées par ces
difficultés
de des conditions de travail en fait
tout le rapport a été abordé sous
l'angle de la santé qu'il s'agisse des
maladies causées par les pesticides du
cadre juridique de l'autorisation de
mise sur le marché de ces produits de
leur évaluation par les agences de leur
commercialisation de leur utilis
ation comme parler
particulier donc dans le cadre
le 5424
merci monsieur le Président ben écoutez
moi je voulais compléter une très bonne
très bonne amendement de ma collègue
poncée Monge pour le par les vibrations
et choc transmis au système mainbras
c'est aussi l'occasion de rappeler que
les conditions de travail et la
pmiibilité du travail que le président
Macron voudrait rayer du vocabulaire
sont un des angles morts de la réforme
qui nous est proposée elle aurait dû
être au fondement d'une loi travail
avant toute réforme des retraites ce que
nous n'avons cessé de rappeler
d'ailleurs le présent le président
Macron refuse tellement de reconnaître
la pénibilité du travail qu'une de ces
premières mesures de son quinquennat
était supprimé ces critères dont les
vibrations portant les maladies
provoquées par ces vibrations sont
particulièrement invalidantes en effet
ces maladies et choc transmis au système
membrane sont essentiellement des effets
des affections
ostéo-articulaires
transformé par des examens radiologiques
je pense à l'arthrose du coude
comportant des signes radiologiques
d'ostéophysodiose
l'ostéonécrose du semis luminaire
la fameuse maladie de kimbock mais aussi
l'ostéoécrose du scaphoïde carpien la
maladie de colère enfin les troubles
angios neurotiques de la main
prédominant à l'index et aux méduses
pouvant s'accompagner de crampes de la
main et de troupes allongés de la
sensibilité et confirmer par des
épreuves fonctionnelles objectivant le
phénomène de Raynaud enfin les travaux
exposants habituellement aux vibrations
qui sont transmis principalement par les
machines outils tenues à la main
notamment les machines percutantes
telles que les marteau-piqueurs les
burineurs les bouchardeuses et les
fouloirs
sans oublier les outils tenus à la main
associé à cette corne il va falloir
conclure enfin nous aurons la liste
du bâtiment qui sont particulièrement
qui le présente merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues moi je vais poursuivre parce
que mon collègue n'a pas eu le temps de
le faire pour introduire donc les
affections qui sont provoquées donc par
des vibrations et par des chocs ce que
je voudrais peut-être souligner et je
tiens à remercier d'ailleurs toute la
documentation que l'on reçoit en tant
que parlementaire et notamment moi je
fais référence emploi chômage et revenu
du travail et notamment à la page 138 et
139 et qu'est-ce qu'on nous dit page 138
et 139 que selon l'Insee et la DARES 54%
des ouvriers déclare être soumis à au
moins trois contraintes parmi les cinq
que sont restés longtemps debout restez
longtemps dans une posture pénible
effectuer des déplacements à pied long
et fréquents de voir porter ou déplacer
des larges des des charges lourdes et
puis également subir des secousses ou
des vibrations et comme mon collègue me
le disait c'est vrai quand on pense au
secousses et aux vibrations on a tout de
suite en tête l'image de la personne qui
est avec son en réalité la mécanisation
de la société a fait que l'utilisation
d'outils percutant ou d'outils vibrants
s'est étendu à de nombreuses professions
notamment les travaux du martelage des
travaux de forge de tôlerie
chaudronnerie de travail du cuir bien
évidemment ce que je le disais les
travaux de terrassement mais aussi
l'utilisation de plus en plus fréquente
de pistolet de scellement l'utilisation
de clouteuses de rifteuse d'objets qui
sont tenus à la main pour le meulage le
les tronçonneuses et de plus en plus ces
outils que l'on voit sur le bord des
routes que sont les débroussailleuses et
puis également ça ne concerne pas
uniquement que ceux qui bricolent le
dimanche mais c'est aussi une profession
ce qui utilisent des six sauteuses et
des ponceuses tout ça tout ça pour dire
que l'utilisation est comme l'a dit
notre collègue engendre des maladies
professionnelles il y a eu des efforts
il faut le souligner en ce qui concerne
les équipements de protection individuel
notamment ce qui concerne les yeux et
les oreilles mais il néanmoins tout cela
génère des angoisses merci l'abonnement
sur Ferro
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues ce sous
amendement vise à compléter lui aussi
l'amendement de notre collègue Raymonde
ponsémont a faim que soit prise en
compte particulièrement une maladie liée
aux animaux d'élevage qui sont les
bruxellos professionnels sont concert
Monique Lubin va une maladie que vous ne
connaissiez pas mais elles sont
concernées les éleveurs les bergers le
personnel des abattoirs les agriculteurs
mais aussi les personnels des
laboratoires vétérinaires et des
laboratoires de diagnostic ces
conséquences sont importantes cette
maladie est encore mal connue et très
mal prévenu ce sous amendement a pour
but de la préciser dans l'amendement de
notre collègue Raymond de penser
que
voilà et le suivant
on aimerait bien élargir et bonifier
davantage l'amendement de notre collègue
un l'ouvrant donnez-vous bien au
nématodes au petit verre rond mais oui
on l'ignore un peu trop souvent c'est
ces types de verres les nématodes qui
ont donné lieu à aux charançons du
bananier qui est une hématode et qui
donne hélas le traitement quand vous
savez le chlordécone or vous avez
supprimé 4 facteurs de pénibilité et
d'insécurité quelles sont l'exposition
aux produits chimiques au pesticides or
les nématodes sont responsables
tenez-vous bien de l'anémie ferriprive
c'est pas mal et de l'anémie
prurigineuse monsieur le Président on
voulait absolument élargir le périmètre
de cette amendement là pour en tenir
compte et les travailleurs agricoles en
sont particulièrement victimes entre ça
également dans les mines et donc on
avait bien raison hélas de le prévoir
comme ça mais comme vous en avez privé
devrait débat démocratique bien bon on
l'expose et c'est un peu curieux comme
exercice démocratique d'exposer et de ne
pas voter
oui monsieur le Président moi je vais
vous parler des affections
causées par les ciment donc ça c'est un
sous amendement béton les ciment
représente des matériaux qui sont pas
sans risque pour les professionnels du
secteur de la construction des travaux
publics et de l'industrie qui les
manipulent afin de fabriquer ou mettre
en œuvre des bétons comme et mortiers
bien que les chiffres soient honnêtes
diminution il s'agit toujours d'une des
principales causes d'eczéma de contact
pour les yeux et la peau les professions
les plus exposées sont celles ayant
appliqué d'une façon manuelle et
matériaux comme les carreleurs les
maçons les chapistes les risques liés
aussi mains peuvent provoquer des
maladies dans certaines se révèlent
invalidantes pour les travailleurs si
l'on ajoute les facteurs
environnementaux froids sueur
manipulation de parpaing lavage avec des
produits agressifs qui donc aggravent
les symptômes les pathologies provoquées
peuvent être reconnues comme maladie
professionnelle
le titre du tableau 8 des maladies
professionnelles du régime général de la
Sécurité sociale ou au titre du tableau
14 du régime agricole de la sécurité
sociale en conséquence il nous paraît
important de compléter l'amendement de
nos collègues compte tenu du nombre
important de risques causés par les
ciment c'est à jour permettra d'inscrire
la prévention des risques liés à ces
matériaux pouvant conduire à des
syndromes d'épuisement pour
professionnels parmi les actions de
sensibilisation permise par le fond de
prévention vous voyez qu'il s'agit pas
d'un sous-amendement d'obstruction mais
d'un sous-amendement constructif et qui
grandit le Parlement qui est beaucoup
critiqué
ces heures-ci
merci monsieur le Président j'avoue
jusqu'à ce qu'on fasse ce travail pointu
et poussé sur les maladies
professionnelles et qui était nécessaire
dans l'examen de ce projet de loi
j'ignorais que les amis étaient
possibles ailleurs que dans les pays
exotiques tropicaux là où il y a des
autres choses je pensais que c'était une
maladie des pays tropicaux et en fait
grâce au travail qu'on a fait au lien
qu'on a avec les organisations
syndicales et avec la les spécialistes
des maladies professionnelles je vais
apprendre quelque chose j'imagine un
certain d'entre vous pas à nos collègues
médecins qui bien entendu le savent déjà
mais les amis sont simplement dans les
eaux chaudes et où y a-t-il des eaux
chaudes
dans la dans les centrales électriques
dans les centrales électriques c'est
comme ça que je reboucle sur toutes les
discussions qu'on a eu précédemment sur
le régime de retraite des personnels des
DF par exemple et donc les personnels
d'EDF sont particulièrement exposées à
toutes les maladies que provoquent les
amis et comme je suis très généreuse
avec vous et que par ailleurs on vit des
moments difficiles je ne vous en ferai
pas la liste mais sachez qu'elles sont
graves et là je ne plaisante pas du tout
je ne plaisantais pas d'ailleurs à aucun
moment de mon propos elles peuvent être
mortes et donc c'est pour ça que il
serait bon de compléter l'excellente
avant de mon âme pour ces Monge par ce
sous amendement
alors l'abonnement 54 30
merci monsieur le Président c'était un
sous amendement donc de l'amendement 33
14 effectivement je trouvais que ma
collègue avait
déjà bien amendé sauf que il manquait
quelques précisions en particulier c'est
la raison pour laquelle je propose
d'ajouter l'émo suivant donc notamment
sur les affections liées aux travaux en
pression supérieure à la pression
atmosphérique alors je ne vais pas faire
de commentaires sur la pression
atmosphérique de ce débat puisque depuis
l'article
44-3 tout va mieux pour la le Pacte des
droites sénatoriale et du gouvernement
puisqu'il y a plus de débat et oui ce
que le rôle du confrontation c'est une
rencontre entre l'air chaud et l'air
froid c'est l'objet d'un débat en tout
cas ce qu'on remarque c'est que ce n'est
plus le cas
sachez quand même mes chers collègues
que il faut savoir que la pression
supérieure à la pression atmosphérique
peut entraîner une perte de vue de la
vue pardon une insuffisance rénale mais
aussi des problèmes de circulation de
sang dans le cerveau il peut aussi
engendrer aussi une perte d'audition et
des lésions donc c'est vraiment des
dangers donc le but du jeu c'était quand
même de donner des précisions puisque
certains salariés effectuent des travaux
dans des milieux où la pression est
supérieure à la pression atmosphérique
et donc dans c'est la raison pour
laquelle je voulais apporter ces
précisions qui méritaient à mon avis un
débat mais vous le refusez apparemment
l'amendement 54 31 madame Dubin merci
monsieur le Président le glycol et le
glycérol peuvent être à l'origine de
nombreux problèmes de santé causés aux
salariés dès lors qu'il travaille
quotidiennement avec les dérivés nitrées
de ces produits par exemple dans le
cadre de la fabrication et du
conditionnement de la nitroglycérine et
du nitroglicole dans l'industrie des
explosifs l'effet indésirable principal
fréquent et la survenue de céphalées et
d'hypotension artérielle nous souhaitons
compléter cette amendement afin de
renforcer les actions de sensibilisation
et de prévention des pathologies
professionnelles quand on fait le compte
nous passons un nombre d'heures
colossales de notre vie au travail c'est
pourquoi nous sommes conduits à nous
intéresser à ce qui se passe dans notre
vie professionnelle afin de nous
protéger et protéger notre santé cette
protection commence par faire de la
prévention pour réduire les risques liés
à cette activité professionnel le
bénéfice de la prévention est évident on
réduit le nombre et l'intensité des
accidents de travail et des maladies
professionnelles nous savons bien que
ces problèmes de santé représentent un
coût pour les entreprises et pour le
système de protection sociale la
prévention assurée aujourd'hui
représente la promesse d'économie de
demain tel est le sens de notre
sous-amendement à l'amendement de notre
collègue Raymond de pensée mange et
au-delà de cet amendement ce que je
voudrais rappeler c'est que nous avons
fait ce travail parce que nous
souhaitions réellement parler des
maladies professionnelles et nous
constatons que même s'il y aura un mieux
par rapport à ce que vous avez enlevé en
2018 c'est-à-dire les maladies dans le
c-3p vous ne les avez pas remises pour
autant dans le compte pénibilité le 54
32 madame meunier
badine
à ce dialogue de sourd je rajoute les
atteintes auditives provoquées par les
bruits lésionnels mais j'ai pas envie de
sourire même de rire parce que le
contexte vient d'être rappelé il s'agit
de santé au travail et de souffrance au
travail alors les atteintes auditives
elles sont répertoriées dans un tableau
42 des maladies professionnelles très
précis je vous en fais grâce la liste
est longue beaucoup de métiers masculins
mais pas que puisque on peut lire aussi
que dans les travaux qui sont de
l'industrie agroalimentaire la battage
et les
viscérations des volailles des pores et
des bovins le plumage des volailles je
connais moi des femmes qui travaillent
en Loire-Atlantique dans ce genre
d'industrie l'emboîtage des conserves
alimentaires ça ça peut aussi être
concerné par les sardinières de Vendée
que un collègue connaît bien ici donc ce
diagnostic s'avère pas à réaliser mais
il est totalement invalidant c'est une
vraie réalité que c'est pertes et ses
atteintes auditives que nous rajoutons à
la liste bien la vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur sur l'ensemble
bien compris mais bon
l'amendement il porte sur la prévention
des pathologies affections psychique en
lien avec les syndromes d'épuisement
professionnel voyez-vous je suis pas sûr
que le concert de la prostate etc soit
inclus effectivement là-dedans alors
vous vous
se font de prévention c'est pour les
soignants vous voyez c'est pas pour les
soigner
c'est pas pour les malades c'est pour
les soignants d'accord c'est la raison
pour laquelle je vois pas bien cette
liste dans le cadre des sous amendements
d'un tas de pathologies et il en manque
énormément le sujet est inépuisable mais
c'est pas celui qui a l'ordre du jour
donc avis défavorable gouvernement
défavorable pour deux raisons monsieur
le Président la première c'est que les
risques psychosociaux évoqués par
l'amendement
pourront être intégrés puisque l'article
9 a une rédaction suffisamment large
pour pouvoir tenir compte de la mission
sur ce sujet là pour les sous
amendements il y a toujours une risque
de compétences à contrario quand on
commence à lister avec le risque
d'oublier donc des favorable sur
l'ensemble si nous allons passer
maintenant à l'examen de l'amendement
33-47 madame ponce
merci monsieur le président
commandement vise à prendre en
considération l'ensemble des facteurs de
risque professionnels ou du moins une
majorité si jamais totalement exhaustif
des facteurs de risque professionnels et
d'élargir donc ceux qui déjà donne que
sont des critères d'accès au Fonds
professionnels mentionnés dès à présent
dans le code du travail à savoir
l'environnement physique agressif je
rappelle agent chimique poussière fumée
activité exercée en milieu hyperbare
température extrême bruit ainsi que
certains rythmes de travail le travail
de nuit le travail en équipe successives
alternante et le travail répétitif les
mesures de prévention doivent concerner
l'ensemble des métiers qui sont
concernés par les risques professionnels
existants il n'y a aucune justification
aujourd'hui à délaisser un certain
nombre de métiers les facteurs de risque
professionnel qu'est-ce que c'est les
facteurs de risque professionnels sont
des situations de travail des situations
de travail qui peuvent nuire à la santé
physique ou mentale des travailleurs
donc on est bien dans le lien santé et
travail ces facteurs peuvent être
présents dans différents secteurs
d'activités et peuvent avoir des
conséquences graves sur la santé des
travailleurs allant des maladies
chroniques problématiques majeures de
santé de notre siècle à des accidents de
travail il est donc de la responsabilité
de gouvernement de prendre des mesures
pour prévenir et gérer ces risques
professionnels et d'essayer d'élargir
d'étendre voir d'essayer d'aller vers le
de prendre en compte tous les facteurs
de risque professionnels je vous
remercie alors l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
soyez rassurés madame Raymond poncelon
je l'ensemble des facteurs de risque
professionnels sont pris en compte dans
le cas de ce fond destiné aux hôpitaux
aux établissements médico-sociaux donc
l'amendement est satisfait merci de le
retirer
il est retiré
alors
l'amendement 3528 monsieur benaroche
ciel président donc la prévention des
risques professionnels est une
obligation légale on vient de le
rappeler le code du travail oblige les
employeurs à identifier les facteurs de
risques professionnels présents dans
leur entreprise et apprendre les mesures
nécessaires pour les prévenir
en tant que garant de la sécurité de la
santé des travailleurs le gouvernement a
donc le devoir de faire respecter cette
obligation légale il doit donc mettre en
place des outils de prévention des
campagnes de sensibilisation ainsi que
des contrôles pour s'assurer que les
employeurs respectent des obligations
légales la gestion des risques
professionnels est également et surtout
d'ailleurs une question de justice et de
justice sociale pourquoi parce que les
travailleurs qui sont les plus
vulnérables alors on peut en citer
quelques-uns les précaires les migrants
les femmes et les personnes en situation
de handicap sont souvent plus exposées
aux risques professionnels et en moins
accès aux ressources pour les prévenir
et les gérer
c'est pour ça que dans la médecine du
travail je permettrai de rappeler tout à
l'heure on en a parlé que le médecin du
travail il a également un rôle très
souvent d'être le seul médecin que voit
un salarié il ne voit aucun autre
médecin et donc dans la détection d'un
certain nombre de maladies même si elle
ne sort pas professionnels ça échappe un
peu aux champs de la loi mais il joue un
rôle essentiel
ce sort par ailleurs
LVE c'est à dire ces travailleurs
précaires que vous allez encore plus
précariser avec cette loi en les mettant
dans un sas de précarité après une vie
entière de labeur dans des conditions
difficiles je vous rappelle donc
monsieur le ministre qu'il est de votre
responsabilité et de celle de votre
gouvernement de garantir que ces
travailleurs bénéficient de la même
protection que les autres travailleurs
et qu'ils aient accès au même ressources
pour prévenir et gérer les risques
professionnels notamment d'ailleurs au
rétablissement au rétablissant les
quatre critères de pénibilité que vous
avez supprimé et dont il sort les
premières victimes
alors monsieur le rapporteur la vie sur
cet amendement que monsieur benaro vient
de présenter
négatif défavorable excusez-moi monsieur
identique
alors un amendement de 35 26 madame
poncemonge
merci monsieur le président
amendement visa associé les partenaires
sociaux à travers des négociations
consultation et négociation elle a
création des actions de sensibilisation
et de prévention à l'usure
professionnelle en appliquant les
organisations syndicales dans les
actions de prévention de la pénibilité
au travail il est possible d'assurer une
meilleure prise en compte des besoins
des préoccupations et des préoccupations
des travailleurs dans les politiques de
prévention c'est aussi un accès plus
direct à ce qu'on appelle le travail
concret à la différence du travail
abstrait souvent des employeurs les
salariés peuvent ainsi faire entendre
leur voix pour défendre les droits des
travailleurs et pour faire avancer les
politiques de prévention comme c'était
hier l'objet des CHSCT que vous avez
supprimés l'implication des syndicats
dans les actions de prévention de la
pénibilité au travail est essentielle
fondamentale je dirais même pour
garantir une bonne prise en compte
effective des besoins des travailleurs
sensibiliser les travailleurs aux
risques liés à la pénibilité au travail
et contribuer à l'élaboration de
politiques de prévention aussi d'assurer
une mise en oeuvre effective des mesures
de prévention et donc important de
reconnaître le rôle des syndicats dans
la protection de la santé et de la
sécurité des travailleurs et de les
appliquer de les impliquer activement
dans les actions de prévention de la
pénibilité du travail au travail pardon
alors la vie de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
défavorable
la vie du gouvernement
un amendement 3821 madame Cohen le
présente
que nous discutons de l'impact de cette
réforme sur les femmes et nous
souhaitons ici qu'un vrai travail de
réflexion soit mené quant à la
pénibilité particulière est souvent
ignorée des métiers disséminins je pense
notamment à ceux du soin et du lien où
les femmes sont largement majoritaires
je pense aussi aux personnel de la
propreté qui sont venus manifester hier
devant le Sénat on le sait partant du
postulat évidemment faux que les
qualités naturelles des femmes leur
permettent d'exercer dans ces métiers
ces professions sont souvent très peu
reconnus du fait d'un manque de
qualification la dimension pénibilité
est très largement minorée absente et
pourtant elle existe vraiment dans ses
métiers lorsque les travailleurs et
travailleuses du soin et du lien sont
interrogés elle est ils font état de
contraintes physiques fortes liées au
port notamment des patients
malheureusement ce critère n'est pas
pris en compte pour définir la
pénibilité
or on sait très bien que ce geste répété
comme soulevé ou déplacer des corps de
50 60 70 kg voire 80 voire même plus
abîme celui des soignantes et des
soignants le taux d'accident du travail
dans les services d'aide à la personne
s'élève à 5,2 % quand la moyenne
ailleurs est de 3,8 %, surtout le taux
de fréquence est supérieur à 36% et le
taux de gravité de 64% monsieur le
ministre doit je vous rappeler que
l'espérance de vie d'une infirmière est
de 6 ans inférieur à la moyenne des
femmes 20% des infirmières et 30% des
aides-soignantes partent à la retraite
en incapacité à cette pénibilité
physique on peut aussi ajouter la charge
émotionnelle ressentie par ses
professionnels face à la souffrance à la
détresse de leur patient ou des
personnes qu'elles accompagnent je crois
qu'on peut tout et tous ici penser aux
aides à domicile qui travaillent auprès
de personnes âgées ou handicapées et qui
sont confrontés à leurs difficultés
quotidiennes une étude de vous Arès
reconnaît les riches psychosociaux de
ces métiers les infirmières assistantes
sociales auxiliaires de vie connaissent
aussi les taux les plus importants de
dépression et d'épuisement professionnel
ce n'est pas un hasard je vous remercie
la vie de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur merci d'avoir effectivement
reprisé c'est important les difficultés
par ces personnes le font s'adresse aux
hôpitaux aux établissements
médico-sociaux qui sont déjà largement
féminisés et donc nous pensions que la
création se font on va témoigner
justement du processus de revalorisation
et de reconnaissance de ces métiers et
le mérite
c'est une demande de retrait donc
défavorable ce n'était pas le cas pour
les mêmes raisons j'ajoute qu'on a notre
chantier à ouvrir sur les métiers du
soin puisque selon qu'on est soyons
infirmiers à l'hôpital public dans une
collectivité locale je pense notamment
aux EHPAD ou dans le secteur privé les
conditions d'accès de protection sont
radicalement différentes ce qui n'est
pas justifié mais ça c'est un chantier
sur le métier en général qui relève de
mon collègue 1900
terminé avec l'article 9 mais je vais
donner la parole pour rappel au
règlement monsieur Fabien gay
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
sur l'article 42 excusez-moi et aussi la
sincérité de nos débats